kritik an
reform des strafrechts paragrafen 219
gibt es noch immer und darüber spricht
mein kollege erhard scherfer jetzt mit
seinen gästen in berlin
da sind wir leider noch nicht ganz
vollständig bei dieser runde aber das
wird sich hoffentlich in den nächsten
minuten noch ändern ja wir haben ein
thema gewählt heute morgen hier auf der
plenarsaal ebene des deutschen
bundestages das ja gestern schon
entschieden worden ist was wir
eigentlich eher selten machen dann
normalerweise reden wir über themen die
vor einer entscheidung stehen aber weil
die ergänzung des paares strafgesetzbuch
paragrafen 219 erstes mal in relativ
kurzer zeit hier behandelt worden ist im
parlament in gerade mal acht tagen
anfang dieser woche ist die anhörung
dazu gewesen
daneben gestern am sehr späten
nachmittag eigentlich am frühen abend
dann noch einmal eine relativ knapp
bemessene debatte und daneben auch die
entscheidung einmal gedacht da sind so
viele fragen noch offen
das sollten wir vielleicht noch mal
thematisieren und das eine und andere
nachfragen im moment kamen wir nur die
seite bei uns die das ganze kritisch
sieht das stimmt nämlich gar nicht jetzt
sind wir nämlich komplett und jetzt
bauen wir mal vor laufender kamera um
und dann stelle ich auch meine gäste
kurz noch mal vollgas
elisabeth winkelmeier becker ist da
rechts und verbraucherschutzpolitische
sprecherin der unionsfraktion war und
ist eigentlich gegen eine ergänzung des
219 all gewesen wenn ich es richtig in
erinnerung habe können sie auch gleich
noch einmal erläutern und katja dörner
ist bei uns war und ist für die
abschaffung dieses paragraphen insgesamt
und deswegen ich hab gerade schon gesagt
das ging alles so schnell in dieser
woche mit diesem mit diesem paragraphen
dass wir das jetzt noch mal nach
besprechen weil einfach viele fragen
offen sind und deswegen mal gleich am
anfang frau winkelmeier-becker wem nützt
dieser kompromiss außer der koalition
wie manche sagen als in der zeit es ist
ein kompromiss für den sie auch beide
seiten wirklich bewegen mussten also
beide haben maximal positionen
aufgegeben
deshalb finde ich das zunächst auch gut
dass wir diesen kompromiss gefunden
haben wir haben darin zwei anliegen
aufgegriffen die ja nicht unplausibel
sind und zwar aus dem blickwinkel der
frauen dass sie jetzt genau wissen wo
finde ich erstens solide fundierte
medizinische informationen und wo finde
ich auch dann die adressen derjenigen
bei denen man einen abbruch machen kann
und aus dem blickwinkel der ärzte ist
jetzt eben auch eine sicherheit gegeben
dass man zumindest über die tatsache
dass in der eigenen praxis abbrüche
durchgeführt werden informiert werden
kann und das waren zwei anliegen die die
ganze debatte hat durchzogen haben darum
sollte es gehen und genau das haben wir
dann auch sehr zielgerichtet
aufgegriffen und ich denke in einer art
und weise auch gelöst
die keinen zweifel lässt er's im kern
das werbeverbot erhalten bleibt das war
uns sehr wichtig aber eben diese zwei
gezielten punkte doch gelöst werden
konnten
frau winkelmeier becker hat das jetzt
ausgeführt was verändert worden ist und
in der tat ist doch auch die frage dass
die möglichkeit dass man sich eben dass
ärztinnen und ärzte und kliniken jetzt
sagen können ja wir nehmen
schwangerschafts abbrüche vorher ohne
dass sie strafen befürchten wir sind ist
doch auch tatsächlichen fortschritt im
vergleich zu der lösung die es vorher
gegeben hat oder nicht
also insgesamt ist das aus unserer sicht
ein komplett verquerer kompromiss frauen
haben weiterhin kein umfassendes
informationsrecht die ärztinnen und
ärzte dürfen zwar sagen sie führen ab
rutsche durch schon schritt nach vorne
oder es ist ein mini schritt ja aber es
ist halt weiterhin keine wirkliche
rechtssicherheit für die ärztinnen das
ist ja in der anhörung am montag auch
sehr deutlich gesagt worden
sie dürfen sagen sie führen abbrüche
durch aber beispielsweise nicht wie und
mit welchen methoden sie die durchführen
es ist völlig absurd wenn ärztinnen und
ärzte auf die methoden hinweisen
sachlich und informativ auf ihrer
internetseite beispielsweise dann wird
das strafrechtlich belangt während
staatlicherseits beispielsweise überall
die bundeszentrale für gesundheitliche
aufklärung die gleichen informationen im
internet völlig straffrei und
unproblematisch zur verfügung gestellt
werden können und das zeigt ja schon wie
absurd und verquer dieser kompromiss
gestrickt ist und insbesondere das
informationsrecht von frauen wird nicht
so wahrgenommen und wird nicht so
bestärkt wie wir das für sinnvoll
gehalten hätten wäre in der tat auch
meine nächste frage gewesen aber bevor
ich sie in stereo beziehungsweise wie
werthaltig wird sie gerne noch ein
bisschen sortieren wenn sie noch ein
kleines bisschen nachlegen und sieben
stückchen vorerst nimmt wie alle viel
besser im licht und die leute im ü-wagen
und auch zu hause vor den fernsehschirm
können sie viel besser sehen
also dass katja dörner gesagt hat auf
der einen seite information nicht
strafbar wenn man sie da abruft aber
wenn man sie auf der seite von ärzten
ärzten kliniken abruf sind sie auf
einmal strafbar das macht in der tat
keinen sinn wie erklären sie diesen
widerspruch
es geht immer noch um die unterscheidung
zwischen denen die informieren wollen
das darf jeder das darf auch bisher
jeder sie finden auch bisher fundierte
information zum beispiel auch wikipedia
bei krankenkassen bei der bundeszentrale
für gesundheitliche aufklärung kurzer
einwand warum kurz sagen warum ich bei
denen dies machen und die eigentlich
auch wissen was da passiert also eben
ärztinnen ärzte kliniken warum dann
nicht da weil es da dann eben immer in
verbindung mit dem angebot dann eben
doch den charakter von werbung hat in
der art und weise dass ich über das über
die information an die kundinnen an die
patientinnen herankommen will und das
ist dann eben patienten ab wieso hat das
in aller deutlichkeit das amtsgericht
gießen auch im fall von der gießener
ärztin ausgedrückt das ist der eine
punkt das ist dann eben nicht nur die
information sondern auch der schritt an
die patientin heran das ist das eine und
das andere ist worum es uns auch ging
das ist eben auch gerade eine lehre aus
diesem genannten fall dass wir eben
sicherstellen wollen dass dann nicht
eine selbst gestrickte information an
der stelle ins netz gestellt wird wo
dann zum beispiel von schwangerschafts
gewebe gesprochen wird das entspricht
nicht den medizinischen grundkenntnissen
und entspricht auch nicht dem
menschenbild was natürlich auch dahinter
steckt und dass das hier vertreten das
hat das bundesverfassungsgericht
vertritt sondern da ist eben davon
auszugehen wenn ich von anfang an und
wer von schwangerschafts gewebe dann
spricht der spricht eben menschenrechte
menschenwürde genau dem ab wie viel
werbung kann informationen stecken frau
dörner also zunächst mal die
berufsordnung der ärzte verbieten
werbung sowie so auch das zeigt dass der
219 a nicht mehr zeitgemäß und überhaupt
nicht nötig ist und abgeschafft gehört
und ich finde auch das was frau
winkelmeier becker gesagt hat zeigt ja
mit wie viel misstrauen den ärztinnen
und ärzten die ja eigentlich expertinnen
in der sache ist
seitens der koalition weiter begegnet
wird die ärztinnen und ärzte sind die
die sich da am besten auskennen und die
sollten aus unserer sicht eben wirklich
informieren dürfen wenn man ins internet
schaut ja dann sieht man ja welche
wirklich absurden informationen da von
wem auch immer eingestellt werden dürfen
das ist strafbar straffrei dass es
überhaupt kein problem aber die die
ahnung haben die dürfen nicht umfassend
informieren und das ist ja das absurde
an der ganzen diskussion das kann ich
überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen gegenrede
ja trotzdem kommt dann so etwas dabei
heraus dass eine ärztin eine information
hinein stellt in der von turnerschaft
gewebe die rede ist und das ist eben der
punkt wo es eben nicht geht und deshalb
haben wir sehr bewusst dafür gesorgt
dass dann eben nur verlinkt werden kann
ihm dann wenn es mit einem angebot
verbunden ist das dann eben nur
verwiesen werden darf auf eben fundierte
informationen der bundeszentrale für
gesundheitliche aufklärung oder der
ärztekammer
sie haben ihn sofort sie haben in einem
namensartikel im tagesspiegel ich glaube
im dezember unter anderem geschrieben
219 a sei überhaupt nicht von großer
relevanz warum halten sie dann trotzdem
so massiv daran fest ja also wir hätten
ihnen deshalb auch nicht auf die
tagesordnung gesetzt sondern er hat
seine bedeutung im sinne des schutts
konzeptes wenn ich das noch mal
ausführen darf
ausgehend von der überlegung wir haben
hier einen menschen der sich entwickelt
im mutterleib und ein paar das
lebensrecht und der staat muss ihn in
gewisser weise schützen er kann sagen
ich möchte das nicht tun indem ich die
frauen kriminalisieren sondern ich
möchte das mit der frau tun und deshalb
in einer beratung und diese beratung
wird entwertet wenn gleichzeitig eben
eine gegenläufige werbung zugelassen
wird und deshalb war dieses werbeverbot
immer mit im paket das hat die kollegin
gestern auch ausgesprochen von der von
der spd hat das noch mal alles sehr
deutlich ulla schmidt hat geredet genau
die hat es noch einmal sehr klar gemacht
dass das werbeverbot immer in allen
diskussionen um den 218 unangetastet
geblieben es war keiner daran wollte
jeder
hat den grundsatz aufrechterhalten dass
es keine werbung geben darf und das
halte ich auch für richtig
die staatsanwaltschaften gehen sehr
nachsichtig mit den ärzten um die da ein
problem haben die sich an dem die
vielleicht darüber hinaus gehen was
erlaubt war bisher in der vergangenheit
und haben gesagt so und so wäre es
richtig und dann ist es auch eingestellt
worden
deshalb gibt es nicht viele zahlen ich
weiß es gleich ein bisschen länger
antworten ich muss aber an einer stelle
ich jetzt jedoch trotzdem noch mal
intervenieren weil sie weil sich auch
von schwangerschafts gewebe gesprochen
habe und der definition von leben und
all diesen dingen die der auch eine
große rolle spielen müssen sie nicht
konsequenterweise dann in paragraph 218
ändern
der bestimmte der abbrüche unter
bestimmten bedingungen bis zu einer
bestimmten frist ja zulässt wäre das
nicht ein konsequent stadt an dieser
stelle zu bremsen oder zu verhindern
dass es weniger abbrüche gibt weil
anders kann man das ja kaum deuten
definitiv nicht also ganz klar wir
halten dieses konzept dass dieser
konflikt zwischen dem lebensrecht des
kindes und der selbstbestimmung der frau
so aufgelöst wird wie er jetzt im gesetz
steht nämlich mit einer liberalen
fristende und akzeptiert dass die frau
das entscheidet weil sich niemand an
ihrer stelle stellen kann jedenfalls
schon gar nicht mit dem strafrecht aber
der schutz für das kind muss da sein er
muss wirksam und effektiv sein sonst
haben wir ein unter maß verbot verletzt
dass das verfassungsgericht auch genannt
hat wir brauchen deshalb diese beratung
die offen und zum leben ermutigt dass
das zusammen ist das paket ich halte das
für eine sehr sehr gute lösung die im
übrigen auch ein sehr gutes frauenwelt
auch transportiert weil eben der frau
genau diese verantwortung und
selbstbestimmung eingeräumt wird
und jetzt dürfen sie das alles erwidern
was sich seit ungefähr drei minuten
heraus beobachtet winkel dringend
loswerden wollen also ich würde auch die
diskussion 219 a und 218 trennen und war
das ist ja gerade in dieser debatte von
seiten der union an vielen stellen nicht
gelungen und ich möchte noch mal sagen
es geht nicht um werbung ja beim 219 a
sondern es muss um information gehen und
ich habe mich sehr daran gestört ja das
häufig suggeriert wurde ja im bundestag
von seiten der union als würden sich
frauen durch werbung zu
schwangerschaftsabbrüchen an
um ihren lassen ja als würde der 219 a
dazu führen ja ich sag das jetzt mal
ganz zugespitzt ja zwei abbrüche zum
preis von einem
und das ist wirklich auch ein frauenbild
und ein bild mit blick auf die ärztinnen
und ärzte dass ich wirklich nicht
akzeptabel finde wir haben den zustand
dass männer ja vor allem ja so genannte
lebensschützer im internet unterwegs
sind und sich einen spaß daraus machen
ärztinnen zu finden ja die abbrüche
vornehmen und dafür auf ihrer
internetseite auch hingewiesen haben um
die dann an zu zeigen und wir haben
diese krassen verfahren die ja auch in
erster instanz mit verurteilungen
beendet sind und das zeigt eben dass wir
ganz dringenden änderungsbedarf hatten
beim 219 a und wenn man sich dieses
konstrukt anschaut dann sieht man er ist
überflüssig ja weil werbung bei ärzten
werbung sowieso verboten ist und das
finde ich auch richtig aber das immer zu
vermischen und so zu tun als würde von
den ärztinnen für abbrüche geworben das
finde ich eigentlich völlig unzulässig
und das hat auch diese debatte vergiftet
und deshalb bin ich der meinung wir
müssen weiter uns dafür engagieren dass
der 219 abgeschafft gehört der gehört
nicht mehr in unsere zeit und ist
wirklich eine misstrauenserklärung an
das selbstbestimmungsrecht von frauen
ich glaube ich möchte noch gerne
ergänzen dass der 208 s 218 ist
natürlich von den demonstrantinnen immer
wieder hoch gehalten worden also dass
der in das gesamtpaket gehört oder das
jedenfalls das nicht voneinander
getrennt diskutiert werden kann
das spricht schon einiges für aber die
frage ob man an 218 dran soll die ist
von der anderen seite gestellt weil
jetzt haben sie mich da gerade gefragt
von unserer seite ist er überhaupt nicht
infrage gestellt worden sondern wirklich
von der anderen seite und da kommt
natürlich auch zum zum ausdruck dass der
allererste frage hier unterschiedlich
beantwortet wissen das ist nicht der
blick auf die frau die sehen wir auch in
großer verantwortung auf
selbstbestimmung sondern der blick auf
das kind ist das was uns unterscheidet
und wenn man natürlich sagt das ist nur
ein einzel haufen dann kann man
natürlich keinen 218 ertragen kann auch
keinen 219 ertragen aber da ist eben
ganz definitiv unserer
eine andere also das ist definitiv nicht
der fall sondern es ist aus unserer
sicht wirklich der blick auf die frau wo
der unterschied ist ja ob man wirklich
sagt die frau kann entscheiden und die
frau lässt sich beispielsweise nicht
durch informationen auf internetseiten
zu schwangerschaftsabbrüchen motivieren
sie haben das selber naja sind das
selber indem plenardebatten quasi die so
dargestellt und das 219 art deshalb
erhalten bleiben muss ja und da ist der
große unterschied ja dass wir sagen
natürlich sollen frauen sich so
umfassend und so gut und auf dem wege
wie sie das wollen ja informieren können
und da machen sie eben weiter
restriktionen und das ist der
unterschied in dieser debatte und die
ärztinnen und ärzte sollen nicht weiter
mit einem fuß im knast stehen weil wir
weiterhin regelung haben die sie darin
limitieren ja auch dem was eigentlich ja
ihrem berufsverständnis entspricht ja
ihre potenziellen patientinnen und
patienten umfassend beraten zu können
das nicht machen zu können das ist ja
beispielsweise in der anhörung auch sehr
deutlich geworden ob das nicht
tatsächlich auch eine nicht akzeptable
rechtlich nicht akzeptable einschnitt in
die berufsfreiheit der ärztinnen und
ärzte ist dieses thema wird uns weiter
beschäftigen so habe ich zumindest die
kolleginnen und kollegen verstanden und
deshalb kann ich das überhaupt nicht
akzeptieren dass sie jetzt sozusagen im
zusammenhang mit 218 a so tun als wäre
ungeborenes leben den anderen fraktionen
in diesem hause nichts wert diesen punkt
werden wir wahrscheinlich ihr überhaupt
gar nicht gar nicht kriegen da bin ich
relativ sicher und wahrscheinlich auch
in der ganzen stunde nicht guckt ein
bisschen nach vorne die fdp hat
zumindest vor der entscheidung darüber
nachgedacht ob man normenkontrollantrag
stellt beim bundesverfassungsgericht um
zu überprüfen ob das was gestern
verabschiedet worden ist überhaupt
verfassungsgemäß und verfassungskonform
ist sie sind die richterin auch wie für
wie verfassungskonform halten sie das
was da gestern verabschiedet wurde dafür
sehr verfassungskonformen die fdp kann
natürlich ihre rechte wahrnehmen und
etwas zur prüfung stellen wie sie das
will aber wir haben ja auch etliche
verfassungsgerichts entscheidungen zu
dem gesamten komplex unter
sehe ich dass dieser kompromiss sich da
doch drin bewegt wie gesagt wir haben
gerade vom verfassungsgericht
hergeleitet dieser dieses dieses
konstrukt einer liberalen fristenlösung
in verbindung mit der unterstützenden
und ermutigenden beratung an dem halten
wir fest und es ist weiterhin auch
abgesichert durch den grundsatz des
werbeverbots der artikel 12 auf denen
sich die ärzte berufen spielt in diesem
dieser abwägung noch eine sehr
untergeordnete rolle das haben auch die
beiden gerichte sehr zutreffend
dargestellt im gießener fall und das hat
auch ganz ganz klar die anhörung noch
mal ergeben und das liegt auch auf der
hand
im übrigen wären ja auch über
werbeverbote an anderer stelle zum
beispiel auch aktuell im bereich
tabakwerbung und dergleichen da habe ich
noch nie gehört dass sich die grünen
jetzt dann in die bresche werfen für
artikel 12 derjenigen die ihre produkte
herstellen
[Gelächter]
beim gießen beim gießen der fall müssen
jetzt mal abwarten was die was die
berufungsinstanzen oder die die folge
instanzen da noch entscheiden ganz gut
zum abschluss das was ich eben
angesprochen habe ein
normenkontrollantrag jetzt bräuchte 25
prozent hier im parlament würden sie
mitmachen
also wir prüfen das und wir sind weiter
mit der fdp im gespräch
und wenn wir da möglichkeiten sehen dann
kann ich mir gut vorstellen dass die
grüne fraktion sich dem auch anschließt
wir haben das aber noch nicht
entschieden und auch noch nicht intensiv
beraten
die debatte wird weitergehen da bin ich
ziemlich sicher weil das ist dann so
konträres feld wo man sehr
unterschiedliche ansätze haben kann und
da sehr unterschiedliche schwerpunkte
setzen kann wir haben heute morgen
wieder gesehen und gehört danke dass sie
da gewesen sind und denke dass sie das
so kontrovers diskutiert haben elisabeth
winkelmeier becker und katharina auch
ihnen vielen dank ich habe schon gesehen
dass die bundestags-vizepräsidentin
claudia roth angekommen ist sein ihren
platz und deswegen gebe ich jetzt fix
mal rang elf märz auf donnerstag den
siebten märz 2009 10 um 10 uhr zu
verlegen
sie sind damit sicher einverstanden hier
kein widerspruch dann ist das so
beschlossen
ich rufe auf den tagesordnungspunkt 25
beratung des rahmenprogramms
gesundheitsforschung der bundesregierung
nach interfraktionell vereinbarung ist
sind für die aussprache 38 minuten
vorgesehen auch dazu höre ich keinen
widerspruch dann ist es so beschlossen
und das wort hat die bundesministerin
anja karliczek politik sie haben das
wort liebe frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten kolleginnen und kollegen meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren
deutschland hat einen guten ruf hier
gibt es exzellente ärzte und
pflegekräfte hier gibt es wirksame
therapien und medikamente gibt es
herausragende forschende und hier gibt
es eine bundesregierung die gerade auch
in die gesundheitsforschung nochmal
weiter investieren will und sie
vorantreiben will
denn gesundheit das wichtigste was wir
in unserem leben haben und mit diesen
gedanken im hinterkopf haben wir unser
neues rahmenprogramm
gesundheitsforschung aufgelegt
deutschland muss in der
gesundheitsforschung international
spitze sein
das sind wir den menschen in unserem
land schuldig dabei ist eine exzellente
behandlung des einer im besten fall
können wir sogar krankheiten verhindern
beispiel krebs wir haben gerade die
nationale dekade gegen krebs gestartet
zehn jahre lang mobilisieren wir alle
kräfte um krebs besser zu verstehen und
krebs zu verhindern und um krebs zu
heilen und ich bin sicher wir werden in
den nächsten zehn jahren große schritte
nach vorne machen
aber nicht nur im kampf gegen den krebs
auch wenn das in deutschland die
gefürchtete krankheit ist die häufigsten
todesfälle verursachen in deutschland
herz-kreislauf-erkrankungen oder auch
millionen patienten leiden an
stoffwechsel
infektionskrankheiten gleichzeitig
breiten sich antibiotikaresistenzen aus
all dies haben wir im blick wenn wir die
anstrengungen in der
gesundheitsforschung weiter verstärken
wollen unser grundprinzip
wir nutzen alle ressourcen auch und
gerade die neuen technischen
möglichkeiten wie er fünf wir binden die
patienten in die forschung an
und das ist nicht weniger als ein
paradigmenwechsel nicht über
patientinnen und patienten zu forschen
sondern mit ihnen auch die angehörigen
die hausärzte und die pflegekräfte
werden von anfang an in die forschung
eingebunden
denn wie ein mensch seine krankheit
erlebt wie er therapien verträgt das ist
nicht nur für den einzelnen wichtig
diese erfahrung können auch forschung
voranbringen und damit das gelingt
bringen wir zweitens forschende ärzte
und patienten zusammen
und dafür haben wir in unserem land die
deutschen zentren der
gesundheitsforschung gegründet
die bestehenden zentren werden wir in
den kommenden jahren weiter ausbauen
in zukunft werden wir aber noch weitere
schwerpunkte setzen
der erste ist kinder- und jugendmedizin
kinder und jugendliche sind keine
kleinen erwachsenen die man einfach mit
einer geringeren medikamentendosis
bahnen kann und deswegen brauchen wir
hier gezielte forschung und damit eben
auch ein neues forschungszentrum für
kinder und jugendgesundheit
zweitens nehmen leider auch die
psychischen krankheiten zu und auch hier
gilt es die ursachen besser zu
erforschen
nur wenn wir die ursachen kennen können
wir auch mehr dagegen tun und deshalb
errichten wir auch ein deutsches zentrum
für psychische gesundheit
[Applaus]
die gesundheitszentren sind auch für den
dritten punkt entscheidend neue
therapien schneller raus aus dem labor
ran an das krankenbett zu bringen denn
gesundheitsforschung nutzt den menschen
nur dann wenn sie bei ihnen ankommt
deswegen wollen wir in der nationalen
dekade gegen krebs beispielsweise
mindestens vier weitere standorte des
nationalen centrums für
tumorerkrankungen errichten
und hier setzt sich auf ihre
unterstützung liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen 40 wir nutzen neue technologien
neue molekularbiologische methoden die
digitalisierung die künstliche
intelligenz technologien die ganz neue
behandlungsmethoden ermöglichen
individuell für jeden einzelnen
das ist eine riesenchance und wir werden
sie nutzen
[Musik]
fünftens schauen über den tellerrand
hinaus unsere forschung leistet auch
einen gewichtigen beitrag für menschen
in entwicklungsländern ebola ist uns
allen doch noch ein warnendes beispiel
wir dürfen nicht einfach zusehen dass
menschen an infektionskrankheiten wie
ebola sterben wenn wir das verhindern
können
wir brauchen dringend neue medikamente
impfstoffe und diagnoseverfahren und sie
müssen auch unter den besonderen
bedingungen in entwicklungsländern
einsetzbar sein
wir forschen gemeinsam mit den
betroffenen ländern und verbessern die
medizinische versorgung vor ort auch das
gehört zu unserer verantwortung
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen fast
täglich lesen wir in der zeitung über
neue ansätze für therapien gegen krebs
gegen alzheimer
auch gegen seltene erkrankungen wie zum
beispiel mukoviszidose jeder fortschritt
im kampf gegen diese heimtückischen
krankheiten ist ein schritt zu einem
besseren leben und das zeigt wie wichtig
es ist dass wir auch zukünftig weiter
intensiv in die gesundheitsforschung
investieren
unser neues rahmenprogramm nimmt die
neuen möglichkeiten des technologischen
fortschritts auf wir stellen den
menschen in den mittelpunkt und treiben
personalisierte und digitalisierte
forschung voran 2,5 milliarden euro
stecken wir als und pro jahr in die
gesundheitsforschung und allein aus
meinem haus kommen davon zwei milliarden
euro
zwei milliarden euro
die wir institutionelle oder durch
förderprogramme in die
gesundheitsforschung stecken
wir machen in meinem haus nicht viele
gesetze aber dafür umso mehr
segensreiche förderprogramme damit wir
auch in der gesundheitsforschung
international weiter mit an der spitze
stehen denn fortschritt für die
gesundheit der menschen in deutschland
das ist unser gemeinsames ziel ja soweit
also die bundesministerin für bildung
und forschung anja karliczek hier zum
ersten tagesordnungspunkt im deutschen
bundestag es geht um die förderung der
gesundheitsforschung und dazu spricht
jetzt auch coach fleming aus der fdp
fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren sehr geehrte
frau ministerin vielen dank für diesen
bericht er wurde im november 2008 10 und
schon zugeleitet das weise ausreichend
zeit sich damit zu beschäftigen heute
debattieren wir darüber so ist das gut
gestern allerdings hat der bundestag im
eilverfahren über mehrere
grundgesetzänderungen abgestimmt
abgestimmt die er so in dieser form noch
nie gesehen hat und die erst am abend
zuvor zugeleitet worden sind meine damen
und herren
wundern sie sich bitte nicht wundern sie
sich bitte nicht die wahre lehre
erlauben sie eine 2 nicht möchte
beschlossen zu ende führen wundern sie
sich bitte nicht wundern sie sich bitte
nicht wie bei herr kollege dass die
bürger da draußen und ich mache mir die
formulierung nicht zu eigen haben die
bürger draußen verwenden inzwischen das
wort einer demokratie inszenierung und
genau das haben sie gestern getan
so würden sie bitte zum thema der
debatte kinder einleitung des gerichtes
der bundesregierung heißt es unter der
sie beruhigen sie sich sie müssen sich
das anhören heißt es unter der viel
versprechenden überschrift unsere
mission
ich zitiere ich zitiere aus dem bericht
zum thema scheinbar habe ich einen
wunden punkt
jetzt hat sie nur fremming das wort und
ich bitte sie zum thema das in der
debatte zu reden und vor der zeit dazu
zum thema
so noch einmal bitte liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen herr doktor frömming hat
jetzt das wort und es geht um ein
bestimmtes thema und ich bitte sie dazu
zu reden ist das komme gerne jetzt dazu
wenn ich da einleiten heißt es im
bericht der bundesregierung zur
gesundheitsforschung ich zitiere wir
werden den standort deutschland in der
gesundheitsforschung an die
internationale spitze führen
das klingt ja erst einmal gut meine
damen und herren es bedeutet im
umkehrschluss aber auch dass deutschland
derzeit nicht zur internationalen spitze
gehört wenn man sich die internationalen
rankings zu den weltweit besten
universitäten im bereich der
medizinischen forschung anschaut dann
tauchen die ersten deutschen
universitäten je nach den gewählten
indikatoren erst ab platz 40 oder noch
später auf meine damen und herren das
war einmal anders und das muss auch
wieder anders werden
der hinweis der hinweis der an dieser
stelle dann oft kommt ja wir haben doch
unsere forschungszentren wie max planck
und andere ist hier ein oft bemühte aber
eben auch nur schwacher trost
lassen sie mich an dieser stelle kurz
berichten von einer delegationsreise die
wir mit dem ausschuss gemacht haben an
das match das ist das größte
amerikanische zentrum zur
gesundheitsforschung dort hatten wir ein
gespräch mit dem vize präsidentin der
sich bei uns dafür bedankte dass wir ihm
so viele gute doktoranten schicken die
dort arbeiten hoch ausgebildet und
professionell sind aber sie bleiben in
der regel da und die jungen leute haben
uns gefragt was tut ihr denn dass wir
wieder zurückkommen können und wir
konnten ihnen leider nicht viel sagen da
wir derzeit hier hauptsächlich eine
einbahnstraße haben und wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass aus dieser einbahnstraße den
vielgerühmten brain drain eine
beidseitige richtung wieder wird das
heißt also dass auch zu uns gute leute
zurückkommen die stichworte hierzu sind
im programm genannt forschungsförderung
innovationsförderung und
strukturförderung dazu die förderung des
wissenschaftlichen nachwuchses und die
etablierung attraktiver karrierewege
insofern richtet sich das gesundheits
forschungsprogramm
auch an die länder denn sein erfolg
hängt in nicht geringem maße davon ab
wie die länder ihre hochschulen in
position bringen einen hochschulpakt für
die jahre nach 2020 ist er in aussicht
gestellt aber über seine zielrichtung
finanzierung wird noch gestritten
sowohl an den universitäten als auch an
den außeruniversitären
forschungseinrichtungen gibt es für
nachwuchsforscher eine hohe zahl von
befristeten stellen mit oftmals sehr
kurzen befristung zeiten
das ist ein grundsätzliches problem
meine damen und herren das auch damit zu
tun hat dass diese einrichtung oftmals
nicht wissen ob die ihnen von uns
befristet gewährten projektmittel auch
noch ein zweites oder drittes mal
bewilligt werden und sie werden in kürze
feststellen durch die gestrigen
beschlüsse wird sich dieses phänomen
jetzt auch noch auf die schulen
verlagern
wir werden dann sehen dass auch dort nur
befristete verträge vergeben werden
können für systemadministratoren und so
weiter die dann aber nicht wissen ob sie
diesen arbeitsplatz behalten können weil
die länder selbstverständlich hier keine
dauerhaften zumacht zusagen machen
können
die bundesregierung muss sich insgesamt
fragen lassen wie glaubwürdig ihr
programm ist haben nicht die
koalitionsparteien und auch die fdp in
den vielen jahren ihre jeweiligen
regierungsbeteiligung genau das
gegenteil von dem getan was sie hier
versprechen etwa bei den karrierewegen
ich höre ja die botschaft sehr gerne
aber man fragt sich schon warum all die
vielen guten absichtserklärung die sich
hier drin finden warum die nicht schon
viel früher angegangen worden sind
lassen sie mich abschließend feststellen
die guten ansätze dieses programms sind
eine echte herausforderung an alle
mitspieler universitäten und
forschungseinrichtungen bund und länder
wenn jeder der mitspieler sich auf seine
stärken und aufgaben sind meine damen
und herren dann kann es gelingen ich
schließe mit einem schönen arabische
sprichwort wer gesund ist hat hoffnung
und ver di hat hat alles hindern
kürzlich war das für die fdp-fraktion
und man muss glaube ich noch mal kurz
was sagen zu sein eingangs bemerkungen
kurzfilmen hat ja auch gestern schon
der vermeintliche nichtbeteiligung des
parlaments und der abgeordneten
angeprangert gleichwohl war natürlich
auch die afg fraktion im
vermittlungsausschuss zum digital packt
vertreten hat da aber wert darauf gelegt
so schildert es ist übrigens alle
anderen fraktionen inhaltlich nicht mehr
zu diskutieren dann hat man gestern
reklamiert dass das ganze angeblich an
der afg vorbeigegangen sei oder am
parlament oder das ist glaube ich nur
bedingt haltbar diese these jetzt rené
was wir für die spd-fraktion der da auch
noch einmal bezug darauf nimmt im
bundesrat
das verfassungsorgan
vermittlungsausschuss ausschuss hat
gestern die entscheidung getroffen dass
hier darüber abgestimmt wird und sie
haben diese entscheidung mitgetragen
übrigen so stellen sich hierhin und
kritisieren das als undemokratisch alle
bürgerinnen alle bürgerinnen sind
aufgerufen sich das in der mediathek des
bundestags festlegen will sie trotzdem
bitten bank gesundheitsforscher davon da
nur reagieren und das wirklich als
propaganda zu entlarven und sie haben
übrigens dagegen gestimmt dass schulen
besser ausgestattet werden als einzige
fraktion gesundheitsforschung viele
menschen stellen sich vor dass
gesundheitsforschung das ist dass da
jemand im labor sitz und an der pille
gegen eine krankheit arbeit und
tatsächlich diese biomedizinische
forschung immer noch der zentrale teil
unseres fortschritts das macht meistens
spaß wenn man erfolg hat häufig ist es
lange jahre mühe weiter zu kommen und
das ist es gut dass wir als
bundesrepublik deutschland mit allen
unseren forschungsgeldern
grundlagenforschung und biomedizinische
forschung auch über dieses
rahmenprogramm weiterfinanzieren
unterstützen
aber wir sind sehr froh dass ich dieses
rahmenprogramm gesundheitsforschung auch
weiterentwickelt hat es geht nicht mehr
nur darum therapien und diagnosen
biomedizinische zu entwickeln sondern
einen großen teilen dem mittlerweile das
programm die prävention aus ein nämlich
wie lassen sich krankheiten von
vornherein verhindern und das ist einer
der wichtigsten punkte die man
tatsächlich auch erforschen muss wie
lassen sich krankheiten überhaupt
verhindern bevor man sie dann eben
bekämpfen muss und ich bin sehr froh
auch im programm zu finden das
einbezogen ausdrücklich ist die
die ursachen und die bedingungen die
umweltbedingungen aber auch die sozialen
bedingungen zu erforschen unter denen
krankheit entsteht und der kollege karl
lauterbach hat lange jahre immer wieder
darauf hingewiesen auf den immer noch
existierenden zusammenhang zwischen
armut und krankheit wir sehen eben dass
arme menschen das in sozial schwachen
stadtteilen krankheit viel verbreiteter
ist als in wohlhabenden und das ist ein
problem dessen wir uns annehmen müssen
und dass wir als gesellschaft eben auch
beantworten und wir als sozialdemokraten
sowieso beantworten müssen und wollen
damit diejenigen die arm sind eben nicht
stärker krank werden und dann findet man
in die tiefe gehend projekte die sich
damit befassen und mit der körperlichen
und psychischen situation von kindern
das ist genau richtig zu gucken welche
umgebung gibt es was müssen wir
tatsächlich tun und nicht nur pillen
geben bis hin eben zu projekten wo es
darum geht eben alleinerziehende zu
unterstützen und gesund erhalten
maßnahmen ihnen angedeihen zu lassen
weil das eine große aufgabe ist und wir
sehen dass viele alleinerziehende in
armut und krankheit rutschen und
deswegen ist gesundheitsforschung eben
auch dass nicht nur pillen zu entwickeln
sondern sich um die ursachen zu kümmern
wir haben über das rahmenprogramm in den
letzten jahren auch strukturen verändert
das sind deutsche zentren für
gesundheitsforschung auf den weg
gebracht worden die vernetzt eben sich
mit fragen von diabetes lunge
neurodegenerativen erkrankungen aber
auch mit krebs befassen und das ist gut
so wir werden hinschauen müssen
inwieweit die organisationsstrukturen
eigentlich richtig oder verändert werden
müssen und ich finde dass man nochmal
gucken muss inwieweit es eine
verlässliche finanzierung dieser
gesundheitszentren gibt auch da werden
an unsere wünsche herangetragen die wir
im weiteren verfahren verfahren eben
betrachten werden
wir haben vor einer woche hier über
künstliche intelligenz gesprochen aus
der sicht der künstlichen intelligenz
wenn man jetzt den medizinischen blick
annimmt wird man sehen dass künstliche
intelligenz in kombination mit medizin
große fortschritte bringen wird denn
maschinelles lernen das heißt maschinen
die ganz viele röntgenbilder die sich
mrt bilder angucken und dann eben dazu
die information kriegen wo gibt es einen
krankheits befunden wie sieht er aus und
das maschinell aufarbeiten können und
einem
oder einer ärztin einer empfehlung gehen
können und am ende eine erste
entscheidet das wird ein großer
medizinischer fortschritt sein und er
wird künstliche intelligenz immer auch
eine gute rolle spielen können
wir sind sehr froh dass wir ein sehr
ausführliches kapitel haben im bereich
der rat des rahmenprogramms forschung
dass sich um armut assoziierte
vernachlässigte erkrankungen kümmert
etwas was uns hier kaum betrifft kollege
alban ist auch seit langem unterwegs
unter karamba diaby wo wir sehen aber
dass in anderen ländern der erde
menschen an krankheiten sterben die
eigentlich gar nicht sterben müssten
weil es keine medikamente gegen
wurmerkrankungen gibt und da haben wir
als so großer und guter
forschungsstandort deutschland eben auch
eine internationale verantwortung weiter
in diesem bereich entwicklung zu
betreiben und deswegen ausdrückliche
unterstützung dass das auch im
rahmenprogramm stehen
ein abschließendes wort zur nationalen
dekade gegen krebs ja es ist viel dort
an erfolge zu verzeichnen es gibt
wahnsinnig spannende neue therapien
wissenschaftliche methoden aber ich will
auch ausdrücklich sagen wir haben als
politik auch eine verantwortung keine
hoffnungen zu wecken bei betroffenen
menschen die wir nicht erfüllen können
deswegen rate ich ihr zur zurückhaltung
mit äußerungen dass wir in zehn jahren
den krebs besiegt haben könnten es ist
der sache nicht angemessen und am
schluss tatsächlich das beste programm
gegen tipps was wir in den letzten
jahren auf den weg gebracht haben war
das nichtraucherschutzgesetz auch da
wieder prävention ist manchmal wichtiger
als jede medizinische forschung vielen
dank der bundestag diskutiert über das
rahmenprogramm gesundheitsforschung der
bundesregierung beziehungsweise über
einen wirklich dazu und da geht es unter
anderem in bei diesem thema darum dass
medizinischer fortschritt schneller in
die regelversorgung eingang
endet und darüber hinaus ist vorgesehen
patienten angehörige und medizinisches
fachpersonal früher als bisher auch in
die forschung einzubinden also auch der
weg anders oben der nächste redner am
pult ist mario brandenburg aus der
fdp-fraktion und da ist der technologie
politischer später mehr
zum einen ist zu sagen dass
individualisierte medizin ein schlagwort
ist was im moment in aller munde ist und
wir müssen uns ehrlich machen das
individualisierte medizin nun einfach
auch bedeutet mehr individualisierte
daten eben sehr wertvolle sehr private
daten und wenn wir uns überlegen dass
beispielsweise eine amazon- alexa allein
an der veränderung der stimmfarbe ihres
besitzers auf
herz-kreislauf-erkrankungen schließen
kann dass beispielsweise eine mischung
aus fitness trecker und
bewegungssensoren beim heimischen
treppen gang einsteigen kann wenn wir
anstatt zehn sekunden auf einmal 15
sekunden brauchen dass wir
wahrscheinlich auf die probleme das
spiel stoßen könnten
oder wenn wir mit scanner apps unsere
arme nach potenziellen melanomen
untersuchen können dann müssen wir uns
schon fragen ob wir als politik und
deutschland im moment schon bereit sind
diese daten zu geben aber es wird sehr
erheblich sein ob wir es als land
hinbekommen denn das wird entscheidend
sein für den forschungsstandort
deutschland und für den erfolg des
medizin standortes deutschland
es bleibt natürlich weiterhin richtig
und wichtig die gängigen
volkskrankheiten zu erforschen diabetes
typ 2 herz kreislauf erkrankungen
das ist und bleibt an der stelle richtig
aber eben mit verweis auf die hoch
innovativen medizin felder wie
beispielsweise die individualisierte
medizin werden wir als opposition bei
der ausgestaltung des programms darauf
achten wie die mittel abfließen und dass
wir eben nicht nur die ausgetretenen
pfade gehen sondern an der stelle auch
zu den modernen faden kommen
die für uns als freie demokraten sehr
wichtig sind und ein letzter satz noch
zu den daten oder ein letzter gedanke
ich glaube wir werden das nur erreichen
wenn wir den bürgerinnen und bürgern
volle transparenz bei der nutzung ihrer
daten zu sichern können wir brauchen die
möglichkeit dass bürger sich in einem
portal einloggen können und sehen wer
wann aus was für einem grund auf ihre
daten zugegriffen hat und warum eine
krankenkassen was beispielsweise
berechnet hat und ich stehe hier als
parlamentarier und einer von uns lassen
sie uns das bitte gemeinsam angehen wenn
ich glaube wirklich dass heilung für
viele dort möglich ist und wir sollten
uns an der stelle nicht im klein-klein
zerlegen das sind wir den bürgerinnen
und bürgern schuldig dass ich in der
gesundheits schuldig gegangen mario
brandenburg aus der fdp-fraktion und
manfort jetzt petra sitte
stellvertretende vorsitzende der
linksfraktion
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
ja dass man spannende lektüre dieses
rahmenprogramm für gesundheitsforschung
noch spannender finde ich aber wo die
bundesregierung rahmenbedingungen
insbesondere die ökonomischen
rahmenbedingungen eher als gegeben
hinnimmt statt sie zu verändern
warum sage ich das weil sie es
eigentlich als ihre mission bezeichnen
ich zitiere gesundheitsforschung ist
dann erfolgreich wenn sie den menschen
erreicht am beispiel einer großen
volkskrankheit nämlich demenz
beziehungsweise alzheimer will ich
zeigen warum sie selbst ihr ziel
gefährden
sie schreiben da in dem bericht ganz
gelassen das akademische einrichtungen
erkenntnisse generieren
idealerweise würden diese dann von der
gesundheitswirtschaft aufgegriffen aber
erstens greifen die pharmariesen nur bei
hohen renditeerwartungen die
erkenntnisse auf und zweitens haben sich
viele pharmakonzerne längst dem
forschungs risiko entzogen und bei
alzheimer ist es ganz besonders
dramatisch zuletzt hat sich im
vergangenen jahr
pfizer rausgezogen aus der forschung
aktuell gibt es kein medikament gegen
das fortschreiten oder die heilung
dieser krankheit derzeit wird im
wesentlichen an alzheimer
nur noch an öffentlichen einrichtungen
oder an kleinen und mittelständischen
unternehmen gearbeitet
in meinem wahlkreis beispielsweise eben
auch dort engagiert sich eine solche
kleine firma und man kann sich gut
vorstellen was das für so eine firma
bedeutet wenn erstens der andere ansatz
nicht trägt oder zweitens kein kauf
erfolgt denn es ist klar erst wenn der
wirkstoff erfolg und rendite verspricht
werden die pharmariesen auf der matte
stehen und natürlich ist ein blockbuster
medikament eine gelddruckmaschine
aber die öffentliche hand und kleine und
mittelständische unternehmen gehen nicht
nur in das erste risiko später zahlen
wir oder erkrankte und kassen noch
einmal für die medikamente und die
preise dieser medikamente werden von den
pharmaunternehmen bestimmt grund genug
dass die bundesregierung aus dieser
logik ausbricht ein weiteres defizit
dieses programms zeigt sich bei
uniklinika und klinischer forschung
uniklinika unterliegen wie jedes
krankenhaus auch der ökonomischen logik
des fallpauschalen systems diese
behandlungs vergütung bildet aber völlig
unzureichend ab worum sich die
uniklinika kümmern nämlich um
maximalversorgung und eben auch um
forschung und lehre und diese
finanzierung für forschung und lehre
kommt auch wiederum aus der öffentlichen
hand kommt von den medizinischen
fakultäten und trotzdem sind natürlich
die einrichtung unterfinanziert wie wir
es seit jahren erleben und das bedeutet
bei den uniklinika dass es schwer wird
unabhängige klinische forschung
durchzuführen und natürlich am ende auch
das zu integrieren in die behandlung
auch hier erwarte ich deutlich mehr von
der bundesregierung insbesondere auch
ein schritt dahin dieses
fallpauschalensystem unter diesem
blickwinkel mindestens zu ändern
meine damen und herren auch
forscherinnen und forscher wollen nicht
nur gut vergütet werden sie wollen auch
attraktive bedingungen für ihre arbeit
so stoßen ärzte die klinisch
wissenschaftlich arbeiten bei ihrer
qualifizierung auf starre an
erkennungssysteme insbesondere der
länder ärztekammern und das bedeutete am
ende dass sie natürlich auch gehemmt
werden in ihrer forschung auch
dazugehören lösungsansätze in eben jenes
rahmenprogramm und schließlich verzögern
diese defizite auch schnellere
fortschritte wie schon angedeutet bei
armut bedingten und vernachlässigten
krankheiten insbesondere in
einkommensschwachen ländern und fast
verständnisvoll vermerken sie an dieser
stelle das fehlen wirtschaftliche
anreize für pharmakonzerne
aber meine damen und herren profit
getriebenes unmoralisches verhalten
müssen wir nicht dulden dass müssen wir
bekämpfen und beenden und schließlich
eine gratis empfehlung bekanntermaßen
hat diese bundesregierung hier ein etwas
unglückliches händchen wenn es um
studien und beratung geht das sieht frau
carlitscheck darf es für das aufwachsen
von kindern in gleichgeschlechtlichen
partnerschaften studien bedarf und herrn
spahn fehlen informationen zu seelischen
folgen von schwangerschafts abbrüche
also ich meine diese studien gibt es
längst
und wie heißt es so schön wer liest es
klar im vorteil dieses bild können sie
gerne in das rahmenprogramm stecken
vielen dank petra sitte stellvertretende
vorsitzende der linksfraktion hier in
der aussprache des bundestages zur
förderung der gesundheitsforschung dazu
gibt es ja im rahmenprogramm der
bundesregierung in dem geschaut wird wo
im moment defizite sind wo mehr
gefördert werden muss bei der forschung
an hochschulen und universitätskliniken
und anderen forschungseinrichtungen und
dazu jetzt kein gehring für
bündnis 90 die grünen wie verbunden ist
oder miterleben zu müssen wie sich ein
lieber mensch aufgrund von demenz
schrittweise zu am fremden entwickelt
darum haben gerade fortschritte in der
gesundheitsforschung eine so große
bedeutung für das leben der menschen und
wir als politik müssen maßgeblich dafür
sorgen dass die erkenntnisse aus dem
labor auch wirklich und zügig in
arztpraxen im krankenhaus und bei den
menschen zu hause ankommen
zumindest rhetorisch stellt die
bundesregierung mit ihrem rahmenprogramm
gesundheitsforschung den menschen in den
mittelpunkt nach immerhin dafür ist auch
eine verbesserung der
wissenschaftskommunikation vorgesehen
denn zitat eine offene und informierte
auseinandersetzung stärkt das vertrauen
der menschen in die wissenschaft und
erhöhte gesundheitskonferenz der
menschen beim start der dekade gegen
krebs hat minister sparen aber gleich
das ganze ordentlich vergeigt aus dem
bauch heraus anzukündigen in zehn bis 20
jahren sei der krebs besiegt ist für
einen gesundheitsminister
unverantwortlich wer solche schlagzeilen
produziert verspielt das vertrauen der
patienten und leistet der forschung ein
bärendienst
aber auch im gesundheits
forschungsrahmenprogramm selbst hapert
es und der wissenschaftsrat hat der
regierung eine ganze reihe von
hausaufgaben aufgegeben
gerade bei der finanzierung klinischer
studien ohne die keine wissenschaftliche
entdeckung bei den menschen ankommt
sehen die expertinnen und experten
dringend nachholbedarf
andere länder haben das längst erkannt
und befördern gezielt soziale und
medizinische innovationen von den
patienten profitieren und sie auch im
gesundheitssystem geld sparen
hier würde jeder euro mehr gleich
mehrfach nutzen
schauen wir auf das neue nationale
forschungszentrum zur psychischen
gesundheit dass die bundesregierung
plant psychische erkrankungen wie
depression oder angststörung sind längst
zur volkskrankheit geworden mehr als
jeder dritte ist im lauf des lebens
betroffen hier mehr zu forschen ist
dringend notwendig das unterstützen wir
doch auch den nationalen
forschungszentrum sagt der
wissenschaftsrat erst einmal klug
nachbessern bevor man auf die schnelle
neue cent und schafft die sind nur
erfolgreich wenn sie sich in die
forschungslandschaft einfügen und
bestehende strukturen auch wirklich
stärken gerade die forschung psychischer
erkrankungen muss die gesamte regens
realität der menschen abbilden das
gelingt am besten wenn hochschulen und
außeruniversitäre
forschungseinrichtungen in netzwerken
mit praktikern zusammenarbeiten vor
carlitscheck bauen sie also keine neuen
parallelstrukturen auf sondern stärken
sie die herausragende forschung im
gesundheits und im sozialbereich dies
landauf landab längst gibt
berücksichtigung der sozialen lagen und
armutsrisiken auf gesundheit wurden
schon angesprochen ist sehr sehr wichtig
auch für eine gute forschung eine
bessere vernetzung braucht es aber auch
mit der geschlechterforschung denn der
faktor geschlecht spielt im
rahmenprogramm kaum eine rolle
das ist problematisch denn solange der
biologisch männliche körper als
non-plus-ultra und norm gilt wird vor
allem dieser erforscht das hat zb zur
folge dass herzinfarkte bei frauen
seltener erkannt werden weil die
symptome anders ausfallen
und hier ist es rahmenprogramm nicht auf
höhe der heutigen wissenschaft gutes
dass das rahmenprogramm auch
internationale gesundheitsrisiken in den
blick nimmt weltweit sterben menschen an
krankheiten wie malaria hiv tuberkulose
und schlafkrankheit weil wirtschaft und
politik sie zu lange vernachlässigt
haben
leider ist deutschland hier auch selber
nicht vorbildlich und weit davon
entfernt die von der weko empfohlenen
0,01 prozent des bruttoinlandsprodukt
für diese vernachlässigten krankheiten
auszugeben das ist nicht solidarisch das
ist armselig
und frau carlitscheck sie bezeichnen ihr
programm für die gesundheitsforschung am
schluss des dokuments selbst als sein
lernen das programm kann man nur sagen
zum glück denn es gibt noch viel zu tun
damit die forschungsförderung nicht als
mitnahme bonus bei den pharmakonzernen
landet sondern die patientinnen und
patienten schnell von neuen
entwicklungen profitieren können vielen
dank kollege kai gehring
nächster redner stephan albani für die
cdu csu fraktion
[Musik]
[Applaus]
herzlichen dank herr präsident meine
lieben kolleginnen und kollegen lieber
zuschauer auf den tribünen und zu hause
an den fernsehern forschung forschung
ist spannend forschung ist relevant
forschung gestaltet zukunft und
medizinische forschung ist mit
sicherheit der teil der forschung der am
wenigsten den menschen erklären muss
wozu sie wichtig ist und wofür sie da
ist und deswegen ist auch das
gesundheits forschungsrahmenprogramm was
wir heute hier diskutieren von höchster
relevanz und setzt um was im
koalitionsvertrag mit dem relativ
schmucklosen satz gesundheitsforschung
ausbauen patientin patienten in den
mittelpunkt stellen schon abgedruckt war
in zwei leitlinien mensch in den
mittelpunkt und personalisierung
digitalisierung als schlüssel macht
dieses rahmenprogramm aus und gerade der
zweite satz gefällt mir sehr gut weil
ich sehr häufig lese dass
personalisierung und digitalisierung
herausforderungen sind die wir
bewältigen müssen nein es ist ein
schlüssel im bereich der medizin durch
personalisierung und digitalisierung
werden wir in der medizin deutliche
fortschritte machen können und dass an
dieser stelle als leitlinie ist sehr
wichtig auch dass wir auch dass wir
letzten endes keine revolution machen
denn in diesem bereich geht es ganz
wichtig darum der branche orientierung
und auch kontinuität zu geben und
verlässlichkeit in den entsprechenden
strukturen denn wie anfang der woche
gerade auf einer tagung der
hochschulmedizin
unisono bestätigt wurde ist die
forschungslandschaft in deutschland
einzigartig und gut wir haben die dzg
ist wir haben die hochschulmedizin wir
haben die großen vier außeruniversitären
forschungseinrichtungen und bitte herr
frömming max planck ist kein trost
sondern ein inneres element genau dieser
differenzierten forschungslandschaft und
dass die rankings außerhalb von
deutschland dieses nicht mit
berücksichtigen ist weniger ein problem
von deutschland sondern von den rankings
medizintechnik in deutschland ist
führend
made in germany vorne wenn wir uns das
dann anschauen 9,8 milliarden umsatz im
inland 18,2 milliarden im ausland 1200
km uns viele hidden champions die 93
prozent an diesem amt an diesem anteil
haben und und das ist entscheidend und
hier muss halt forschung öffentlich
geförderte forschung liebe linke und
auch industrie zusammenarbeitenden die
investieren neun prozent ihres gesamten
umsatz die kmu s 9 prozent ihres
umsatzes in genau diese forschung
entsprechend hinein das ist wichtig ein
anderer punkt der sehr wichtig ist
ist halt interdisziplinarität es ist
halt wie der kollege rené röspel sehr
richtig sagt nicht der einzelne forscher
der da in seinem zimmer hin sitz und so
weiter sondern es ist mittlerweile
netzwerke aus allen einrichtungen aus
allen bereichen und wenn ich bei mir im
wahlkreis mir das mal anschauen dort
gibt es eine industrien klinik plattform
die entsprechend das alles bündelt kiss
me klinisches informationszentrum für
medizintechnik in oldenburg und was dort
halt gemacht wird ist dass mediziner
pflege ärzte physiker psychologen
soziologen alle zusammen an den
projekten arbeiten und auf diese art und
weise die interdisziplinarität in der
sache und in der arbeit herstellt und
ärzte pflege praxen werden schon während
der ideenfindung der projekte mit
eingebunden so dass auf diese art und
weise das was man user centered design
der erweiterte form des mensch in den
mittelpunkt nicht nur der patient
sondern auch der anwender und die
anwenderinnen
entsprechend sicherstellt ist ein
wesentlicher punkt dass wir in der
medizin angemessen vorankommen ein
weiterer zentraler gedanke wird nämlich
durch solche institutionen aufgerufen
nicht versäumen nicht silo denken
sondern vernetzt und in dieser
vernetzung auch die translationale was
beim patienten ankommt und wenn man da
heute immer noch weiß dass es 14,2 jahre
dauert bis etwas vom wissenschaftler
fertiggestellt letzten endes am
patienten durchschnittlich dauert bis es
dort ankommt dann kann man nur sagen das
ist zu lange hier müssen wir noch besser
werden und das wird durch diese
zusammenarbeit schlussendlich ermöglicht
werden insofern aus meiner sicht
zusammenfassend wir haben hier ein gutes
rahmenprogramm vorliegen dass im sinne
eines fernrohrs in die zukunft schaut
und die branche orientiert es wurden
aufgenommen
die evaluationsergebnisse des laufenden
oder jetzt entsprechend zu ende
laufenden forschungsrahmenprogramms und
es bietet perspektive für die
forschenden einrichtungen und die
industrie die gleichermaßen im nachgang
zur veröffentlichung bereits ihrerseits
gesagt haben sowohl die forschenden
unternehmen als auch der medizinische
fakultätentag hierbei handelt es sich um
ein gutes rahmenprogramm was eine gute
basis für die nächsten jahre legen wird
insofern ist der rahmen an dieser stelle
gesetzt und jetzt beginnen wir in
anführungsstrichen mit dem ausmalen des
bildes was dadurch gezeichnet wird das
wird uns in den nächsten jahren
beschäftigen
ich freue mich auf die zusammenarbeit
mit den kollegen rené röspel dass wir
dort auch wie wir schon eingebunden
waren hier entsprechend dieses weiter
aus fertigen werden zusammen mit dem
bmbf und im sinne der patienten mensch
im mittelpunkt und als abschluss sei mir
noch erlaubt diese rede wurde in diesem
umfang ermöglicht durch eine zeitspende
der csu herzlichen dank stephan albani
für die unionsfraktion übrigens
gelernter physiker und ihm folgt als
letzter redner in dieser debatte ein
gelernter chemiker nämlich
diaby für die spd-fraktion er ist
mitglied im ausschuss für bildung
forschung und technikfolgenabschätzung
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
gedämpft herren als letzter redner bei
dieser debatte rahmenprogramm
gesundheitsforschung der bundesregierung
möchte ich am anfang bei einer rede auf
einen ganz konkreten fall eingehen
bei einer jungen mutter von zwei söhnen
wurde im vergangenen jahr blutkrebs
festgestellt astrid ist 41 jahre alt und
hat mittlerweile einige chemo therapien
hinter sich
doch der behandlungserfolg blieb leider
bisher aus sie braucht einen also
dringend einen stammzellenspender
natürlich gibt es ähnliche fälle zu
viele meine ich der palast ist jedoch
schwierig sie ist deutsch nigerianische
herkunft sie brauchen deshalb einen
westafrikanische europäischen spender
leider sind nur drei prozent der
registrierten spender multi ethnische
das rahmenprogramm gesundheitsforschung
sieht vor dass der mensch im mittelpunkt
steht ich zitiere alle menschen nehmen
am medizinischen fortschritt teil
und doch sehen wir an diesem fall dass
es menschen gibt denen viel seltener
geholfen werden kann
umso wichtiger ist es rahmenbedingungen
behandlungsmethoden und technologien zu
fördern sowie forschen zu verbessern
die schnelle überführung
die schnelle überführung von
forschungsergebnissen in die
medizinische forschung versorgung steht
dabei im fokus
denn je schneller diese forschung
angewendet werden kann desto früher
können patienten behandelt werden
deshalb sagen wir als das jahr
demokratischen staat demokraten die
situation der forschende erst innen- und
erster muss verbessert werden
als spd-bundestagsfraktion setzen wir
uns dafür ein dass eine forderung des
koalitionsvertrags umgesetzt werden das
heißt erstens wir wollen mehr stellen
für ziehen die forscher in der ersten
und erster schaffen zweitens für sie
muss die vereinbarkeit zwischen arbeit
im krankenhaus forschung und familie
verbessert werden und drittens
deutschland muss ein spitzenstandort der
medizinische forschung seien
medizinische forschung ist eine globale
aufgabe
daher müssen wir auch die internationale
kooperation in forschung stärken denn
krankheiten kennen keine grenzen
deswegen sollten wir auch keine kennen
wir
wir wollen ein gesundes leben für alle
menschen
dafür kann das rahmenprogramm
gesundheitsforschung einen maßgeblichen
beitrag leisten
meine damen und herren selten geht es
wirklich um leben oder tod doch
internationale zusammenarbeit in der
medizin kann den unterschied machen und
lieber astrid an dich von ganzem herzen
wünsche ich dir dass du so schnell wie
möglich einen spende findest damit du
dein leben weiterführen kann es alles
gute
und carla maria wie endet mit einem
persönlichen wort in dieser aussprache
in dem es um das rahmenprogramm
gesundheitsforschung der bundesregierung
gegangen ist das wird jetzt weiter
diskutiert im ausschuss für bildung
forschung und technikfolgenabschätzung
und wir können einen blick richten auf
den nächsten tagesordnungspunkt da geht
es nämlich um die nationale tourismus
strategie die ist zwar im
koalitionsvertrag zwischen cdu csu und
spd vereinbart aber so sagt
beispielsweise die fdp kommt er im
grunde gar nicht vor wird nicht
thematisiert wird eigentlich gar nicht
weiterentwickelt sowie plan war obwohl
es einen tourismusbeauftragten der
bundesregierung gibt mit thomas bareiß
dem wir gleich in der debatte auch hören
werden
und da also hat die fdp einen
entsprechenden antrag gestellt in dem
sie die nationale tourismusstrategie
mittelstandsfreundlich gestalten lassen
will und es gibt auch einen antrag der
linksfraktion zu diesem thema die
fordert bessere arbeitsbedingungen für
die fast drei millionen beschäftigten im
tourismus gewerbe sowie mehr staatliche
hilfen um einkommensschwache familien
und kindern ferien reisen rund
klassenfahrten zu ermöglichen
warum ist nationaler tourismus so
relevant durchaus in diesen tagen da
reicht ein blick auf die
übernachtungszahlen im vergangenen jahr
477 millionen übernachtungen hat es
gegeben mit urlaubern aus dem in und
ausland also tourismus natürlich auch
ein wirtschaftsfaktor
jetzt hat bundestags-vizepräsidentin
claudia roth die abgeordneten noch mal
ermahnt platz zu nehmen bzw das plenum
zügig zu verlassen falls sie
gesundheitsexperten sind und an dieser
debatte nicht wirklich teilnehmen wollen
und dann geht es auch los mit marcel
klinge tourismuspolitischer sprecher der
fdp fraktion
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen würde die große koalition bei
der nationalen tourismus strategie
ähnlich fleißig sein wie die drei
millionen beschäftigten in der
tourismusbranche
sie wäre schon heute eine
erfolgsgeschichte
leider ist das gegenteil der fall
nichtstun ist handlungsmaxime von
schwarz-rot wir freidemokraten wollen
dagegen mehr tempo mehr einsatz und mehr
herzblut für eine der wichtigsten
wirtschaftsbranchen in deutschland und
was mich am meisten ärgert liebe
kolleginnen kollegen von der koalition
ihre notorische ambitionslos sich kite
denn diese haltung haben unsere
mittelständler unsere familienbetriebe
im tourismus die über 300 milliarden
euro im jahr erwirtschaften und über
50.000 ausbildungsplätze schaffen
wahrlich nicht verdient mit
wertschätzung hat diese politik so lange
nichts mehr zu tun
was ist bisher passiert 4,5 seiten non
paper 4,5 seiten non paper mit neuen
inhalt das ist das magere ergebnis von
knapp einem jahr ihre arbeit
die nationale tourismus strategie ist
eine blackbox bisher von der keiner so
recht weiß wo die reise am ende hin geht
die fdp fraktion wir mit ihrem heutigen
antrag der debatte den notwendigen
schwung und die inhaltliche richtung
geben
wir wollen dass bereits ende des jahres
2019 erste maßnahmen umgesetzt werden
und das gelingt nur meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren wenn wir die nächsten
monaten uns nicht in detailfragen
verlieren sondern wenn wir uns auf die
wesentlichen kern herausforderung der
branche konzentrieren und dabei das ist
besonders besonders wichtig den
mittelstand in den fokus unserer
bemühungen stellen eine nationale
strategie die muss erstens smarter
antworten darauf finden wie wir den
existenzbedrohenden fachkräftemangel
bekämpfen
sie muss zweitens antworten darauf
liefern wie wir die digitalisierung für
alle akteure im tourismus positiv
gestalten und in die fläche tragen und
sie muss drittens antworten darauf
liefern wie wir die immer schneller
drehende bürokratie spirale durchbrechen
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
wir finden besser vier seiten konkrete
lösungen umsetzen als 40 seiten für die
schublade produzieren legen wir endlich
mit der arbeit los
liebe kolleginnen kollegen kurz vor der
größten tourismusmesse der welt der tb
ist glaube ich ein guter anlass auch mal
zwischenbilanz der wirtschafts und
tourismus politik zu ziehen und diese
fällt wie sage ich es möglichst
diplomatisch verheerend aus die großen
gehen im wirtschaftsministerium ein und
aus die kleinen und mittleren werten
links liegen gelassen wir sind mit einer
solchen politik nicht einverstanden und
ich will ihnen das an drei beispielen
illustrieren was hat der
bundeswirtschaftsminister gemacht und
die dringend notwendige flexibilisierung
von arbeitszeiten voranzutreiben
nichts was hat der
bundeswirtschaftsminister gemacht um das
seit jahren schwellende problem der
gewerbesteuerlichen hinzurechnung für
kleine und mittlere reiseanbieter zu
lösen nichts was hat der
bundeswirtschaftsminister getan um die
bürokratie lawine bei der
pauschalreiserichtlinie zu stoppen
nichts deswegen sehr geehrter altmaier
sie sind für die tourismusbranche die
große enttäuschung des ersten
regierungsjahres und das war gar nicht
so einfach bei der konkurrenz im
kabinett meine damen und herren es wird
also höchste zeit dass die mopo ihre
bewegung starre überwindet und die
nationale tourismus strategie
immerhin ihr einziges projekt im
koalitionsvertrag zu einer
erfolgsgeschichte gemacht wir freie
demokraten liefern dazu gerne ideen der
in unserer großartigen betriebe haben
jede unterstützung verdient
marcel klinge für die fdp fraktion in
dieser debatte in der es um die
nationale tourismus strategie geht unter
anderem und dazu jetzt der bereits
angesprochene vertreter des
bundesministeriums für wirtschaft und
energie das ist der parlamentarische
staatssekretär thomas bareiß und der ist
auch tourismusbeauftragter der
bundesregierung mit dem heutigen antrag
der fdp und auch der linken haben einmal
die gelegenheit über einen der
wichtigsten branchen in deutschland zu
reden die leider auch viel zu wenig
anerkennung und wertschätzung verdient
aber die von ihrer bedeutung her
aber was die zahlen angeht enorm ist
willst du mal einen wenigen zahlen
deutlich machen wir haben 105 milliarden
euro bruttowertschöpfung aus dem
tourismus es sind vier prozent unserer
gesamtwertschöpfung wir haben daraus
konsumausgaben im wert von 290
milliarden euro die vielen anderen
branchen hinein eine enorme strahlkraft
haben und wir haben drei millionen
beschäftigte sind sieben prozent unserer
gesamtbeschäftigung die zahlen zeigen
dass wir hier in augenhöhe sind mit der
automobilbranche mit dem maschinen
anlagen bauen dass die terrorismus
brauche ich eine ganz ganz große
bedeutung für unsere wirtschaft hat und
es sind nur zahlen meine damen und
herren wichtig ist für mich ein ganz
besonderer weise dass diese branche auch
von ihrer struktur etwas ganz besonderes
ist nämlich mittelständisch geprägt
viele familienunternehmen kleinteilig
mit einer hohen leistungsbereitschaft
mit einer flexibilität in einer großen
leidenschaft vor ort wo man sich um
kunden kümmert um anliegen kümmert und
ich weiß wo ich arbeite dankeschön sagen
will all diejenigen die hier arbeiten
und die ihr vieles vieles tun von der
landwirtschaft ein herzliches dankeschön
für das was in der tourismusbranche
gemacht wird mein antrag eine weitere
zahl mit 84 millionen übernachtungen aus
dem ausland zeigt auch dass die
tourismusbranche eine visitenkarte ist
unser land dass menschen die gerne
herkommen auch zur botschafter während
zu landes- und es somit auch in viele
viele andere bereiche hinein strahlt und
damit auch eine querschnittsaufgabe für
uns in der bundesregierung geworden ist
insofern auch das soll noch mal zeigen
wie wichtig die tourismuslandschaft für
die bundesregierung ist die
tourismusbranche ist derzeit sehr
regional sehr länderspezifisch
organisiert und hat auch hier ihre
kompetenzen und deshalb ist es groß die
große frage welche aufgabe jetzt der
bund stark übernehmen kann in der frage
der tourismusstrategie ich glaube das
und viel mehr
auch tourismus strategisch angehen muss
weil die herausforderung die nächsten
jahre kommen werden enorm sein werde ich
sage mal stichwort digitalisierung ist
eine große herausforderung 86 prozent
der übernachtungen derzeit wären übers
internet gebucht das heißt auch hier
wird eine enorme verschiebung gemacht
fällt dies erfolgen konnte
anbieter wie erwin wie solche entweder
werde eine größere rolle spielen und
immerhin 150 millionen menschen in ganz
europa sind gehandicapt heutzutage und
haben auch hier ganz besondere ansprüche
an unsere attraktionen unsere und
tourismuseinrichtungen auch das zeigt
dass wir auch hier stark voran gehen
wissen uns an den bedürfnissen der
nächsten jahre orientieren müssen das
sind herausfordernd die wir an
nationalen regeln müssen und deshalb
brauchen wir auch eine
tourismusstrategie wir jetzt gemeinsam
erarbeiten wollen lieber kollege zu
kollege von der fdp in der tat haben sie
wichtige punkte in ihrem eintrag
geschrieben geschrieben dass wir die
genau hinzurechnung einpacken müssen
diesen punkt der mir sehr am herzen
liegt und der woche vor durch alle auch
mitzumachen daran auch den augen auch
teile zu werden auch das thema
arbeitszeitregelung spielt eine ganz
besondere rolle für die kleinen
gaststätten für die hoteliers auch hier
sind wir dran westen lösungen zu finden
dass wir hier flexibilität am markt
brauchen und die müssen veränderungen
auch diese legislaturperiode erfolgen
auch daran arbeiten wir mit nachdruck
daran aber wir haben noch weitere themen
die wir anpacken müssen und deshalb
dadurch dass wir jetzt relativ schnell
auch in konkrete maßnahmen gehen müssen
und ich sage ihnen ganz offen ich habe
ihren antrag sehr genau gelesen die 17
punkte die sie aufgeschrieben haben
vonseiten fdp sind viel viel
allgemeinplätzen ich rate jedem
tourismusbranche diese einträge zu lesen
weil drin steht nicht viel ist die
heißluft fasste entsteht wir brauchen
konkrete maßnahmen um die
tourismusbranche wirklich auch zu helfen
meine damen und herren
und diese maßnahmen wollen wir wollen
wir ja jetzt erarbeiten und ich möchte
hier an der stelle auch immer sagen die
wichtiges mehr ware als
tourismusbeauftragten auch das parlament
einzubinden deshalb bin ich recht früh
auch auf den tourismus ausschuss
zugegangen wir haben gemeinsam überlegt
welche punkte wichtig sind wichtig sind
auch dass wir die wir aufnehmen sollen
und deshalb haben wir jetzt gemeinsam
auch ein papier erarbeitet wir wollen
jetzt im ersten schritt eine
eckpunktepapier ins kabinett einbringen
mit den herausforderungen beschreiben
die handlungsfelder definieren und das
wird sich noch im märz passieren dass
wir hier auch wirklich im kabinett an
die vorlage haben und darauf aufbauen
werden wird dann mit den ländern mit den
regionen mit den akt
und fortan auch die handlungs punkte
definieren wie wir die
tourismusstrategie umbauen das ist für
mich eine strategie die in sich stimmig
und wenig ist sie auch dann die chance
hat wirklich auch konkret was um
zusätzliche luft zu produzieren wie das
was ich gerade gemacht habe ihre rede
sondern auch das was die politik macht
die branche wirklich auch hilft und noch
etwas voranbringen diesem sinne freue
ich mich auf die nächsten monate auf die
umsetzung der strategie oder auf eine
hoffen auch sinnvoll der branche helfen
der strategie die danach welche
verbesserung und flexibilität denn auch
bietet herzlichen dank schlanker kollege
bar als nächster redner sebastian
münchen bayer für die alfsee faktoren
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren die nationale tourismus
strategie der bundesregierung das
unbekannte wesen
bereits seit konstituierung dieser nicht
mehr ganz so großen koalition war bei
der begriff durch die tourismusbranche
und über die flure des deutschen
bundestags bisheriger inhalt vollkommen
fehlanzeige
dabei wäre eine strategie die auf
bundesebene die rahmenbedingungen für
die branche verbessert definitiv zu
begrüßen und es gibt unzählige probleme
die diese strategie aufgreifen oder noch
besser lösen sollte die
gewerbesteuerliche hinzurechnung bedroht
existenzen viele betriebsübergaben oder
neugründungen im gastronomischen bereich
scheitern an bürokratischen hürden
unser arbeitszeitgesetz verhindert
freiräume für arbeitgeber und
arbeitnehmer
die komplizierte fördermittel struktur
wird wohl von kaum einem mittelständler
durchschaut und über noch größere
projekte wie beispielsweise eine gut
ausgebaute verkehrsinfrastruktur oder
eine flächendeckende 5 gehen
netzabdeckung wage ich überhaupt nicht
zu sprechen
sie sehen meine damen und herren zu tun
gäbe es genug
wir als fdp fraktion fordern deshalb
eine nationale tourismus strategie die
diesen namen auch verdient hat
hierzu gehört erstens hierzu gehört
erstens eine klare schwerpunktsetzung
und zweitens eine realistische
lage-einschätzung was wir auf
bundesebene überhaupt regeln können
apropos schwerpunktsetzung meine freunde
auf der linken bahn kam in ihrem antrag
zur tourismus strategie den schwerpunkt
beispielsweise aus kindergarten
abschlussfahrten gelegt
damit wir uns nicht falsch verstehen
natürlich sind kinder und jugendreisen
wichtig aber wenn der schwerpunkt wenn
der schwerpunkt einer bundesweiten
strategie für eine branche die für eine
bruttowertschöpfung von über 105
milliarden euro verantwortlich ist und
in der knapp drei millionen menschen
arbeiten wenn sie dann den schwerpunkt
auf kindergarten abschlussfahrten legen
muss ich sagen sie haben die bedeutung
dieser aufgabe nicht erkannt ihren
antrag lehnen wir ab
aber kommen wir zurück zur realistischen
lage-einschätzung da die aufgabe
tourismus gemäss kompetenzverteilung des
grundgesetzes ländersache ist kann eine
nationale tourismus strategie auf
bundesebene letztendlich nur die
politischen und rechtlichen
rahmenbedingungen im land prägen nicht
mehr aber auch nicht weniger
statt das offen zu sagen wird die
tourismusbranche von spd und cdu/csu
regelmäßig enttäuscht die koalition hat
mit der strategie unglaublich hohe
erwartungen geweckt und alle warten
jetzt gespannt auf die kommende
arbeitserleichterung aber genau ihre
koalition kann sich doch schon über
einfachste sachverhalt in diesem bereich
überhaupt nicht einigen
er bereist hat eben angesprochen wir
müssen die gewerbesteuerliche
hinzurechnung angreifen am mittwoch
haben sie meine damen und herren von der
spd öffentlich widersprochen ihrem
eigenen koalitionspartner und haben
gesagt nein wir werden das thema
gewerbesteuerliche hinzurechnungen
politisch nicht mehr angreifen und
warten stattdessen auf ein
gerichtsurteil das ist ein armutszeugnis
für diese regierung und ist vor allem
ein armutszeugnis für das
selbstverständnis eines jeden roten
abgeordneten hier im hohen haus wissen
sie was ich weiß ja ich weiß ja dass ihr
selbstbewusstsein äußerst antiken axis
und wenn ich mir angucke und ihr
führungspersonal dann verstehe ich auch
warum aber das ist schon so weit ist
dass sie sich politische lösungen
überhaupt nicht mehr zu trauen und sich
hinter gerichtsurteilen verstecken das
ist harter tobak
kleiner tipp vielleicht sollten die
stadt hier um zu sitzen und zu pöbeln
vielleicht sollten sie gerichtsprozess
beobachter für eine ihrer vom aussterben
bedrohten spd zeitungen werden und in
zukunft das bundestagsmandat denen
überlassen die politisch etwas verändern
im gegensatz zu ihrer trümmer truppe
versucht die fdp-fraktion weniges jahr
noch politisch zu wirken und will der
nationalen tourismus strategie mit
immerhin 17 punkten kontur verleiht
schade ist ehrlich gesagt nur dass diese
themenliste zum größten teil aus
allgemeinplätzen besteht
sie wollen zum beispiel prüfen ob
einfachere förderinstrumente für mehr
investitionen sorgen
liebe liberale dass eine binsenweisheit
es muss nicht geprüft sondern umgesetzt
werden
wir haben antrag erklingen antrag werden
wir im ausschuss trotzdem gerne beraten
wir freuen uns auf die debatte und wie
sie sehen sind wir als fdp fraktion
werden wir uns in zukunft kritisch aber
auch konstruktiv mit der idee der
nationalen tourismusstrategie
auseinandersetzen und wir hätten gern
einige realistische lösungsvorschläge
zum beispiel unterstützen wir die vielen
mittelständischen betriebe in dem
fördermaßnahmen aus den verschiedensten
töpfen gebündelt und mit einem
einheitlichen ansprechpartner versehen
werden beispielsweise beim
kompetenzzentrum tourismus entlasten wir
die menschen die ihre zeit lieber den
eigenen gesten anstatt der überbordende
bürokratie widmen wollen
führen wir den digitalen meldeschein
endlich ein und sorgen wir im sinne der
verbraucher und der anbieter für mehr
transparenz auf hotelbuchungsplattform
erleichtern wir die nutzung von
betriebsnahen unterkunftsmöglichkeiten
und sorgen wir dafür dass azubis in
bezug auf den geldwerten vorteil
entlastet werden wenn sie im
ausbildungsbetrieb essen oder
übernachten dürfen
schreiben sie sich diese ideen hinter
ihren herr bereits verbessern sie bitte
die rahmenbedingungen wo sie es können
und geben sie auch ehrlich zu was auf
bundesebene nicht machbar ist denn nur
so funktioniert glaubwürdige politik und
nur so können sie auf die vielen
menschen mitnehmen die mit großen
erwartungen auf die national
tourismusstrategie schauen vielen
herzlichen dank
sebastian münzenmaier war das für die
afg fraktion
tourismuspolitischer sprecher aber er
ist natürlich auch vorsitzender im
tourismusausschuss und
tourismuspolitische sprecherin ist
gabriele hiller ohm und sie spricht
jetzt für die spd-fraktion kolleginnen
und kollegen schön dass wir heute im
vorfeld der weltgrößten touristikmesse
der tb in berlin gelegenheit zur debatte
über die künftige tourismuspolitik in
unserem land haben
ich freue mich dass es gelungen ist im
koalitionsvertrag von spd und cdu/csu
eine nationale tourismus strategie zu
verankern sie lieber herr kollege klinge
haben das ja bemängelt dass es so spät
kommt usw
ich will sie nur daran erinnern dass
ihre ihre fdp auch schon mal einmal in
regierungsverantwortung war
sie haben es überhaupt nicht geschafft
eine tourismusstrategie auf den weg zu
bringen
wir schaffen das und das ist gut so und
zdf lieber haben wünschen weil sie haben
überhaupt gar nichts geliefert bisher
außer worten die hier gehalten haben
kein antrag das waren wahrscheinlich zu
anstrengend sich hier mit einem antrag
in die debatte ein zu geben also doch
seien sie über still und hören sie was
wir zu sagen haben
sie wirken regeln und kollegen obwohl
der tourismus in fast allen regionen in
unserem land eine ganz große rolle
spielt und drei millionen beschäftigte
in hunderttausenden betrieben arbeiten
fehlt uns eine übergreifende
tourismusstrategie bisher und vor allen
dingen fehlt uns die koordinierung der
tourismuspolitik von bund ländern und
kommunen dass liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wollen wir jetzt ändern das
bringen wir auf den weg
deshalb war ich auch schon sehr gespannt
auf die anträge der tourismusstrategie
liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der linken und der fdp was sie
dazu zu sagen haben
sie haben ja keinen antrag gestellt die
grünen leider auch nicht schauen wir uns
den antrag der fdp an
sie sprechen eine brechen einige punkte
an für die wir uns als spd auch stark
machen ja wir brauchen eine effizientere
tourismusförderung fairen wettbewerb
zwischen den klassischen gastbetrieben
und der schering economy wie air berlin
und natürlich brauchen wir auf glasfaser
netze für ein schnelles internet sie
fordern ein einwanderungsgesetz und
investitionen in die berufsschulen
lieberherr klinge wir setzen uns dafür
bereits ein und setzen das in der großen
koalition um und sie wollen alles
mittelständisch mittelstandsfreundlich
ausgestalten da kann ich nur sagen ja
bitte machen wir aber liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen von der fdp
wer trägt dann den deutschen mittelstand
im tourismussektor
das sind doch vor allem die
beschäftigten auf sie kommt es an und
deshalb müssen wir mit unserer politik
genau diesen menschen unter die arme
greifen diese menschen müssen wir in den
fokus nehmen und was will die fdp das
beschäftigte zukünftig noch länger als
bisher am stück arbeiten sollen sie
wollen ran als arbeitszeitgesetz acht
oder sogar zehn stunden am tag kellnern
oder an der rezeption stehen ist ihnen
nicht genug dabei ist erwiesen dass
arbeitszeiten ab der neunten stunde
schwerwiegende gesundheitliche
auswirkungen haben könnte deshalb machen
wir bei diesen plänen nicht mit meine
damen und herren von der fdp sie fordern
zudem dass es mehr geringverdiener geben
soll
nichts anderes wäre eine
der 450 euro grenze für minijobs dabei
wissen wir
minijobs führen in die sackgasse mit
jahrelange niedriglöhne und sozialer
absicherung und ohne soziale absicherung
ich sage nur bei klingele nicht mit uns
ich konnte zum antrag der linken mit
seiner nur vier forderungen ist da ein
falls ein fliegengewicht aber leider
kein ausreichender beitrag für eine
tourismusstrategie aber keine sorge die
spd denken für sie mit liebe linke wir
haben in den vergangenen monaten im
intensiven dialog mit den
tourismusverbänden vereinen und
gewerkschaften zentrale themenfelder und
forderungen ausgearbeitet gerade in
dieser woche haben wir ein umfassendes
positionspapier mit konkreten maßnahmen
in unserer fraktion beschlossen chancen
doch alle mal rein es lohnt sich auf
jeden fall
ich begreife einige zentrale punkte
heraus erstens gute arbeit und
ausbildung gerade im gastgewerbe
hier setzen wir darauf die tarifbindung
zu stärken gute arbeitgeber und
ausbildungsbetriebe besser anzuerkennen
gravierende ausbildungs verstöße
konsequenter zu ahnden sowie
überbetriebliche ausbildung und
weiterbildung zu stärken
wir wollen eine leistungsfähige
infrastruktur wir wollen setzen auf
erreichbarkeit der touristischen ziele
per schiene straße luft und wasser das
wollen wir ausbauen
wir setzen auf mehr nachhaltigkeit und
verbraucherschutz beim reisen
natürlich haben wir auch die
veränderungen durch die digitalisierung
im lenken sie an ihre redezeit ich komme
zum theater
ganz wichtig ist aber auch die
tourismuspolitik zwischen bund ländern
und kommunen sowie ressort übergreifend
besser zu koordinieren
nur so kann eine nationale tourismus
strategie erfolg haben meine damen und
herren liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ich lade sie ein arbeiten sie anders
strategie mit das ist gut für den
tourismus das ist gut für unser land
dankeschön gabriele hiller-ohm für die
spd-fraktion und da sage noch jemand das
scheinbar dröge thema nationale
tourismus strategie setze keine
emotionen frei die nächste chance dazu
hat kerstin kassner
für die linksfraktion liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen meine fraktion möchte mit
diesem antrag eine ergänzung zu den
bereits in arbeit sich befindenden
teilen der tourismusstrategie liefern
wir möchten gerne dass ein besonderer
schwerpunkt auch auf kinder und
jugendreisen gelegt werden das ist bis
jetzt noch in keinem wort hier gefallen
das muss unbedingt dazu kommt erinnern
sie sich doch alle mal an ihre kinder
und jugendzeit haben sie nicht alle
besondere erfahrungen erinnerungen an
schöne reisen vielleicht mit den eltern
mit den großeltern oder eben mit der
schulklasse
ich erinnere mich an eine wunderschöne
reise als 610 auf die insel rügen und
habe mich dort in wasser sand und meer
verliebt und freute mich riesig als
meine eltern später einmal entschieden
wir ziehen jetzt auf die insel rügen und
dort lebe ich seit vielen jahren sehr
gern und wünsche mir dass viele gäste
diese schönheit auch erleben ja gut sein
kinder- und jugendreisen
wir haben darüber bereits im ausschuss
debattiert und der beauftragte der
bundesregierung herbei reisberg ein
defizit bei kinder- und jugendreisen
dem muss ich leider ganz vehement
widersprechen und das taten im übrigen
auch sieben experten auf der anhörung
die wir in dieser woche im
tourismusausschuss zu diesem thema
durchgeführt haben
es gibt dort sehr wohl differenzen die
ausgeglichen werden müssen und die
liegen einmal aufsitzen
denn es ist längst nicht mehr
selbstverständlich dass jedes kind mit
den eltern ins ferienlager oder auf
andere art und weise weisen können auch
klassenfahrten sind keine
selbstverständlichkeit mehr
denn sie sind in aller regel nur möglich
wenn auch das letzte der kinder der
schüler auch das geld für diese reise
aufbringen kann
ja und wir denken auch mit diese reisen
ist ein wahnsinnig breites war vorhanden
für die liebe zum tourismus für die
liebe zum reisen und deshalb muss es
genutzt werden aber eben auch zu
bildungszwecken und deshalb wünscht sich
die linke dass es zum bildungsprogramm
und das beginnt nun mal im kindergarten
werter herr kollege jens maier
das muss dazu gehören es braucht
standards für alle altersgruppen in der
schule bis zur abiturstufe dass man
reisen kann
es ist eine wunderbare möglichkeit
bildung zu vermitteln auf reisen wo
sollte man sich möglichkeiten
erschließen sich mit ökologie mit
umweltfragen zu vertraut zu machen wenn
man das nicht vor ort im wald im park
erleben kann also umweltfragen auf jeden
fall aber es gibt noch viel mehr es gibt
erinnerungsorte mit denen sich unsere
jungen schülerinnen und schüler
beschäftigen sollten es gibt sehr viele
möglichkeiten die man mit der bildung
und reisen verbinden können
deshalb möchten wir dass es standards
für alle schülerinnen und schüler ich
werde auf der idee die gelegenheit
nutzen auf einer podiumsdiskussion mit
erfahrenen organisatoren für solche
reisen zu sprechen um hier daran weiter
zu arbeiten dass es zukünftig diese
standards geben soll
denn wie gesagt reisen bildet
aber es bildet eben auch menschen für
das reisen und deshalb dürfen wir auf
diese möglichkeit auf keinen fall
verzichten
ich denke auch dass es wichtig ist dass
wir sprachreisen das sind ja menschen
die nach deutschland fahren um deutsch
zu lernen unterstützen dass dort eine
aufgabe der die ct werden und auch dafür
werde ich zukünftig streiten
deutschland ist ein schönes land es
lohnt sich gäste ins land zu holen
aber ich denke wir sollten das auch
unseren kindern und jugendlichen
ermöglichen dass sie das erfahren so wie
ich damals auf rügen
vielen dank kerstin kassner für die
linksfraktion in dieser debatte über
nationale tourismus strategie gibt es ja
auch einen antrag der linksfraktion über
den nachher auch noch abgestimmt wird
weil er schon beraten worden ist im
zuständigen ausschuss und die
schwerpunkte werden linksfraktion bei
diesem thema haben sie gehört
es geht um die beschäftigten es geht
aber auch um die reisen in
urlaubsmöglichkeiten von
einkommensschwachen familien und kindern
ja jetzige redner ist markus tressel und
kommt aus der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen ich glaube selten zuvor sind so
großer veränderungen auf einmal über
diese branche gekommen digitalisierung
klimakrise mobilitäts wandel und
fachkräftemangel das sind die themen die
wir auch in der tourismuspolitik auf
bundesebene diskutieren müssen weil man
diese herausforderungen nicht alleine
auf länder- oder gar destination ebene
gestalten kann selbst wenn man das
wollte und in zügen hinzu kommt die
wichtige frage wie wir innovation und
weiterentwicklung unserer destinationen
finanzieren die wettbewerber schlafen ja
nicht um uns herum wenn wir zum beispiel
nach österreich schauen dann sehen wir
dass dort sehr aktiv und vor allem
koordiniert die weiterentwicklung des
tourismusstandortes vorangetrieben wird
und für andere länder gilt das
gleichermaßen und deshalb möchte ich für
uns vier punkte hervorheben die neben
einigen anderen aspekten zentral sind
für eine weiterentwicklung des
tourismusstandortes deutschland und ganz
wichtig und dass der erste punkt wir
brauchen eine deutlich bessere
koordinierung dieses wichtigen
politikfeld
ohne eine grundlegende veränderung bei
der koordinierung auf bundesebene aber
auch mit den ebenen darunter brauchen
wir die inhaltlichen themen gar nicht zu
diskutieren fast jedes bundesministerium
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen macht
irgendwie tourismus politik in diesem
land dazu kommen die länder und die
destinationen da spielen viele akteure
nebeneinander her und das kann so nicht
funktionieren
und deshalb ist das ein zentrales
handlungsfeld wenn wir da nach vorne was
entwickeln wollen wir müssen kräfte
bündeln konzeptionelle und auch
finanzielle
das bringt am ende nicht nur mehr output
für den tourismusstandort sondern auch
ein größeres politisches gewicht für die
branche dass die branche auch dringend
braucht und der zweite punkt liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ist das thema
nachhaltigkeit sie es angesichts des
klimawandels ein zentrales element der
tourismuspolitik da müssen wir besonders
über mobilität sprechen die ist ja quasi
grundlage für tourismus wie kommen die
leute in die destinationen wie gewinnen
wir mehr passagiere für die bahn wie
gewährleisten die ein bequemes und vor
allem verlässliches bahnangebot und da
kann der bund einen intensiven beitrag
leisten als eigentümer der bahn des muss
zwingender bestandteil einer tourismus
strategie sein
drittens müssen wir mit nachdruck über
das thema fachkräfte sprechen
prosperierender hochwertiger tourismus
ist auf gut ausgebildetes fachpersonal
angebot angewiesen da sind wir heute
schon am limit wir sprechen von
abbrecherquoten von fast 50 prozent beim
ausbildungsberuf restaurantfachmann
restaurantfachfrau ähnliche zahlen bei
den köchen die meistgenannten gründe zu
lange arbeitszeiten auch an wochenenden
geringer lohn und das heißt liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der fdp
da ist es nicht gerade förderlich die
sogenannte flexibilisierung von arbeits
zeit in den mittelpunkt zu stellen das
klingt für viele jugendliche zu recht
nicht gerade nach traumberuf liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und eine eine antwort wir können uns
selber andere themen in dem bereich
unterhalten eine antwort auf den
fachkräftemangel müssen aus unserer
sicht gute und faire ausbildungs und
später arbeitsbedingungen seien die die
fachkräfte auch in der branche halten
und da kann eine nationale tourismus
strategie einen beitrag leisten wir
müssen da auch über forschung und lehre
diskutieren
und wir müssen auch über die anerkennung
von ausländischen qualifikationen an der
stelle diskutieren und ein wichtiger
punkt ein vierter punkt ist die
förderpolitik die unternehmen die uns
als reise an standort attraktiv machen
die brauchen mittel um ihn das produkt
zu investieren da fehlt es bei den
vielen banken heute an expertise die
förderlandschaft ist zersplittert und
deswegen brauchen wir eine zentrale
anlaufstelle mit förderung aus einer
hand wo man auf fragen des
bürokratieabbaus bündeln kann stichwort
tourismus bank da brauchen wir haben wir
großen nachholbedarf und das muss im
rahmen einer nationalen tourismus
strategie auf die agenda
was wir brauchen für die nationale
tourismus strategie ist politischen
nachdruck wir brauchen keine weitere
zustandsbeschreibung sondern wir
brauchen einen konkreten handlungsrahmen
herr staatssekretär das eine oder andere
kann man übrigens auch schon ohne
nationale tourismusstrategie zeitnah an
gehen in dieser frage
und deswegen haben wir das nicht mehr
länger auf die lange bank die nächste
wahl kommt spätestens 2021 und wenn wir
die strategie nicht nur auf dem papier
sondern auch in der umsetzung haben
wollen dann muss das jetzt zeitnah
passieren
herzlichen dank für auf menschen vielen
dank markus tressel
nächster redner paul lehrieder für die
cdu/csu-fraktion serie damen und herren
liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen seger
die frau präsidentin seit mehreren
jahren boomt der tourismus in
deutschland
wir haben beständig zu wechseln
staatssekretär hat darauf hingewiesen
bei gästeübernachtungen die im letzten
jahr erneut um 4 prozent auf immerhin
nunmehr aktuell 477 millionen gestiegen
sind
deutschland ist nicht nur bei
auslandsreisen weltweit mit an der
spitze sondern auch als reiseziel immer
attraktiver gehört dass es gar nicht
verkehrt dass im unmittelbaren vorfeld
der ezb über das thema tourismus
tourismusstrategie hier im bundestag zu
debattieren
gleichzeitig sehen wir aber auch dass
wir die chancen der branche für die
wirtschaftliche entwicklung und ihr
potenzial in vielen bereichen noch nicht
ausgeschöpft haben und von einer reihe
von herausforderungen stehen auch durch
die zunehmende internationale konkurrenz
deshalb haben wir in der großen
koalition eine nationale tourismus
strategie des bundes vereinbar
um die rahmenbedingungen für die
mittelständisch geprägte
tourismuswirtschaft in deutschland
weiter zu verbessern
wir wollen die bundesförderung noch
effizienter gestalten die belange der
branche in allen politikbereichen noch
besser berücksichtigen und noch mehr
bewusstsein für die große bedeutung der
tourismuswirtschaft schaffen
und ja und ja herr kollege doch der
klinge lieber massen
sie haben in ihrem antrag einiges ihr
habt in eurem antrag einiges was
tatsächlich erwähnenswert ist im übrigen
auch in dem antrag der linken mit
ausnahme des komplett kostenfreien op en
vs wenn wir nicht hinbekommen verpassen
auf jeden fall sie haben ausgeführt wird
hier was tatsächlich eben noch
einbezogen kann und was wo ich ihnen
zugestehen ist das wäre lieber einige
big points in der tourismusstrategie die
wir dann auch realistisch in den
nächsten jahren umsetzen können
produzieren können als immer 132 unter
punkte in dem positionspapier unseres
koalitionspartners englisch tier
abarbeiten wollen dass wenn wir die
nächsten jahre sicher nicht alles eben
umsetzen können wir werden auch mehr
doch tun als in der tourismusstrategie
steht dann wenn versichern wir hatten
gestern ein gespräch zum was ist mit
unserer ag wir hatten vorgestern die
anhörung
im kinder- und jugendtourismus frau
kollegin kassen im ausschuss werden
letzte woche stichwort bürokratieabbau
was sie in ihrem antrag gegeben haben
mit dem namen kontrolldaten wieder
kollegin der ehemaligen kollegin mayer
bonde im gespräch über bürokratieabbau
bürokratische belastung wird diskutiert
auch über sachen die nicht unbedingt
jetzt schon fixiert sind sie dürfen
versichert sein der tourismus die
tourismuspolitik herr kollege klinge
nicht schwätzen wenn ich mit ihnen
sprechen sie dürfen versichert sie dann
versichert sein dass wir neben der
tourismusstrategie die belange der
tourismus tätige nämlich wirklich
umsetzen und wir diskutieren
leidenschaftlich um eine große sache
darüber wir haben über den digitalen
meldeschein letzte woche mit dem start
erklärt marco wanderwitz im heimat
ministerium gesprochen
die möglichkeiten das entsprechend hier
abzubauen zu erleichtern
wir sind da auf einem guten weg und
wissen ich habe als einigendes ihren
ausführungen gehört das sind schon noch
phantomschmerzen vom neunzehnten auf den
20 november 2017 bei ihnen da lieber
nicht regieren als falscher gehen haben
die brache frau präsidentin ja natürlich
ich frage und e-reader ob dazu lässt er
lässt zu herr dr
vielen dank herr kollege redet dass er
die zwischenfrage zu lassen ich will den
zunächst noch einen ganz zentralen punkt
zustimmen
selbstverständlich hätte der tourismus
in einer jamaika koalition an völlig
anderen stellenwert gehabt irgendwie
aktuellen großen koalition spaß in
diesem falle würde die fdp den
wirtschaftsminister oder die
wirtschaftsministerin stellen also das
versteht sich von selbst
sie haben vielleicht noch gut in
erinnerung dass der zentrale knackpunkt
für das scheitern von jamaika ihre
notorische ablehnung einer konsequenten
auslaufen des solidaritätszuschlags war
die grünen als auch die union haben uns
in diesem zentralen punkt sind sie uns
uns in diesem zentralen punkten nicht
entgegengekommen
deswegen möchte ich sie fragen hat sich
die haltung der unionsfraktion zum thema
satz loses auslaufenden
solidaritätszuschlags in den letzten 16
monaten geändert und ich frage dies auch
vor dem hintergrund dass die fdp
fraktion erst vor wenigen wochen eine
namentliche abstimmung genau zu diesem
antrag zu diesem thema beantragt hat und
alle 246 mitglieder der unionsfraktion
nicht für die ersatzlose streichung des
solidarität
zuschlags gestimmt haben liebe kollegen
doping
ich war nicht in der auch
verhandlungspositionen deinem bett zu
schlafen und 90 prozent abbauen und
diese schon fixiert haben dann ist es
eine legendenbildung zu sagen wir hätten
uns verweigert den komplett abbau
zustimmen aber sie wissen selbst sie
sind jetzt neu im bundestag alles kann
man noch nicht voraussetzen
sie wissen aber selbst politik beginnt
mit dem betrachten der realität wenn aus
kostengründen aus fiskalischen gründen
hat noch keine 100 prozent möglich sind
dann fängt man mit 90 prozent an wenn
dann spielräume sich ergeben weiter
abzubauen dann streben wir das an dass
in der großen koalition in guten händen
besagt das hätte man möglicherweise mit
jamaika auch hinbekommen ist frau
kollegin zu den wir haben den bereich
familien mit verhandeln dürfen
da war auch nicht immer alles wird
möglich steuerpflichtig aber wir hätten
uns schon zusammen geraucht und
partnerschaft mit lebensgemeinschaft
gegeben für ein paar jahre letztendlich
mit der man auch hätten gut leben können
aber im endeffekt wir arbeiten daran den
solidaritätszuschlag komplett abzubauen
aber die machbarkeit ist immer
entsprechend von physikalischen aspekten
auch abhängig das sollten sie auch
wissen herr kollege dr klingen hören
würden sie noch harrieder vielen
herzlichen dank dass sie die
zwischenfrage zu lassen
ich halte mich auch ganz kurz kurze
zwischenfrage teilen sie die auffassung
ihres koalitionspartners der spd das
werde das problem der
gewerbesteuerlichen hinzurechnung nicht
mehr politisch lösen sollten sondern uns
auf die gerichtsurteile verlassen ein
kurzes jahr dann als antwort würde mir
reichen sie können nur die antwort nicht
vorschreiben und ob ich ja oder nein
sache und wie ich das beantworte ist
immer noch meine sache sie haben vom 1.2
wir haben hier auf ihren antrag vor ein
paar monaten über die gewerbesteuerliche
hinzurechnung bereits debattiert da
haben wir haben uns gedanken gemacht man
sagt ja wohl
es ist aus meiner sicht ähnlich sache
des gesetzgebers zu sagen wenn ein
gesetz aus unserer sicht falsch ist dass
wir uns richtig der bundesfinanzhof eben
verstecken aber es ist wie in jeder
partnerschaft wir brauchen ein konsens
wieder zeit und wir diskutieren glück
hat mit unserem koalitionspartner
ob wir da irgendwas auf die reihe
bekommen oder ob er fahren müssen
mit uns insofern um die reisebüros ein
stück weit leid du dann mit
rückstellungen natürlich ein gewisses
damoklesschwert über sich haben
das sollten wir uns überlegen ob man da
kleinen und mittleren gewerbebetrieben
30 büros busunternehmen entsprechend ihr
genügend oder gerecht werden wenn wir
das nicht lösen das problem also wer
wann die arbeiten aber sie davon
versichert sein
dieses problem ist bei der großen
koalition in guten händen das theater
nicht glaubt ist mir schon klar meine
damen und herren schwerpunkte
schwerpunkte in der tourismusstrategie
wollen wir auf die stärkung der
ländlichen räume legen die weitere
erschließung von ausländischen
quellmärkten mit glaube diese ganz
wichtiges thema incoming tourismus
stichwort deutsche zentrale für
tourismus in frankfurt da haben wir die
mittel erhöht um mehr gäste für
deutschland zu begeistern
die unterstützung der branche bei der
digitalisierung auch da haben sie
natürlich ein stück bei einem antrag
recht zu sagen kennen wir schon können
es erreichen dass eben auch kleine
anbieter im ländlichen raum natürlich
eben die möglichkeit haben online ihre
produkte agent her an den mann zu
bringen
die förderung umweltfreundlicher
angebote sowie natürlich auch dem ausbau
der barrierefreiheit stichwort tourismus
für alle stich und inklusive tourismus
da gibt es genug zu tun wo die
schwerpunkte in der tourismusstrategie
sein werden wenn wir die nächsten wochen
lebhaft mit unserem koalitionspartner
und mit der bundesregierung diskutiert
lieber thomas bareiß freue mich auf die
konstruktive debatte den ex miss schweiz
der asche wieder vor mir auf die
konstruktiven debatte die nächsten
wochen wünsche ihnen noch einen schönen
darf dankeschön paul lehrieder für die
unionsfraktion hat es nicht leicht
gehabt in seinem beitrag hingabe oder
geschwatzt und dann muss er sich auch
noch ein verbales scharmützel liefern
mit dem abgeordneten klinge aus der fdp
fraktion immer wieder erstaunlich wie
häufig dieses jamaika scheitern doch
noch bei dem einen oder anderen eine
etwas größere rolle spielt so jetzt
thema durchgegriffen von claudia roth
und die nächste rednerin darf ans pult
und auch sprechen gül ist ein wechsel
für die spd fraktion
danke
so musste es ja vielen dank frau
präsidentin meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren auf den tribünen liebe
kolleginnen kollegen
der tourismus ist wie keine andere
branche von weltoffenheit und gas
freundschaft geprägt das wurde in
einigen beiträgen auch eben deutlich es
muss auch deswegen in unser aller
interesse sein diese zu fördern kinder
und kinder und jugendreisen sind hierfür
eine gute möglichkeit denn in ihnen
liegt ein besonderes bildungspotenzial
sie fördern die
persönlichkeitsentwicklung herr lerida
danke denn denn dänin
denn in ihnen liegt ein besonderes
bildungspotenzial sie fördern die
persönlichkeitsentwicklung und sie
vermitteln wichtige werte wie toleranz
neugier und eben weltoffenheit und das
wollen wir allen ermöglichen eine studie
des bundeswirtschaftsministeriums aus
2014 hat gezeigt dass drei von vier
kindern und jungen menschen in
deutschland mindestens einmal im jahr
verreisen dass es gut wir dürfen aber
jene junge menschen nicht vergessen die
aus verschiedenen gründen keine
möglichkeit dazu haben wir wollen dass
auch sie reise erfahrungen sammeln
können
zur überwindung finanzielle hürden
bietet der bund mit dem bildungs und
teilhabepaket bereits eine gute ein
gutes instrument
dies bestätigten auch die experten in
der anhörung im tourismusausschuss am
mittwoch wir waren ja alle anwesend
demnach bestehen eher praktische hürden
bei der durchführung von klassenreisen
hier stehen aber vor allem die länder in
der pflicht liebe kollegen frau kastner
das haben die sachverständigen uns auch
mitgeteilt
wir fordern daher entschuldigung wir
fordern daher in unserem positionspapier
zur nationalen tourismus strategie auch
eine stärkere wertschätzung von kinder-
und jugendtourismus
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen so
erfreulich der wachsende nationale
tourismus sektor auch ist wirklich
erstrebenswert ist ein nachhaltiger
tourismus dieser muss im sinne der
agenda 20.30 ökologisch sozial und
wirtschaftlich nachhaltig sein
entsprechend eindeutig und ausführlicher
als im vorigen antrag der linken sind
unsere erwartungen an die nationale
tourismus strategie auch hier gemeinsam
mit allen akteuren im tourismus wollen
wir entlang der gesamten
wertschöpfungskette den schädlichen
auswirkungen des tourismus
entgegenwirken
gleichzeitig gilt es die potenziale des
tourismus für nachhaltige entwicklung zu
nutzen und das sowohl im nationalen
kontext als auch in den liegt
entwicklungszusammenarbeit
deshalb halten wir zahlreiche maßnahmen
auf den unterschiedlichen
zuständigkeiten für erforderlich liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen so etwa die
einführung einer staatlich getragene
zertifizierung für mindestanforderungen
an nachhaltigen reisen
diese würde beispielsweise angaben zur
co2-emission einschließen so schaffen
wir die nötige transparenz durch die
reisenden nachhaltigkeit zum buchungs
kriterium machen können
staatliche behörden sollten dabei
vorbild charakter haben indem sie
klimafreundliche transportmittel zum
zentralen auswahlkriterium ihrer reise
bestehen machen
liebe kollegen kollegen die drei minuten
sind schon um mit diesen und vielen
weiteren vorschlägen stellen wir die
weichen für einen nachhaltigen tourismus
ich freue mich auf die gemeinsamen
beratung in den kommenden monaten in
diesem sinne wünsche ich ihnen allen
eine später eine gute fahrt am besten
mit der bahn in ihre wahlkreise
herzlichen dank wünscht minister
wechsele den abgeordneten des deutschen
bundestages der heute nicht besonders
lange tag denn man nimmt rücksicht auf
einen europa parteitag in der linken der
ab heute abend in bonn stattfindet
michael theurer aus der fdp fraktion ist
der vorletzte redner in dieser
aussprache zur nationalen tourismus
strategie betont und unterstrichen aber
ich halte an der stelle nur fest hätte
die fdp fraktion durch unseren kollegen
dr marcel klinge nicht den antrag
vorgelegt und hätten wir es nicht zum
top thema dieser woche gemacht dann
würde dieses parlament gar nicht über
diese nationale tourismus strategie
sprechen es war gut dass wir freien
demokraten dass beantragt haben und nun
zu ihnen sehr geehrter staatssekretär
bahr als ihre bemühungen ihre anstellung
sind ja aller ehren wert aber im grunde
genommen ist es doch erforderlich dass
der bundeswirtschaftsminister sich
dieses themas zur chefsache macht er hat
angekündigt ein mittelstands ministerium
sein zu wollen ein service ministerium
für den mittelstand aber wenn man
anschaut was der minister altmaier tut
dann legt er eine nationale industrie
strategie vor was er nicht ist er ist
kein mittelstands minister wenn er etwas
ist dann ist er ein monopol minister den
er philosophiert öffentlich darüber wie
man industriekonzerne fluss syrien kann
anstatt als die rahmenbedingungen für
kleine und mittlere betriebe verbessert
wird und genau das ist notwendig und wir
freie demokraten reden da nicht nur
darüber sondern wir haben konkrete
initiativen und gesetzesentwürfe hier in
den deutschen bundestag eingebracht etwa
das thema flexibilisierung des
arbeitszeitgesetzes um den neuen
anforderungen durch die digitalisierung
und globalisierung besser rechnung zu
tragen und bürokratie im mittelstand
abzubauen eingebracht im märz 2018
abgelehnt von den fraktionen die die
große koalition tragen oder auch dass
bürokratie entlastungsgesetz drei wann
kommt denn im koalitionsvertrag steht
drin
wir glauben nicht dass sie das zeitnah
vorlegen werden oder auch die
abschaffung des solidaritätszuschlags
ist bereits angesprochen wurden oder das
thema minijob verdienstgrenze anpassen
an den mindestlohn die dynamisierung
davon sind ja nun wirklich mio
einen menschen in der gastronomie in der
hotellerie betroffen und wir haben einen
akuten fachkräftemangel dort und gerade
im bereich der teilzeit und minijobs
muss es eine verbesserung geben wir sind
der festen überzeugung wenn
mittelstandspolitik nicht nur in
sonntagsreden sondern auch in der arbeit
im parlament hier auf die tagesordnung
kommen würde dann könnte man den
menschen im der gastronomie und
hotellerie im tourismus das leben
wesentlich erleichtern denn sie
verbrauchen anstatt an kunden am gast zu
arbeiten anstatt zu kochen und die
menschen zu verwöhnen verschwenden die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter in den
tourismus und hotelbetrieben ihre zeit
mit zettelwirtschaft ihre zeit mit
dokumentationspflichten da muss alles
dokumentiert werden über die
brotschneidemaschine über den fett ab
schneider das ist bürokratie pur meine
damen und herren an der stelle sollte
minister altmaier seinen ankündigungen
entlastung und mittelstand in den
mittelpunkt zu rücken jetzt endlich auch
taten folgen lassen und wir werden die
regierung an der stelle treiben
vielen vielen dank michael theurer und
der letzte redner in der debatte zur
nationalen nationalen tourismus
strategie ist dr klaus peter schulze für
die cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
erste frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen
kollegen meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren wir haben im koalitionsvertrag
mit der spd
das erste mal verankert dass eine
tourismusstrategie auf den weg gebracht
werden soll damit sind wir im vergleich
zu den vorangegangenen
legislaturperioden in deutlichen schritt
nach vorn gekommen und der zweite punkt
das muss ich ihm zugestehen die kollegen
von der fdp bzw
von den linken durch ihren antrag haben
wir in einer kernzeit die möglichkeit
dieses thema ganz einfach zu diskutieren
dafür herzlichen dank aber kollege
teurer wenn sie sagen in den hotels
zettelwirtschaft glaube ich sie haben
lange nicht mehr im hotel übernachtet da
geht mittlerweile alles elektronisch und
digital
denn dort ist die digitalisierung schon
angekommen und zudem bashing was dem
staatssekretär hier übrigen über
geholfen wurde in sachen tourismus
strategie und es passiert nichts dann
frage ich sie herr münzenmaier wo waren
sie denn am dritten zwölften wo der
tourismus beirat der des
wirtschaftsministeriums getagt hat und
der staatssekretär nur sechs stunden mit
den fachleuten aus deutschland
diskutiert hat wie wir die
tourismusstrategie bringen die einladung
habe ich auch rechtzeitig bekommen
übrigens war ich der einzige abgeordnete
der dort anwesend war kurz aber wichtige
dinge kann man dann auch mal verlagern
aber meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren kommen wir zu zwei punkten die
für mich für größere von großer
bedeutung sind damit sie auch in den
bestandteil dieser tourismusstrategie
wären erstens wir haben eine sehr gute
entwicklung des tourismus in den großen
städten wenn ich mir die zahlen von 2017
angucke wo münchen leipzig im plus von
14 prozent hatten köln immerhin von neun
prozent und hamburg von fünf prozent im
ländlichen raum sieht es nicht so aus
dort ist es deutlich schwieriger die dzt
die wir ja in diesem jahr erstmalig mit
mehr als 30 millionen euro unterstützen
hat im jahr 2016 damit begonnen den
ländlichen raum stärker zu bewerben und
ein guter erfolg muss man sagen war das
lutherjahr dort hat sie ja international
werbung für deutschland gemacht
insbesondere für die lutherstadt
wittenberg und dort ist es also so
gewesen dass in sachsen anhalt die
übernachtungszahlen und 14 prozent
angestiegen sind ich denke das ist ein
gutes ergebnis und dann können wir
zufrieden sein dass wir die dzt h die
international unterwegs ist und ich
glaube die kolleginnen die in peking in
nordamerika und in österreich unterwegs
und für uns arbeiten haben wir beifall
verdient in dem zusammenhang möchte ich
noch mal auf das thema ländlichen raum
zurück kommen hier sind aus meiner sicht
große potenziale zu heben die teilweise
sich sehr gut entwickelt haben mich
erinnern unser 16 nationalpark sich
erinnern an die 16 biosphärenreservate
und hier gelingt es zunehmend besser
regionale produkte die von kleinen
mittelständischen unternehmen erbracht
werden an den touristen zu bringen sie
haben damit eine gute umsatzentwicklung
auf dem weg sollten wir zukünftig unter
anderem auch durch abbau von bürokratie
die entsprechende unterstützung geben
der zweite punkt den die ansprechen
möchte den wir unbedingt berücksichtigen
müssen ist das thema kreuzfahrten die
kreuzfahrer die in den häfen liegen und
mit janz noch selbst laufenden
kraftwerken dafür sorgen dass die
emissionen anfallen
stop und hendrix deutlich höher sind als
alle diesel fahrzeuge zb in hamburg
da müssen wir etwas tun und ich sage der
erste schritt muss sein
landstromversorgung der zweite schritt
muss sein katalytische nachverbrennung
in den abgasanlagen und der dritte
schritt und das ist dann der
entscheidende die kreuzfahrer müssen auf
led umgestellt werden herzlichen dank
für ihre aufmärsche für die
unionsfraktion noch mal da war der
letzte redner jetzt in dieser debatte
zur nationalen tourismus strategie jetzt
wird hier zunächst einmal der antrag der
fdp in den zuständigen ausschuss für
tourismus überwiesen
und dann wird eine beschlussempfehlung
abgestimmt aus dem ausschuss für
tourismus und zwar zum antrag der linken
die nationale tourismusstrategie sozial
ökologisch gestalten die
beschlussempfehlung aus dem ausschuss
lautet diesen antrag abzulehnen also
wird es eine mehrheit für die sich für
diese beschlussempfehlung geben und das
bedeutet dann dass aber der antrag der
linksfraktion abgelehnt worden sein wird
jetzt gucken wir auf den
tagesordnungspunkt 26 dieser
sitzungswoche im deutschen bundestag es
geht um einen antrag der fraktion
bündnis 90/die grünen und es geht um
feministische außenpolitik weil sie das
noch nicht gehört haben es ist auch noch
nicht ganz so im öffentlichen bild
angekommen ist es geht zurück die idee
eigentlich zumindest auf eine uno
resolution aus dem jahr 2000 in der
nämlich anerkannt wird dass vor allem
frauen und kinder von bewaffneten
konflikten und kriegen betroffen sind
aber zugleich mehr als 90 prozent der
offiziellen friedensvermittler weltweit
männlich sind also geht es in erster
linie darum so wie es auch
beispielsweise die schwedische
außenministerin war und schon einmal
formuliert hat wohl die schweden ja
feministische außenpolitik schon machen
indem ich das ziel sich zu setzen die
rechte repräsentation und die ressourcen
von allen frauen und mädchen zu stärken
und das bedeutet eben unter anderem auch
dass schwedens botschafter position
zunehmend mit frauen besetzt werden
jetzt hat claudia roth die
bundestags-vizepräsidentin diesen
tagesordnungspunkt eröffnet und die
aussprache dazu an joschka buga wird die
erste rednerin sein wo sie
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
ist nämlich bei den grünen
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
wer sich über das thema feministische
außenpolitik lustig macht wie die afg da
macht sich heutzutage einfach nur noch
selber lächerlich und dass sie ein
problem mit frauen haben sieht man ja
auch daran muss man einfach nur in ihre
reihen auf eine feministische
außenpolitik das heißt die rechte die
repräsentation und die ressourcen von
frauen sicherzustellen und zu stärken
es geht um geld aber es geht auch um
perspektiven und es geht um potenziale
und außenminister maas hat sich ja schon
sehr wolkig auch zu dieser idee bekannt
und wir legen in unserem antrag sehr
viele sehr pragmatische vorschläge vor
wie deutschland in diesem jahr im vn
sicherheitsrat und im nächsten jahr im
rahmen der eu ratspräsidentschaft dem
ganz konkret pragmatische taten folgen
lassen kann
schweden und kanada die haben das schon
auf der internationalen bühne vorgemacht
wie es geht und dass das ehrlich gesagt
auch ziemlich cool ist und es geht dabei
überhaupt nicht darum dass frauen die
besseren menschen sind
worum es geht das wird im handbuch der
schwedischen regierung sehr klar und
bestechend erklärt zitat die
feministische außenpolitik sie beginne
beginnt und endet mit der realität sie
basiert auf fakten und statistiken zum
alltag für mädchen und frauen
und sie möchte konkrete ergebnisse im
leben von menschen übrigens nicht nur
frau erzielen andernfalls verliert sie
ihre relevanz meine damen und herren
noch immer sind die rechte von frauen
weltweit unter beschuss und wieder mehr
wenn frauen nicht selbst entscheiden
können wo wie und mit wem sie leben
wenn populisten wie die präsidentin
stramm und ball szenario mit
frauenfeindlichen parolen hass säen
wenn frauen und mädchen bei der
verteilung von hilfsgütern leer ausgeht
wenn vergewaltigung und abscheuliches
sexualisierte gewalt in kriegen
systematisch als waffe eingesetzt werden
dann braucht es eine klare und laute
stimme für diese frauen und es braucht
jemanden dafür ihre rechte kämpft das
internationale kies institut hat
friedensprozesse weltweit untersucht und
festgestellt dass ein stabiler frieden
um mehr als ein drittel wahrscheinlicher
wird wenn frauen am prozess beteiligt
werden
allerdings sind nur 8 500 stellen an den
tischen von friedensverhandlungen von
frauen besetzt und das muss sich endlich
ändern
übrigens sollte man nicht immer noch mit
dem finger in die ferne zeigen wenn wir
glaubwürdig für die frech rechte von
frauen eintreten wollen müssen wir auch
auf dem internationalen parkett
gleichberechtigt frauen in erster reihe
haben und wie sieht es da in den
deutschen botschaften aus der zeit 20
botschafterin und 132 botschafter das
sind keine zahlen aus die heiko maas
stolz sein kann und da erwarten wir
schnelle veränderungen in halle damen
und herren ich sitze jetzt seit ungefähr
zehn jahren im verteidigungsausschuss
und er kriegt man als junge frau so sie
nämlich mal junge frau war so sachen zu
können wie das mädchen ist ja gut
vorbereitet und ja frau bürger wenn sie
dann mal alt werden das ist ja alles ein
bisschen idealistisch unterlief dazu
möchte ich zwei sachen kurz sagen
die erste ist wenn ich mir die düstere
welt lage anschauen und auch manchmal
die verschlafen haid und steifheit der
deutschen außenpolitik wir muss ich
sagen so eine prise idealismus sie kann
dem ganzen nicht nur schaden sondern die
kann die weltpolitik gut gebrauchen und
meine zweite bewirtschafte gehen raus an
alle frauen und vor allem mädchen da
draußen
lasst euch nicht entmutigen glaubt an
euch selbst macht euer eigenes ding geht
euren eigenen weg vielen dank
in der stadt lucca hat die erste rede
gehalten zu einem antrag der grünen hier
zum thema feministische außenpolitik in
dem antrag fordert die fraktion ja das
prinzip einer feministischen
außenpolitik zu einem der
grundprinzipien der deutschen
außenpolitik zu erklären und somit einen
friedens sozial und
menschenrechtspolitischen beitrag in der
welt zu leisten elisabeth motschmann
jetzt für die unionsfraktion weimarer
nationalversammlung hielt löste das laut
protokoll heiterkeit aus heute 100 jahre
später reden wir über feministische
außenpolitik und wieder gibt es diese
heiterkeit und wieder gibt es vier
männer da drüben seid wirklich sehr sehr
berechenbar
aber es ist nichts
heiterkeit kann was schönes sein und ich
bin da auch immer dabei aber es gibt
auch eine abschätzige heiterkeit wir
frauen kennen das hinter dieser
heiterkeit verbirgt sich die frage
vieler nicht alle männer die häufig
gehört habe in den letzten tagen was
soll das denn jetzt oder habt ihr keine
anderen probleme
oder wie albern ist das denn für uns ist
diese heiterkeit nicht selten der humus
für sowie witze und davon haben wir
frauen genug was bedeutet nun
feministischer außenpolitik erstens die
aktive teilhabe von frauen an der außen
und sicherheitspolitik die außenpolitik
muss weiblicher werden
und leider übrigens die grünen die den
antrag gestellt haben ihr habt keine
einzige frau als ordentliches mitglied
im auswärtigen ausschuss das kann auch
noch besser werden
soviel zur feministischen außenpolitik
inhaltlich geht es um die interessen das
wurde ja eben auch schon gesagt um die
interessen die rechte und den schutz von
frauen vor gewalt und unterdrückung es
wir müssen als frauen in der
außenpolitik anwältin der schwächsten
sein die sich nicht selbst verteidigen
können
wenn mehr frauen in der außen und
sicherheitspolitik agieren ändert sich
der blickwinkel auf die forscher aus
berlin dämpfer und amsterdam haben
friedensverträge ausgewertet und
festgestellt frieden ist nachhaltiger
wenn frauen mit
verhandlungstisch gesessen haben leider
ist außenpolitik in unserem land und
weltweit nach wie vor eine männerdomäne
wenn es um krieg und frieden geht sitzen
keine bzw nur sehr sehr wenige frauen an
den verhandlungstischen und das genau
muss sich ändern
an dieser stelle gleich dann oft was
wollt ihr denn ihr habt doch eine
bundeskanzlerin ja die ja gesagt das ja
alles wunderbar ihr seid so berechenbar
und sowieso entschuldigung blöd ja ja
die haben sie ja und sie ist
außenpolitisch auch sehr gut unterwegs
und erfolgreich aber angela merkel warnt
aber selber zitat aus der tatsache dass
es mich gibt darf kein alibi werden also
immer noch dominieren dunkle
herrenanzüge die parlamente es ginge
auch anders
übrigens auch bei der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz dominieren die
dunklen herrenanzüge obwohl es einige
wenige frauen mehr gab in diesem jahr
auch das ginge anders frauen wollen und
können außenpolitisch tätig sein und
frauen sind dafür auch besonders
geeignet wir sind gute diplomaten gute
brückenbauerin nicht konfrontation
sondern ausgleich der verschiedenen
interesse interessen ist unser
grundprinzip und dies alles im treff im
interesse der schwächsten der frauen und
im interesse der freak des friedens in
der welt
es gibt ja gute ansätze auch das haben
wir eben genannt vieles von dem was im
antrag steht wird auch schon gemacht ich
nenne drei punkte erstens der nationale
aktionsplan der bundesregierung zur
resolution 13 25 zweitens die
eu-taskforce zu frauen frieden und
sicherheit und drittens die
unterstützung der bundesregierung
vom african women leaders network
der antrag ist ein weg uns und das finde
ich durchaus gut
allerdings ich komme zum ende frau
präsidentin allerdings mit 33
forderungen auf neun seiten an die
bundesregierung überfrachten sie das
thema und verzetteln sich weniger wäre
mehr
deshalb lehnen wir den antrag ab ich
will ja am ende sagen am beginn meiner
politischen arbeit vor 40 jahren hätte
ich allergrößte probleme mit dem begriff
feminismus gehabt wenn es aber um die
rechte die teilhabe von frauen in allen
bereichen unserer gesellschaft und
weltweit geht dann habe ich heute kein
problem mehr mit dem feminismus
vielen dank
elisabeth motschmann war das mit einem
überraschenden bekenntnis kann man
glaube ich wohl so sagen aber sie hat
auch noch halten satz feministischen
aussenpolitik vielen vielen dank elisa
und da gibt es jetzt nochmal applaus
auch aus dem linken reihen des
parlaments der nächste redner in der
debatte zum thema feministische
außenpolitik ist peter wistron aus der
afg fraktion
jetzt kommt meine güte
sehr geehrte damen und herren wir müssen
uns heute mit einem sexistischen antrag
und claudia roth und ihren
künstlerkollektiv beschäftigen ich
trenne bewusst zwischen den autorinnen
und dem rest der fraktion denn einigen
gründeten sie ist dieses elaborat
peinlich wir werden gleich sehen warum
kostprobe aus dem papier
frauen und mädchen werden in allen
regionen in allen regionen der erde
diskriminiert ihnen werden gleiche
rechte verwehrt und es wird verhindert
dass sie politisch gesellschaftlich und
wirtschaftlich gleichberechtigt
teilhaben können
das schreibt das schreibt eine frau
vizepräsidentin eines parlaments in
einem land in dem seit 13 jahren eine
frau regiert frau roth schlagen sie
grundgesetz nach männer und frauen sind
gleichberechtigt
frauen werden nicht in allen ländern der
welt diskriminiert sie und raum härter
sind die besten beispiele dafür
oder wurde etwa angela merkel zum achten
mal nacheinander zum mächtigsten frau
der welt gekürt auch strukturell
diskriminiert und an der
gleichberechtigten politischen teilhabe
gehindert von wem denn helmut kohl
roland koch friedrich merz christian
wulff oder wolfgang schäuble
ja ja es gibt es gibt länder in denen
frauen durch mittelalterliche
patriarchalische strukturen unterdrückt
und benachteiligt werden
es sind allesamt islamischer länder und
das verschweigen sie in ihrem antrag
das passt nicht zu ihrer ideologie sie
selbst frau roth haben ihren antrag
völlig wertlos gemacht indem sie sich im
iran diesen strukturen unterworfen haben
anstatt also bitte
so hat es drohen ich versuche hier die
sitzungen zu leiten ich bitte sie
ich bitte wenden sie sich an die
kolleginnen und kollegen und ich werde
dann gegebenenfalls auf ihrer geschichte
an politischen diskussion im hause das
wiederum passt
wir werden diese äußerung von herrn gies
und selbstverständlich im nächsten
ältestenrat befassen wer hier würdig ist
und wer nicht würdig ist und ich müssen
sie ja dass in ihrer rede fortzuführen
sie selbst vor roth haben ihren antrag
wertlos gemacht indem sie in iran den
frauen in den rücken gefallen sind die
ins gefängnis gesteckt werden wenn sie
auf der straße ohne kopftuch gehen sie
haben mit den mullahs paktiert und dabei
auch noch das symbol der unterwerfung
das kopftuch aufgesetzt
das ist für minister politik aller
claudia roth was für minister politik
aber angela merkel bedeutet sehen wir in
den letzten vier jahren rexit zerstört
der eu das gemeinsame europa gespalten
und deutschland international isoliert
meine damen und herren sie sehen selbst
dieser antrag ist ein missbrauch des
parlaments für kultur marxistischer
propaganda
die autorin dann wollen sich lediglich
mehr geld und macht sichern mit quoten
für jobs für die ihnen die qualifikation
fehlt und frau roth
sie wollen einen paradigmenwechsel den
sollen sie haben wir brauchen einen
paradigmenwechsel denn die alt 68er
haben den letzten 50 jahren genug
schaden angerichtet
so wie frau merkel europa spaltet
spalten sie unsere gesellschaft sie
hetzen frauen gegen männer auf
homosexuelle gegen hetze gegen schwarze
behinderte gegen nichtbehinderte
das lassen wir uns nicht mehr von ihnen
gefallen wir brauchen wir brauchen keine
spaltung wir brauchen keine quoten ein
staat treibt außenpolitik um seine
interessen zu vertreten nicht die
interessen seiner frauen sondern die
interessen aller seiner bürger
wir brauchen daher eine
verantwortungsvolle außenpolitik für
alle bürger dieses landes und im moment
am meisten für einen mann für billy six
denn sie im gefängnis verrotten lassen
[Applaus]
frau roth ich spreche daher für jeden
einzelnen unserer wähler über acht
millionen menschen lehnen ihren antrag
geschlossen
nächste rednerin in dieser debatte
michelle müntefering für die
bundesregierung vom winter für endete
herzlichen dank frau präsidentin christa
ich gehe nicht weiter auf sie ein sie
haben ihr verständnis von gleichstellung
und gleichberechtigung von frauen hier
gestern schon deutlich gemacht oder soll
ich besser sagen ihr unverständnis
dieser antrag hat keine berechtigung
diese debatte lohnt sich ellinor von
puttkamer war die erste botschafterin
der bundesrepublik deutschland 69
ernannt durch den damaligen
außenminister willy brandt zuvor hatte
das auswärtige amt ganz offiziell
bescheinigt sie hat einen durchaus
männlichen verstand das sollte wohl ein
lob sein
mit verlaub an so einem grundsätzlichen
männlichen verstand habe ich nicht nur
mit blick auf so manche staatenlenker
dieser welt meine zweifel
aber es tut sich etwas auf im
auswärtigen amt bei der besetzung von
spitzenämtern mit frauen wenngleich sie
wissen 33 prozent in der berliner
zentrale in führungspositionen aber auch
15 prozent leiterin im ausland das ist
nicht genug es gibt noch viel zu tun es
gibt luft nach oben auch beim
berichtswesen unserer botschaften etwa
mit heiko maas kolleginnen und kollegen
mit heiko maas haben wir einen
außenminister der das thema nicht nur
verstanden hat sondern für den auch
gleichberechtigung kein fremdwort ist
und wir sind uns bewusst dass wir noch
besser werden können die teilhabe von
frauen an politischen prozessen ist eben
noch lange keine selbstverständlichkeit
und deswegen finde ich es gut dass die
opposition von den grünen heute einen
impuls ein
von denen mit vorschlägen auch mit
konkreten vorschlägen ja von denen wir
einige schon umsetzen andere auch schon
angefasst haben
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
wissen heute und wir haben es auch grad
schon von frau muss man gehört
friedensverträge sind stabiler und
halten länger wenn auch frauen beteiligt
sind
es sind besonders frauen betroffen wo
krieg herrscht vergewaltigung ausbeutung
sexuelle gewalt das wird ganz gezielt
als demütigung von völkern als
kriegswaffe eingesetzt und deswegen
arbeiten wir auch mit den lokalen
bevölkerungen zusammen ein beispiel die
abrüstungs kampagnen die wir im
ländlichen nigeria unterstützt haben
hätten ohne die ein beziehungen und die
überzeugungskraft weiblicher
führungskräfte gar nicht funktioniert
ohne die bedürfnisse der hälfte der
bevölkerung zu berücksichtigen können
wir keine gute politik machen ohne sie
einzubeziehen können wir keine
demokratie fördern und ohne ihnen
sicherheit zu geben können wir keinen
frieden in der welt herstellen
das ist kein selbstläufer in der welt
die vn charta der menschenrechte die
globalen ziele die stg es das sind die
großen internationalen verabredungen für
die wir für deren durchsetzung wie immer
und überall ringen müssen und deswegen
setzen wir ein schwerpunkt im
sicherheitsrat wir übernehmen den putsch
er 13 25 frauen frieden sicherheit und
das ist ein starkes signal deutschlands
auf diesem feld ich habe mich selber mit
margot wallström getroffen habt den
mitgliedern im sicherheitsrat unsere
unterstützung auf konkrete auch
finanzielle unterstützung zugesagt die
netzwerkbildung zwischen frauen ist
wichtig und deswegen helfen mit dem
african women leaders network und
gründen gerade ein zweites in
lateinamerika und karibik und wir werden
die zivilgesellschaft ein
nach new york wir wollen ihnen eine
stimme geben wir wollen ihnen gehör
verschaffen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich bin
überzeugt dass diese debatte sich lohnt
weil wir frauen einen unterschied machen
können dabei wohin sich diese welt
entwickelt und liebe männer helfen sie
uns dabei
herzlichen dank vielen dank herr
müntefering war das staatsministerin im
auswärtigen amt in dieser debatte der
ein antrag der grünen zum thema
feministische außenpolitik zugrunde
liegt und die nächste rednerin in eben
dieser debatte ist jetzt renata alt für
die fdp fraktion sehr geehrter herr
präsident liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
meine damen und herren
letzte woche wurde meine büroleiterin
war eine veranstaltung zur europäischen
verteidigungspolitik von einem älteren
herrn angesprochen
völlig überraschend fragte er sie na was
machen sie hier bei einer
außenpolitische veranstaltung dessen
praktikantin sind sie meine damen und
herren das im jahr 2019 eine
außenpolitische qualifikation den frauen
derart plump abgesprochen wird ist
beschämend
deutsche außenpolitik muss weiblich
verwerten
andere länder sind uns längst voraus ich
nenne nur einige bekannte außen
politikerinnen condoleezza rice die
leute clinton für ist ja vielen federico
morgue rini madeleine albright war
gerade in münchen bei der
sicherheitskonferenz eine sehr gefragte
gesprächspartnerin
lassen sie uns für eine aussenpolitik
und eintreten in der frauen
selbstverständlich ihren platz haben vor
allem aus gestalterinnen dazu bekennt
sich die bundesregierung in den
leitlinien zur krisenprävention in der
un-resolution 13 25 diese macht deutlich
dass frauen nachhaltig frieden sichern
setzen sie in ihren projekten endlich
auf die aktive beteiligung und
einbindung von frauen in un missionen
bei der gesetzgebung oder in der
traumabewältigung frau müntefering
nutzen sie den un-sicherheitsrat lege
sie einen schwerpunkt auf die rechte der
frauen
es darf nicht sein dass in afrika
sexualisierter gewalt immer noch als
kriegswaffe eingesetzt werden
es darf nicht sein dass in indien weit
über 100 frauen täglich vergewaltigt
unterdrückt oder sogar ermordet werden
nur weil sie frauen sind
unterstützen sie frauenbewegungen wird
weit wie zb die iranische write once
they bewegung liebe verbrugge vielen von
dem was sie gesagt haben kann ich
zustimmen uns eint die überzeugung dass
wir eine bessere außenpolitik brauchen
aber brauchen wir unbedingt das adjektiv
feministische aussenpolitik nein nein
das label feministisch ist für unser
anliegen überflüssig wie sogar der
meinung dass manchmal sogar
kontraproduktiv denn wir werden sehr
schwer eine gemeinsame definition von
feminismus finden und das haben
mittlerweile die schwedischen politiker
auch erkannt meine damen und herren
deutschland ist ein modernes land wir
brauchen eine moderne und
verantwortungsvolle außenpolitik die
schwache schützt eine außenpolitik die
alle chancen bietet und teilhabe
ermöglicht
wir brauchen eine aussenpolitik deren
umsetzung und repräsentation
gleichermaßen von männern und frauen
vorangetrieben wird
denken sie auch an die zukunft ihrer
eigenen töchter zur vorbildfunktion in
den führungspositionen können wir der
jungen generation und frauen ermutigen
die junge generation verantwortung zu
übernehmen
dieses bild modernes deutschland möchten
wir freie demokraten in die welt
transportieren der überweisung des
antrags in den ausschuss werden wird
zustimmen
vielen dank vielen dank frau kollegin
bald als nächstes spricht jones die
kollegin kathrin vogler die linke
[Applaus]
guten morgen herr präsident meine herren
und damen und einem saal und oben auf
den tribünen wir reden hier immer ein
antrag der grünen zur feministische
außenpolitik und da hört man dann gleich
das große murren auf der rechten mitte
des hauses was sollen das sein und von
ganz rechts kommt das übliche geplänkel
von der angeblichen gender ideologie
auch wenn ich zugeben muss dass der
beitrag von herrn bisschen und heute
schon außergewöhnlich flegelhaft war und
auch auf der anderen seite des saales
hört man ganz leise den einen oder
anderen joschka fischer zitieren er
sagte es gibt nur gute oder schlechte
außenpolitik stimmt übrigens denn eine
politik die die bedürfnisse und die
fähigkeiten der mehrheit der menschen
vernachlässigt und nicht einbeziehen das
ist einfach schlechte politik wenn
finster zeit der länger halten hat
frauen daran beteiligt waren das ist
auch gut für alle
ich freue mich übrigens dass sie der
gedanke so provoziert das zeigt doch
dass er offenbar ein wunder punkt
getroffen wird
aussenpolitik halten ja viele hier im
saal quasi naturgemäß
für männersache die ihnen silberrücken
kunden stattzufinden hat
schauen wir mal unseren auswärtigen
ausschuss an
nur zwölf frauen sitzen hier 33 männern
gegenüber bei der afg klar aber auch bei
den grünen keine einzige frau bei der
fdp immerhin eine und bei der union sind
von 16 vollmitglieder drei frauen und
das können auch die spd mit 50 prozent
und die linke mit 75 prozent
frauenanteil nicht ganz raus reißen
aber ich kann sie beruhigen
feministische außenpolitik damit können
sie auch männer beschäftigen und das
können auch männer mit voranbringen und
sie sehen werden sehen es ist eine
politik die ganz nebenbei auch für die
männliche minderheit auf diesem planeten
gut ist wenn politik die bedürfnisse von
frauen ganz besonders berücksichtigen
will berührt dass einige grundsätzliche
fragen
mir reicht es da nicht die un-resolution
13 25 in sonntagsreden zu feiern und
verbale bekenntnisse zum schutz von
frauen und kindern in us militär mandate
zu schreiben oder in nato stäben einfach
mal ein paar mehr weibliches personal
unterzubringen sondern wir müssen
knallhart über interessen reden erstens
rüstungsexporte das kinderhilfswerk der
vereinten nationen unicef geht davon aus
dass 80 prozent aller durch kleinwaffen
getöteten personen frauen und kinder
sind und was du die bundesregierung im
koalitionsvertrag haben sie sich ja noch
dazu verpflichtet kleinwaffen nicht mehr
in länder außerhalb von eu und nato zu
exportieren aber die regelung haben sie
noch nicht umgesetzt weil jetzt erst mal
darüber geschachert wird welche
ausnahmen erlaubt sein sollen
meine damen
herren so geht das nicht da müssen sie
endlich vorankommen und in diesem
zusammenhang will ich auch noch einmal
daran erinnern dass die bundesregierung
endlich aufhören muss waffen an die
länder zu liefern die haben jemanden
krieg beteiligt sind denn da leiden die
frauen ganz besonders zweitens opfer von
vergewaltigung und zwangsehen etwa die
jesiden im nordirak müssen nicht nur
rechtlichen schutz in deutschland
bekommen sondern vor ort hilfsmaßnahmen
etwa psychotherapie und soziale
unterstützung und da unternimmt die
bundesregierung leider viel zu wenig und
wenn sie in deutschland also wieder
halten müssen sie selbstverständlich das
recht bekommen ihre familien zu sich in
die sicherheit zu holen
alles andere ist doch unmenschlich und
unerträglich kollegin dann laufen sie
eine zwischenfrage aus der fdp-fraktion
von den kollegen drittens frauen vor
allem arbeiterinnen und arme frauen sind
in vielen ländern der welt besondere
unterdrückung und ausbeutung ausgesetzt
dass ich erwarte von der bundesregierung
dass sie diese besonderen unterdrückung
sind ausbeutungsverhältnisse in ihren
internationalen beziehungen anspricht
und auf veränderungen drängt das muss
nämlich auch konsequenzen für die praxis
deutscher konzerne im ausland haben es
gibt kein recht auf profitmaximierung
durchs web shops in den schlecht
bezahlte frauen und kinder unter
krankmachenden arbeitsbedingungen
markenklamotten für die reiche welt
zusammennähen und das muss in den
mittelpunkt kathrin vogler war das von
der linksfraktion friedenspolitische
sprecherin und gisela mann der lage ist
jetzt die nächste hier am rednerpult für
die cdu csu fraktion
kollegen kollegin sehr verehrte damen
und herren ich möchte nicht auf die
menschenverachtenden bemerkungen der afg
kollegen eingehen die peinlich waren
aber ich möchte nur eine bemerkung
machen so kandidatur von kanzlerin
merkel als sie zum ersten mal kandidiert
hat da waren es die frauen der cdu csu
und die frauen aus der gesellschaft und
anderen politischen gremien die frau
merkel in dieses amt getragen haben und
da sind wir heute immer noch sehr sehr
stolz drauf der frauen stärkt starb die
welt ist der leitspruch der un women und
zwar des nationalen komitees deutschland
und das thema ihres antrags liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von den grünen
dass auch heute so emotional geführt ist
zeigt dass dieses thema weiterhin im
fokus bleiben muss und deshalb bin ich
ihnen dankbar dafür dass sie dieses
thema heute noch einmal auf die
tagesordnung bringen allerdings muss ich
ihnen sagen dass ich den ansatz
feministische außenpolitik nicht trage
und sie wissen ja auch dass hier ihren
antrag heute ablehnen werden bereits
überweisen werden dankeschön
bereits im jahr 2000 hat der
sicherheitsrat der vereinten nationen
die resolution 1325 verabschiedet und
hier unter dem leitsatz frauen frieden
und sicherheit und seitdem wurde diese
resolution und sieben weitere ergänzt
kern ist dass frauen einen hohen
stellenwert in der außen- und sicherheit
und entwicklungspolitik haben auf der
einen seite sind frauen ein maßgeblicher
faktor bei der etablierung von frieden
und sicherheit aber auch andere seite
sind es gerade frauen und mädchen die am
stärksten unter den folgen kriegerischer
auseinandersetzung und gewaltsamer
konflikte leiden müssen
die bundesregierung hat deshalb den
stellenwert der resolution 13 25 erkannt
und die umsetzung der agenda frauen
frieden sicherheit als immens wichtiges
thema identifiziert und so soll die
geschlechter perspektive als
querschnittsthema systematisch in alle
relevanten politikfeldern mit betrachtet
werden und dies gilt umso mehr und das
wurde auch schon gesagt dass sie krisen
konfliktherde in der welt nicht zu
nehmen sondern leider nicht abnehmen
sondern leider zu nehmen die
befriedigung dieser vielschichtigen
krisen und gewaltsamen
auseinandersetzung ist eine der
drängendsten herausforderungen der
gesamten weltgemeinschaft und hier vor
hierfür ist erforderlich ein
mehrstufiger ansatz und ich will die
punkte gerne stichpunktartig nennen
es geht um prävention es geht um
konflikt belebung es geht um
stabilisierung es geht um
friedensbildung und wiederaufbau und vor
allem geht es um nachsorge und
friedenssicherung und diesem ansatz
meine damen und herren wird die deutsche
außen- und sicherheitspolitik gerecht
so wurde zunächst ein erster aktionsplan
der regierung im zeitraum 23 10 216 auf
den weg gebracht es ging um die
förderung der rechte von frauen und über
einen außenpolitischen und
innenpolitischen aspekt es ging zuerst
einmal um die marktplatz staaten und den
osze raum und es ging und da bin ich der
regierung sehr dankbar
vor allen dingen darum dass geflüchteten
frauen und mädchen hier in deutschland
eine besondere fürsorge zuteil wurde
es ging darum auch dass frauen und
mädchen in flüchtlingsunterkünften zum
beispiel getrennt unterkamen und
besonders gefördert worden und wenn sie
mal sehen
wollen wie frauen die flüchtende frauen
in der welt gesagt werden da müssen sie
sich den film von lukas rüger ansehen
der das eindeutig beweist der zweite
aktionsplan im jahr 2017 bis 2020 konnte
ebenfalls große erfolge erzielen und
meine damen und herren ich glaube dass
es dringend notwendig ist dass wir auf
unserem weg für den frieden die freiheit
und die sicherheit von frauen und
mädchen weiter gehen deshalb noch einmal
vielen dank für ihre aktion und ich
wünsche mir dass wir auf diesem weg
miteinander konstruktiv weitergehen
vielen dank gisela manderla für die
cdu/csu-fraktion anerkennung für den
grünen-antrag wenn auch nicht
übereinstimmung aber sie hat auch noch
mal darauf hingewiesen dass die
vereinten nationen vor fast 20 jahren
die resolution 1325 verabschiedet haben
für frauen frieden und sicherheit
daniela darüber jetzt für die spd liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen liebe gäste in
zahlreichen ländern dieser erde wächst
die tendenz zu einem besorgniserregenden
nationalismus
damit einher geht eine anti
emanzipatorische und eine
frauenverachtende entwicklung wo
menschenrechte missachtet werden sind es
vor allem immer frauen und mädchen deren
rechte mit füßen getreten werden mit
blick auf die un konvention für
menschenrechte und die resolution
bereits in 25 muss sich die deutsche
außenpolitik daher immer als gegenpol zu
diesen entwicklungen begreifen unser
sitz im un-sicherheitsrat bietet also
eine hervorragende gelegenheit das thema
frauen frieden und sicherheit mit hoher
priorität auf die welt politische agenda
zu setzen
und wir wollen noch einen schritt weiter
gehen und deutlich machen das ja auch
jungen und männer in patriarchalen
strukturen leiden und wir setzen deshalb
auf eine geschlechter orientierter
außenpolitik und wir haben dazu auch
schon einige handlungsfelder entwickelt
auch im auswärtigen amt ohne frage so
wie bei mandaten
missionen bei auslandseinsätzen und der
polizei und sicherheitskräfte setzen wir
auf gender mainstreaming und arbeiten
mit akribie an einen gender aktionsplan
ja wir brauchen mehr diplomatie in
unserem deutschen botschaften und
konsulaten liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
denn der kampf gegen hunger und armut
kann doch nicht losgelöst werden von den
geschlechtsspezifischen lebenslagen der
menschen
gleiches gilt etwa für sexualisierte
gewalt denken wir an genitalbeschneidung
songs verheiratung oder massen
vergewaltigung als kriegswaffe ebenso
gilt dies im übrigen für die bessere
medizinische versorgung etwa bei armut
oder hunger induzierten krankheiten bei
der bekämpfung von mütter und
säuglingssterblichkeit oder auch bei der
hiv prävention weltweit brauchen frauen
und mädchen gleiche rechte und einen
gleichberechtigten zugang zu ressourcen
wirtschaftliche ungleichheit und
geringer teilhabe von frauen an
politischen entscheidungsstrukturen
kritisieren die schaf- und sagen sie
sicher das tun wir keineswegs nur hier
im plenum liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir setzen auf faire vertriebsstrukturen
und handelsabkommen und wir machen uns
stark für international anerkannte
umwelt und sozialstandards die immer auf
frauen mit betreffen frauen sind jedoch
keineswegs nur opfer in konflikten die
verstärkte beteiligung von frauen bei
friedens diensten und versöhnungs
initiativen am friedens und
abrüstungsverhandlungen stellt nicht nur
eines unserer nachhaltigkeitsziele bei
der agenda 20.30 politik da die
erfahrung lehrt uns doch auch dass der
einfluss von frauen zu einem besseren
und schnelleren abschluss der verfahren
führt und dass diese sogar nachhaltiger
wirken meine damen und herren ja herr
bistro frauen können mehr als nur an der
stange zu tanzen
wir setzen national das will ich ihnen
sagen auf eine engere zu übergreifenden
zusammen
und international auf unsere
multilateralen kooperation insbesondere
mit jenen ländern die ihrerseits bereits
konzepte zu einer gleichstellung zu
einer gleichstellung orientierte
außenpolitik oder einer politik der
parität entwickelt haben wir etwas
schweden kanada und frankreich
last but not least wir brauchen ein
gender monitoring ein gender sensibles
frühwarnsystem und eine gender
orientierte forschung zur außenpolitik
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
lassen sie mich zum schluss kommen mit
verlaub herr präsident das thema der
gleichstellungs orientierten
außenpolitik ist zu wichtig und zu groß
um im klein-klein der fraktions
differenzen zerrieben zu werden
daher habe ich sie alle ein meine damen
immer fraktion l
im rahmen eines parlaments kreises
frauen in der außenpolitik enger
zusammenzuarbeiten
dazu eingeladen sind selbstverständlich
auch alle feministen die uns dabei gerne
unterstützen möchten gott sei dank ist
dann die afd
ja nicht mit von der partie vielen dank
nächste rednerin hier in der debatte ist
jetzt claudia roth für die grünen sie
war bis 1 45 stunde noch hier amtierende
bundestags-vizepräsidentin leitet die
sitzungen wurde da angegriffen
angesprochen von einem afg redner jetzt
spricht die als grüne abgeordnete frauen
und mädchen werden in allen regionen der
welt strukturell diskriminiert sie sind
in besonderem maße von krieg von gewalt
von armut und übrigens auch von der
klimakrise betroffen
zugleich wird ihre perspektive aber in
der internationalen politik weiter
sträflich vernachlässigt und das
erfordert einen grundlegenden
paradigmenwechsel
wir müssen
die bedürfnisse von menschen nicht von
staaten in den mittelpunkt rücken
wir müssen also den traditionellen
sicherheitsbegriff ergänzen von der
staatlichen hin zur menschlichen
sicherheit und wir müssen anfangen außen
und sicherheitspolitik systematisch aus
der perspektive derer zu betrachten die
seit jahrhunderten besonders unter ihren
negativen folgen zu leiden hatten
denn gewalt leid not gehen längst nicht
mehr nur von zwischenstaatlichen
konflikten aus sie sind konsequenz tief
verwurzelter auch patriarchaler
machtverhältnisse und diese verhältnisse
zu ändern
auch das ist ziel einer feministischen
außenpolitik und deswegen wollen wir die
klassischen strukturen aufbrechen
wir wollen die gelder neu ausrichten und
neue analyse mechanismen anwenden
wir wollen dass deutschland voran geht
und druck macht nicht zuletzt im uno
sicherheitsrat bei der vollständigen
umsetzung von 13 25 bei der förderung
von frauen und marginalisierten gruppen
weltweit beim schutz und der
durchsetzung ihrer sozialen ihrer
ökonomischen ihrer politischen ihrer
reproduktiven und ihrer sexuellen rechte
und das wären hinter deutsche
außenpolitik aber aber es geht immer
auch um gleichberechtigte beteiligung
frauen sind entscheidende akteur innen
die eingebunden gehören weil sie teil
dieser gesellschaft sind wie elisabeth
motschmann gesagt hat weiß
friedensprozesse nachhaltiger weise
gesellschaftliche umbrüche inklusive zu
gestalten helfen es geht also nicht
darum frauen zu zählen sondern
sicherzustellen dass frauen
das ist das was wir auf meinen mit
paradigmenwechsel
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
angesichts alle dieser maskulin ist und
macho machtpolitiker weltweit braucht
dass die kraftvolle vision einer
gerechteren einer diversen welt mehr
denn je mehr denn je braucht es
selbstbewusster und mutige stimmen
gerade auch weibliche stimmen die
eintreten für eine gesellschaft in der
alle menschen ohne gewalt und
unterdrückung leben können klassische
außenpolitik ist an dieser aufgabe
leider bislang gescheitert also zeit für
eine feministische außenpolitik wie sie
übrigens von margot wallström
von justine oder schiester hat rudow
auch vertreten wird vielen dank liebe
kolleginnen hier in diesem teil des
hauses hat dieser teil des hauses das
sind nämlich die grünen die spd und die
linke gibt bei dem beitrag und während
des beitrags von claudia roth
entsprechend beifall gespendet haben
die letzte rednerin jetzt hier zu diesem
tagesordnungspunkt kathrin staffler für
die unionsfraktion
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen frauen frieden sicherheit den
drei klagen haben heute in dieser
diskussion schon ein paar mal gehört und
das ist der dreiklang der uns in der
diskussion um umtreibt fakt ist wir
brauchen mehr frieden ja wir brauchen
auch mehr sicherheit und ganz definitiv
in der tat wir brauchen mehr frauen
frauen sind in fast allen bereichen der
außenpolitik nicht in dem maße vertreten
dass männer sind dabei sind frauen in
meinen augen zumindest sehr sehr gut der
außenpolitiker zumindest sind sie aber
definitiv keine schlechteren als männer
hätten
im umkehrschluss heißt es aber auch
nicht dass männer die schlechteren
außenpolitiker sind nur weil sie männer
sind
das zu behaupten wäre
rimini und diskriminieren wollen wir in
dieser diskussion wer sicher nicht der
antrag der antrag in allen ehren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen aber ich frag
mich ganz ehrlich sind sie nicht ein
bisschen spät dran damit ich habe in
ihrem antrag nichts aber auch gar nichts
gelesen was wir neu gewesen wären auch
wir sind uns der schwierigen lage in der
sich viele frauen und viele mädchen
weltweit befinden durchaus sehr bewusst
und ja es wurden auch schon
unterschiedlichste maßnahmen auf den weg
gebracht um die situation dieser frauen
und mädchen zu verbessern und ich möchte
an der stelle einfach nur einen kleinen
auszug davon aufzählen was schon alles
getan wird damit sie sehen dass ihr
antrag eigentlich ad acta gelegt werden
könnte beginnen wir doch mal mit den
zielen die das auswärtige amt im übrigen
nicht erst seit gestern für sich
festgelegt hat das ziel ist ein
frauenanteil von 50 prozent in allen
bereichen um das ziel zu erreichen gibt
es einen gleichstellungs plan und es
gibt eine gleichstellungsbeauftragte die
höhe unter anderem darüber wacht dass
frauen auch in ihrer karriereentwicklung
im auswärtigen amt nicht benachteiligt
werden
im übrigen eine forderung die in ihrem
antrag steht auf europäischer ebene ist
deutschland regelmäßiger teilnehmer der
eu taskforce zu frauen frieden und
sicherheit da ist er wieder der
dreiklang
dabei wirkt deutschland an
entscheidungen und aktivitäten der eu
zur umsetzung der resolution 13 25 auch
die haben heute ein paar mal gehört mit
und zählt auch auf ebene der vereinten
nationen zur freundesgruppe diese
resolution und der wichtigste faktor
anders formuliert der entscheidende
hinweis dass das thema schon lange an
höchster stelle angekommen ist ist die
tatsache dass frauen frieden und
sicherheit ein thematischer schwerpunkt
für die deutsche mitgliedschaft im
sicherheitsrat 20 19 und 20 ist im
internationalen organisationen wie den
vereinten
aktionen und der europäischen union
setzt sich die bundesregierung schon
seit langem dafür ein dass die rolle von
frauen in konfliktbewältigung und
krisenprävention zu stellen ist gestärkt
wird
sei es bei der ausbildung von
polizistinnen in afghanistan bei der
förderung von iranischen frauen in
existenzgründerinnen seminaren oder
verschiedene andere projekte zum schutz
von frauen gegen sexuelle gewalt und zur
gewaltprävention
sie sehen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
fordern tun wir die gleichstellung von
mann und frau nicht nur sondern wir
fördern sie auch weil die gleichstellung
der geschlechter eine frage der
gerechtigkeit ist und die frage der
gerechtigkeit und der gleichstellung
bringt mich wieder zurück zu ihrem
antrag
und es tut mir leid aber den folgenden
kommentar kann ich mir an der stelle
nicht verkneifen ich habe ja schon ein
bisschen schmunzeln müssen als ich auf
seite 7 in ihrem antrag das wort frauen
versehen mit einem gender sternchen
gelesen habe und zwar noch einen damals
dass er wegen dem stern hinter dem wort
frauen an sich
aber wenn sie schon so korrekt sein
wollen und in der von der gleichstellung
der geschlechter sprechen an der stelle
dann hätte ich ehrlich gesagt schon
erwartet dass sie einen absatz später
bei der aufzählung männer und frauen das
dritte geschlecht nicht vergessen
abschließend möchte ich noch den
kolleginnen und den kollegen der grünen
aber auch den kolleginnen alle anderen
oder auch die kolleginnen alle anderen
parteien müssen sich auf der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz getroffen habe es
war schön dass sie so zahlreich
vertreten waren und ich hoffe sie haben
das gleiche gedacht als sie mich und
meine kollegin bettina wiesmann
getroffen haben von der cdu csu fraktion
als frauen beim thema außenpolitik man
höre und staune dankeschön katrin
staffler war das von der cdu csu
fraktion
sie haben auswärtigen an gibt es eine
gleichstellungsbeauftragte sagte sie und
jetzt gibt es aber hören wir gerade noch
eine kurzintervention war aus den reihen
der spd
herr präsident vielen dank ich möchte
die kurze anlagerung von meiner kollegin
daniela der ritter noch einmal erläutern
es ging einige unruhe durch die reihen
der kollegen von der afd
die anmerkung an herrn pistolen frauen
könnten mehr als an der stange tanzen
bezog sich auf seine innerparteiliche
mitbewerberinnen der bescheidenheit
frauen wie sie frauen wie sie sollten
lieber an der stange tanzen vielen dank
darauf können sie nicht antworten frau
kollegin ist eine schlichte feststellung
aber wie ich habe das zu erwarten möchte
die ard fraktion jetzt eine
kurzintervention des kollegin wistron
die ich zulasse herr kollege wissen sie
haben das wort
der bistro hier angesprochen von der hfg
fraktion
sie wollen das nicht mehr erster
sie zitieren falsch sie haben mir
unterstellt dass ich das gesagt habe
richtig ist dass aus meiner kollegin auf
einen wahlkampf innerparteilichen
wahlkampf gesagt hat so viel ist so viel
zum umgang zwischen frauen und männern
ja
zweitens sie wurde nicht gewählt ich
wurde auch nicht gewählt in diesem
wahlgang gewählt wurde unser kollege kai
gottschalk weil er der beste war so ist
das bei uns in der partei
und drittens das war wirklich
durchsichtig dass es kommt und sie sehen
wir haben uns längst vertragen wir gehen
mit einer sehr gut aus und wir brauchen
so was nicht
liebe kollegen
damit schließt sich die debatte hinter
vor der bundestags- vizepräsident
wolfgang kubicki hat ja die
kurzintervention noch zu belassen weil
die debatte war auch zum teil emotional
aufgeladen emotional geführt auch weil
es persönliche auseinandersetzung hier
gab aber das thema weil ihr allen
rednern zumindest wichtig und katrin
staffel hier zuletzt gesprochen hat
unserer normalen zu knüpfen
inhaltlich die hat gesagt es gibt im
auswärtigen amt eine
gleichstellungsbeauftragte allerdings
das bild ist personell bei der deutschen
außenpolitik männlich besetzt es gab ja
noch nie eine deutsche außenministerin
und 13 prozent der botschafterposten in
deutschland werden von frauen also die
grünen die haben das alles festgehalten
ihrem antrag der wird jetzt weiter
geraten
in den ausschüssen und wird dann das
plenum erneut beschäftigen wir kommen
zum nächsten thema ein ganz anderes
zimmer wie sieht der auto antrieb der
zukunft aus
nach dieser krise und fahrverboten da
müssen autofahrer sich durchaus über
alternativen gedanken machen ein
autobauer müssen wege gehen um das
klimagas co2 zu reduzieren die politik
beschäftigt sich beispielsweise damit
wohl lohnt es sich forschungsförderung
einzusetzen wenn es um alternative
antriebe geht bzw
vorteile als steuervorteile als anreiz
zu setzen
es gibt zwei anträge zu diesem thema
alternative autoantriebe die afg hat
einen vorgelegt und die fdp-fraktion und
inhaltlich werden wir jetzt dazu
weiteres hören unter anderem jetzt hier
vom ersten redner der spanier für die
afg fraktion präsident sehr geehrte
damen und herren
heute geht es um nichts weniger als die
zukunft des automobilstandortes
deutschland und das liegt an der
europäischen gesetzgebung die ab anfang
2000 21 die co2 emission es grenzwerte
bei neufahrzeugen massiv verschärfen
wird wenn alles so kommt wie aktuell
beschlossen werden in europa in wenigen
jahren im wesentlichen nur noch
kleinwagen produziert werden
das sage nicht ich das haben uns
expertenanhörung im bundestag erklärt
und noch mal kurz das war nicht mal
unsere experten noch mal kurz die
sachlage die fahrzeugflotten der pkw
hersteller dürfen bis 2030 einen
durchschnittsverbrauch von ca 2,5 liter
auf 100 kilometer nicht mehr
überschreiten sonst drohen diesen
herstellern drastische strafzahlungen an
die europäische union
ja da können sie ruhig klatschen da
sehen sie die arroganz genau fahrzeuge
oberhalb der kompaktklasse werden dass
ohne elektrifizierung nicht erreichen
die elektrifizierung dieser fahrzeuge ob
nun als plug in hybrid oder aus von
elektrofahrzeug macht diese fahrzeuge
aber aufgrund der hohen herstellkosten
für weite teile unserer bevölkerung
unerschwinglich und unpraktikabel und
mit dem willen der angeblich
bürgerlichen cdu/csu wird hier mal so
eben der verbrennungsmotor aus
politischen gründen so verteuert dass er
nicht mehr marktfähig ist und die spd
umweltministerin schießt dann noch den
vogel ab wenn sie die strafzahlung noch
weiter erhöhen wollte höher als von der
eu gefordert sie nehmen den bürgern in
diesem land ihr bezahlbares auto und die
arbeitsplätze dazu weg die eu papiere
die eu papiere zu der verordnung
sprechen von einem zu erwartenden
wegfallen von arbeitsplätzen der durch
sozialpartner aufgefangen werden soll
dann wird mir auch klar warum sie von
der spd das sozialsystem ausbauen wollen
die geplante massenarbeitslosigkeit ist
für cdu csu und spd
mindestens ein kollateralschaden wenn
nicht sogar ein politisches ziel auf dem
weg zu einer
vermeintlich besseren welt die afg geht
hier einen völlig anderen weg
wir haben den menschen vor der
bundestagswahl 2017 versprochen dass wir
eine alternative anbieten wollen eine
alternative zur ideologischer
wirtschaftsfeindliche und undurchdacht
politik und genau aus diesem grund
wollen wir die finanzielle
gleichbehandlung von fahrzeugen mit
synthetischen kraftstoffen zu
elektrofahrzeugen
wir nehmen es nicht hin dass die
bundesregierung durch staatliche
subventionierung den verbrennungsmotor
aus dem markt drängt und dadurch dass
wir die bundesregierung dazu bringen
sich auf europäischer ebene für die
anerkennung von fahrzeugen mit
synthetischen kraftstoffen als null
gramm co2 fahrzeuge einzusetzen
tun wir übrigens auch was für die
tatsächliche reduktion der
co2-emissionen liebe kollegen von den
grünen
ihre geschichte vom sauberen ökostrom
der elektrofahrzeuge antreibt ist doch
ein hirngespinst
ein elektrofahrzeug erzeugt genauso viel
co2 wie ein diesel fahrzeug um das zu
ändern müsste man erst mal den strom in
deutschland komplett co2 frei erzeugen
und das ist in den nächsten 15 jahren
überhaupt gar nicht möglich
sie wissen dass sie erzählen aber
trotzdem ihr märchen
sie vernichten hier einen industriezweig
ohne dass wir co2 emissionen damit
reduzieren das finde ich total
verachtenswert ich jeder der zukünftig
co2 frei mit seinem auto fahren will
kann das tun wir bieten hier ein
praktikables konzept an
durch umsetzung unseres antrages kann
jeder an die tankstelle fahren mit
sauberem gewissen co2 neutralen sprinten
übrigens auch mit älteren fahrzeugen und
mit diesem antrag erhalten wir das auto
für alle teile der bevölkerung das ist
echte sozialpolitik denn nur günstige
verbrennungsmotoren ermöglichen auch der
alleinerziehenden mutter die möglichkeit
kostengünstig und schnell von a nach b
zu kommen
ein elektrofahrzeug ermöglicht das eben
nicht wir brauchen einen fairen
wettbewerb und es muss endlich schluss
sein mit der planwirtschaftlichen
privilegierung von elektrofahrzeugen
unser antrag tut einen beitrag dazu
leisten
vielen dank sagt dirk spanier für die
cdu csu fraktion erst mit dem
finanzausschuss habe resident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren im
koalitionsvertrag ist festgeschrieben
ich zitiere wir wollen die klimaziele
von paris erreichen und dabei soziale
belange berücksichtigen die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit der industrie
gewährleisten und bezahlbare mobilität
sicherstellen dafür bedarf es eines
ganzen bündels von maßnahmen wie zum
beispiel der förderung von
elektromobilität das zeigt meine damen
und herren die union sagt erstens jahr
zur sicherung der mobilität und ja zum
klimaschutz auch in der mobilitäts und
kraftstoffstrategie des
verkehrsministers werden diese
grundsätze aufgegriffen und sie werden
konkretisiert und sie erkennen meine
damen und herren dass es nicht gegen die
verbrennungsmotoren geht dann das auch
nicht einseitig interessengetrieben
entschieden wird auch nicht ideologisch
verblendet sondern pragmatisch offen
technologieoffen und offen für neue
erkenntnisse und es wird nachvollziehbar
entschieden
und auch aus der abwägung ob
elektromotoren oder andere alternative
antriebe vorzuziehen sind wird genau
dieses deutlich aber das ziel möglichst
schnell um möglichst deutlich co2 zu
reduzieren
das führt dazu dass gegenwärtig ein
vorzug zu gewährleisten ist der
einführung der elektromobilität und zwar
dann wenn sie eingesetzt wird oder wenn
eingesetzt wird regenerativer strom
deswegen erfolgt eine besondere
förderung der forschung und produktion
aber auch des absatzes von
elektroantrieben durch deutliche 1 13
und vielleicht auch vorzüge dabei der
maut natürlich meine damen und herren
werden auch weitere kriterien in die
betrachtung mit einbezogen natürlich die
kompatibilität mit dem vorgehen den
nachbarstaaten natürlich auch die
auswirkungen auf die automobil und auf
die energiewirtschaft natürlich wird
auch die verfügbarkeit der notwendigen
infrastruktur getestet und und und vor
allem aber meine damen und herren und
die elektromobilität ist keineswegs
abschließend überzeugend vor allem aber
wenn die co2 ziele nicht alleine durch
die elektrofahrzeuge erreicht werden
vor allem deswegen werden wir weiter
suchen werden wir weiter forschen und
auch neue antriebskonzepte untersuchen
und zwar technologie offen
und auch das ist im koalitionsvertrag
sehr deutlich so formuliert und auch
jüngst im csu papier von museum wird
sehr deutlich darf wieder zitieren wir
wollen die wissenschaft beim heben von
klima innovationen unterstützen
durch neue technologien und methoden zur
emissionsreduktion können die potentiale
in allen sektoren ausgeschöpft werden
wie zb auch synthetische kraftstoffe
zitat ende ausdruck dieser
technologieoffenheit ist unser klares
zweitens ja unser jahr zur förderung
innovativer antriebssysteme insbesondere
auch synthetischer kraftstoffe meine
damen und herren
und zwar in der hoffnung oder erwartung
dass der entscheidenden nachteil dieser
technologie nämlich die ineffizienz bei
der produktion ausgeglichen aufgehoben
werden kann dann wenn hinreichend
regenerative energie bei der erzeugung
dieser kraftstoffe zur verfügung steht
was im moment noch nicht der fall ist
vorteile sehen wir natürlich dann wenn
wir daraus eine führende position der
branche in der welt erreichen können
wenn die technologie der
verbrennungsmotoren hier bei uns
weiterentwickelt werden kann und nutzbar
werden kann werden wir vorhandene
infrastruktur nutzen können
deswegen meine damen und herren gibt es
die ausgeprägte forschungsförderung auf
der anbieter und hersteller seite der
bundestag schon lange unterwegs dazu
gibt es viele belege und auch nicht
zuletzt die anfrage der fdp hat es
heraus gestellt nämlich fordert
förderprojekte des bundesministeriums
bildung und forschung von wirtschaft und
energie aber auch des umweltschutzes
immer wieder und überall geht es darum
diese technologie weiterzuentwickeln um
sie nutzbar zu machen für die zukunft
das ist gut so dass es auch strategisch
konsistent weiter so
aber meine damen und herren so lange
einen angeboten nicht in ausreichender
menge verfügbar ist macht es auch keinen
sinn auf der nachfrageseite anreize zu
setzen und deswegen drittens sagen wir
heute nein zur steuerlichen
gleichstellung der des verbrechers mit
synthetischen kraftstoffen mit
elektrofahrzeugen
es ist frustrierend es ist
kontraproduktiv in eine nachfrage an
getriggert wird die gar nicht befriedigt
werden kann
deswegen sagen wir auch nein zu dem
antrag der afd
die dieses viel zu früh fordert oder
aber mit ihrem antrag zu spät ist weil
die debatte um die synergetischen
kraftstoff längst läuft und auch die
forschung längst vorangetrieben wird
attraktiver der antrag der fdp
der fordert nicht nur herkömmliche
sondern auch neuartige antriebsformen
breitgefächert zu erforschen und zu
fördern da sind wir schon längst
unterwegs vor diesem hintergrund meine
damen und herren freue ich mich heraus
mit leopard im ausschuss die anträge
sind so insbesondere der dfb nicht zu
akzeptieren ich danke jetzt kommen wir
aber zu dem anderen antrag der fdp
technologie offenheit wenn es um die
forschungen die förderung alternativer
antriebstechnologien geht hören wir uns
dann jeder kluckert für die fdp
veränderungen brauchen und kluge ideen
vor allem sie brauchen wir die dann auch
von den menschen angenommen
das gilt insbesondere für themen die so
ernst sind wieder klimawandel
die bundesregierung versucht derzeit mit
sehr viel geld mit subventionen auf der
einen seite auf der anderen seite mit
verboten dem co2 ausstoß auf unseren
straßen herr zu werden
das problem daran ist aber dass erstens
gelte niemand will
und zweitens die verbote nicht wirken
zumindest müssen sie nicht so wie sie
sich das gewünscht haben von der
regierung denn wirksam wird damit unsere
wirtschafts geschädigt und wirksamen
werden mit dieser politik auch
arbeitsplätze gefährdet warum die
bundesregierung so agiert das kann ich
nur an meiner vermutung nach geht es
eben vielen gar nicht um den
umweltschutz sondern es geht am ende
darum den kampf gegen den
verbrennungsmotor zu führen oder am ende
eben das kampf gegen das aus im ganzen
klar ist jedenfalls dass das
verkehrsministerium und das
umweltministerium das die sich heillos
uneins sind
und auch das ist eben eine form
schlechten regierens und deswegen von
uns die forderung lösen sie diesen
knoten endlich auch werden sie sich
einig wie sie da vorangehen als freie
demokraten setzen wir bei der bekämpfung
des klimawandels auf unsere klügsten
köpfe und eben auch auf wettbewerb
anders wird es nicht gehen mit unseren
klügsten köpfen wollen wir innovationen
vorantreiben und deswegen brauchen wir
endlich eine technologieneutrale
forschungsförderung dies so jetzt nicht
gibt
ohne politische vorgaben sollen unsere
wissenschaftler am besten wegen forschen
die dann zu co2 einsparungen führen
und zweitens der wettbewerb der
wettbewerb und damit die menschen müssen
am ende entscheiden was sich durchsetzt
und am ende dafür sich einsetzen wie
eben auch co2 neutrale mobilität
funktioniert die bundesregierung setze
leyen auf elektromobilität und wie er
zwei demokraten sagen um die ice pohl
über wasser zu halten dafür brauchen wir
eben auch die gasantrieb und dafür
brauchen wir eben auch die us- meine
damen und herren
studien zeigen dass es ein beitrag von
40 prozent co2 minderung leisten können
warum in aller welt nehmen wir sie da
nicht mit auf und deswegen muss sich die
bundesregierung endlich dafür einsetzen
dass die flotten ziele dass die flotten
ziele der automobilhersteller eben diese
diese fuels aufnehmen können und dass
diese angerechnet werden
auf die flotten ziele die letzte chance
dafür wurde 2018 bei den pkws vertan
hier wurde nichts gemacht auch wegen der
uneinigkeit der ministerien
jetzt haben sie aber jetzt gerade jetzt
haben sie die möglichkeit dass bei den
lkws nachzuholen und hier die chance
diesmal nicht zu vertun der nur mit der
anrechenbarkeit der co2 neutralen
kraftstoffe kann eben auch investiert
werden solche kraftstoffe und dann ist
sie auch bezahlbar bezahlbare
individuelle mobilität das muss eine
kernforderung von uns sein das muss sie
bleiben und meine damen und herren den
ice pohl ist eben egal wie wir co2
einsparen behandeln sie deswegen
gasantrieb elektromobil gleich und
nutzen sie die chancen den neuen
kraftstoff
vielen dank frau kollegin kluckert als
nächster redner das wort der kollege
bernhard daldrup spd fraktion
[Applaus]
herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und haben
ist heute mit einem
gleichstellungspolitischen antrag der
afg zu tun das kommt auch nicht alle
tage vor
es geht darum dass durch eine kleine
technische entwicklung durch
steuererleichterungen also die
steuerpolitik unterstützt werden soll
das ist auch der punkt weshalb ich hier
rede
und man kann zweifellos über so ein
thema reden dann braucht man aber auch
in der steuerpolitik nicht jemanden der
nur rosinenpickerei betreibt sondern
einen seriösen gesprächspartner und das
ist die afg bei dem thema nicht denn
jedes mal jedes mal wenn wir über
steuerpolitik reden ist es so dass eine
steuer abgeschafft oder ausgehöhlt
werden soll
ein paar beispiele grundsteuer 14
milliarden afd sagt vollständige
streichung überträgt die folgen die
menschen in den städten und gemeinden
gestern gewerbesteuer haben wir von
herrn von stefan kreuzer gehört
abschaffen zuschläge auf die
einkommensteuer folge spaltung in dieser
gesellschaft was die städte angeht
dritter punkt grunderwerbssteuer
steuersenkungen fordern ohne den ländern
an ihren an der stelle zu sagen denn die
bekommen diese steuer wie ein ausgleich
anzubieten sein sollte oder
solidaritätszuschlag wir werden den sony
und 90 prozent der steuerzahler 20 21
abschaffen macht rund zehn milliarden
euro steuerentlastung ganz konkret
alleinerziehende beispielsweise
alleinstehende entschuldigung mit einem
zu versteuernden einkommen von unter
61.000 oder bei familien bei 122.000
152000 zu versteuerndes einkommen werden
vom soli befreit komplett aber wer mehr
verdient sind wir der auffassung sollte
durchaus auch mehr bezahlen ein minister
sollte mit 180000 durchaus eine 3600
euro soli bezahlen oder einer außen
dax-konzern der 5,8 millionen verdient
er sollte durchaus auch 142000
zusätzlichen soli bezahlen das alles
will die afg natürlich auch abschaffen
sie will hohe und höchste einkommen
sozusagen entlasten fazit der ganzen
geschichte
die steuerpolitik zu verantworten hätten
dann wäre deutschland schon morgen
pleite
das ist ökonomisch falsch mal im rahmen
des patriotisch ist das übrigens auch
nicht der staat hätte nämlich gar keinen
spielraum um solche wünschen
entwicklungen wie sie sich jetzt
vorgeschlagen haben steuerlich fördern
zu können wenn man auch die
steuereinnahmen sozusagen zu lasten der
menschen in den städten und gemeinden
und zugunsten von höchstverdienern
verzichten wollte das machen wir nicht
herr kollege langsam zwischenfrage
airline des kollegen dr
der präsident und bleibt die frage ich
biete ihnen kein vor und kein
zusätzliches bleibt die frage ob ihr
antrag technisch gerechtfertigt ist dazu
hat der rocker eben schon etwas gesagt
aus klimapolitischer sicht sind diffus
und tricks technologien hier durchaus
eine option
ich muss mich da mehr auf das urteil von
fachleuten stützen die sagen dass die
steuer rechtliche gleichstellung mit der
elektromobilität mit fahrzeugen die nur
mit synthetischen kraftstoffen betrieben
werden das steht nämlich in ihrem antrag
an der wirklichkeit vorbei geht aber da
wird vielleicht der kollege matthias
stein vor mir noch ein paar bemerkungen
zu machen
jetzt muss ich mich bei der fdp
entschuldigen wegen der zeit ich habe
noch nicht zu ihrem antrag sagen können
zur frage der technologie offenheit bei
antriebstechnologien aber hilft
vielleicht mal sagen es ist nicht falsch
schreiben aber neu ist es auch nicht
und was was beim thema änderungen der
dienstwagenbesteuerung auf den weg
gebracht wird genauso wenig also haben
wir mal ganz freundlich mit der toll zu
dem antrag braucht es eigentlich und die
antwort ist ja es braucht es braucht er
ist offensichtlich für selbstbewusstsein
der fdp der rest geht in die ausschüsse
herzlichen dank vielen dank
er hat die fraktion alleine
kurzintervention beantragt ich zulasse
der kollege dr
das wort
dank herr präsident sehr geehrter herr
kollege sie haben eben ausgeführt dass
wir sechs selektiv steuern rauspicken
wollen streichen wollen nein die
korrekte formulierung in diesem antrag
ist doch völlig klar
deshalb wundere ich mich dass ich das
jetzt hier so nicht darstellen wir
wollen steuer nicht erheben für etwas
was es im moment noch gar nicht gibt
weil diese steuern bei einem
konkurrenzprodukt eben auch nicht
erhoben werden und wir wollen hier einen
fairen wettbewerb bei fahrzeugen
erreichen den einerseits
steuervergünstigungen und sonstige
vergünstigungen zugestanden werden das
sind nämlich elektrofahrzeuge und
anderen fahrzeugen die den gleichen
effekt auf die umwelt haben verweigert
werden und das verstehen wir unter
wettbewerb und es hat überhaupt nichts
damit zu tun dass wir steuer peking
betreiben wollen und ich finde es sehr
bedauerlich hätten sie einen antrag
vielleicht mal ein bisschen lesen sollen
der war in die richtung gemeint wir
wollen einen wettbewerb erzeugen wollen
sie antworten
sie möchten nicht antworten dann ist die
kurze version beendet als nächster
redner hält das wort der kollege jörg
zusammen die linke präsident meine damen
und herren der verbrennungsmotor ist tot
lang lebe der verbrennungsmotor so wäre
vielleicht die die grundlegende
botschaft die sich leider hinter beiden
anträgen mehr und ein weniger verbirgt
wir können über einzelfragen im
ausschuss gerne reden ich will zu zwei
grundlegenden einwenden dass sagen
erstens technische lösungen die
fixierung auf technische lösungen bei
der bewältigung der verkehrswende reicht
nicht aus die innenstädte die städte die
ballungsräume werden von blechlawinen
nahegelegt dieses problem lösen wir
nicht dadurch dass wir mineralöle durch
strom basierte kraft schloss ersetzen
die beste immobilien die besten
immobilie sind straßenbahnen u bahn und
s bahn ohne ein gut ausgebauten
ohne einen gut ausgebauten öffentlichen
nahverkehr werden mit die
verkehrsprobleme in unseren städten die
zukunft der mobilität nicht in den griff
bekommen das gilt auch für den mieter
fans werden weiter punkt offenheit für
neue technologien ist gut man muss sich
aber auch nicht nur schnellen einzelnen
sein muss wenn sie wenn sie sich auch
nur mal im kopf überschlagen helfen
welche strommengen notwendig wären um
den pkw verkehr in deutschland auf
sogenannte mini fuels umzustellen dann
eher dr spanien das müssten sie
eigentlich hinkriegen dann müssten sie
dass das überhaupt keine option ist
immer die sich ernsthaft nachzudenken
nun wir werden die für uns brauchen das
stimmt von den luftverkehr wird es
wahrscheinlich keine alte an keine
andere alternative geben aber für den
straßenverkehr sind batterie elektrische
antriebe für den pkw verkehr in jedem
fall das gebot der stunde die
entscheidung ist längst gefallen
die entscheidung längst gefallen tesla
ist vorangegangen vw zieht nach die
deutsche automobilindustrie tun das auch
und wir sind gut beraten wenn wir in
deutschen automobilkonzernen und sie
ihren beschäftigten den übergang in
diesen strukturwandel ebenen und das
geht mit dem antrag den sie hier
vorgelegt haben nicht um es auf den
punkt zu bringen wenn wir die probleme
des verkehrssektors und der
automobilindustrie werden wir nicht
dadurch lösen dass wir den
verbrennungsmotor mit eagles künstlich
ford beachten wir brauchen eine echte
verkehrswende die in den öffentlichen
verkehr in den mittelpunkt stellt und
dafür wird auch in zukunft autos geben
die man auf die übersee überschaubarer
nächste zukunft batterieelektrisch
verkehren die werden geteilt werden und
möglich
also auch aus und fahren dafür sollten
wir unsere staatlichen mitteln aufwenden
ich dann gegangen hätte bei den future
geht es eben um diese künstlichen
kraftstoffe die idealerweise aus
erneuerbaren strom hergestellt sein
sollten allerdings co2 neutral sind es
nur dann wenn der eingesetzte strom zu
100 prozent aus erneuerbaren energien
stammt stephan kühn jetzt für die grünen
die gegen den ausstiegskompromiss bei
der kohle kommission sich stellen die
vor den ausbau erneuerbarer energien
blockieren wollen klimafreundliche
mobilität mit kraftstoffen sichern die
auf basis erneuerbarer energien
hergestellt werden das ist schon
erstaunlich
wegen der enormen energie verluste bei
der umwandlung von strom ins system
synthetische kraftstoffe und der hohen
kosten die dabei entstehen wäre dass die
mit abstand teuerste variante
klimafreundlicher mobilität die kosten
für jus liegen derzeit vier euro 50 pro
liter diesel äquivalent das sagt eine
studie im auftrag des vdi derzeit gibt
es nur einige demonstrationsanlagen aber
keine industrielle förderung aber die
afg suggeriert wenn eine steuerbefreiung
für jus käme könnten morgen autos mit
verbrennungsmotor zitat problemlos mit
synthetischen kraftstoffen betrieben
werden meine damen und herren
sie wollen die bürger hinters licht
führen dass die prognosen in den
auftrags studien der mineralölwirtschaft
zeigen die erzeugungskosten für jus
werden 2030 noch deutlich höher sein als
die kosten für benzin und diesel
die fdp will also die mobilität der
menschen richtig teurer machen
wir grüne wollen das nicht
und auch der zusätzliche strombedarf
wäre immens für das fahren mit fuse
müsste fünf mal so viel strom eingesetzt
werden wie wenn der strom aus rein mit
rein batterieelektrischen fahrzeugen
erbracht wird und damit effizient die
infrastruktur genutzt wird
eine studie der thora verkehrswende
zeigt würde der verkehrssektor vor allem
mit synthetischen kraftstoffen
klimaneutral umgebaut könnte der
strombedarf allein des verkehrs in
deutschland im jahr 2050 bei etwa 900
terawattstunden liegen
dieser bedarf übersteigt die gesamte
derzeitige brutto stromerzeugung in
deutschland wo soll der strom herkommen
diese freiheit können sie nicht
beantworten sie wollen es nur in neue
importabhängigkeit bringen
herr kollege habe ich eine zwischenfrage
aus fdp fraktion ein in der debatte ist
mehr augenmaß notwendig wir werden
flüssige synthetische brennstoffe aus
öko strom brauchen aber wegen der
beschriebenen nachteile sollten sie nur
dort zum einsatz kommen wo wir mit der
elektromobilität an grenzen stoßen also
insbesondere im flug und seeverkehr die
fdp zu der ich jetzt kommen möchte ist
ebenso schräg unterwegs wie die afg sie
wollen fossile kraftstoffe
durch einen anderen nämlich erdgas
ersetzen während alle namhaften
deutschen automobilhersteller längst
innovative elektrische antriebe im
angebot haben
mit so einer strategie würden dir wer
die klimaschutzziele erreichen noch
könnten unsere deutschen automobilfirmen
international im wettbewerb bestehen
zum glück sind unsere hersteller
deutlich klüger investieren mit
ehrgeizigen zielen in die
elektromobilität
nach dem lesen des textes kann ich ihnen
nur empfehlen informieren fürst
antragsschreiben second ich verteidiger
ungern die regierung aber in dem fall
muss ich mal tun es stimmt einfach nicht
dass die staatliche förderung sich nur
auf elektromobilität konzentriert die
staatliche förderung zielt auf den
aufbau von wasserstofftankstellen
insbesondere vor also ist es
technologieoffen anders als in ihrem
antrag steht
sina trilog verhandlungen in brüssel zu
den co2 grenzwerten für pkw und lkw
längst abgeschlossen sie sind einfach zu
spät dran wenn sie uns ihr
verkehrspolitischer herausforderung haus
fordern wollen dann müssen sie etwas
früher aufstehen sagt stephan kühn für
die fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen wären
fragte verkehrspolitisch lieber herr
kollege kühn sie haben ja leider eine
zwischenfrage nicht zugelassen
ich will ihnen einfach ganz offen sagen
es spricht überhaupt nichts gegen die
flüssige elektromobilität also die
synthetischen kraftstoffe es gibt viele
gründe so was zu fördern und wir werden
da auch in den nächsten jahren einen
gesunden neuen mix bekommen
und natürlich werden diese kraftstoff in
der regel auch wenn man die neuen
anlagen sich anschaut dieser weise in
deutschland auch nicht alle hergestellt
werden
aber es ist trotzdem ein guter beitrag
um auch eine einen ausgleich zu finden
zwischen ökonomie und ökologie und
deswegen fragen sie warum haben sie das
als verkehrspolitischer sprecher der
grünen in irgendeiner weise
intellektuell noch nicht durchdrungen
dieses thema iols christian jungen für
die fdp herr kollege
möchten sie antworten
also er vorsitzender möchten eigentlich
nicht aber ich tue es trotzdem weil
lieber kollege jung wenn sie in meiner
rede aufmerksamkeit zugehört hätten dann
hätte ich einsatzfelder für das thema e
views werden sich an die einsatzfelder
die ich genannt habe für das thema
erinnern können
dann hätten sie auch gemerkt dass es um
eine differenzierte betrachtung geht wir
haben unterschiedliche verkehrsträger er
braucht das unterschiedliche antworten
wahrscheinlich übrigens weltweit
regional unterschiedlich aber wir müssen
auf das thema kosten erfolgt das thema
effizienz und die frage auf wann
bestimmte technologien verfügbar sind
schauen und da muss man sagen dass zur
erreichung der ziele die wir 2030
erreichen wollen im verkehr
die e views keinen beitrag leisten
werden das ist der fakt schauen sie in
die studien schauen sich die
kostenstrukturen an wenn sie die
mobilität nicht teuer machen wollen dann
haben es nichts zu suchen
sie sind wir bestimmte bereiche haben
sie eine bedeutung aber erst nach 20 30
das sagen übrigens auch die studien die
das thema e views pushen wollen so damit
erhält als nächstes wird der kollege dr
christoph ploß cdu csu fraktion
herr präsident verehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen die mobilität der zukunft dass
es derzeit eines der megathemen in
deutschland und das vollkommen zu recht
denn auch das einen seite geht es hier
im deutschen bundestag um die frage
welche politischen initiativen wir
ergreifen müssen um die steigenden
erwartungen an die mobilität strukturen
in deutschland zu erfüllen immer mehr
güter während transportiert die
individuellen mobilitätsansprüche die
steigen und auf der anderen seite müssen
wir aber auch die frage beantworten wie
wir die luft und lärm qualität in den
deutschen großstädten weiter verbessern
und natürlich auch den co2 ausstoß dem
verkehrsbereich reduzieren können und
für uns als cdu csu fraktion ist dabei
vollkommen klar
die antworten auf diese herausforderung
das sind nicht fahrverbote das ist nicht
gängelung und das sollen auch möglichst
nicht politische vorschriften seien wie
die bürger sich fortzubewegen oder zu
leben haben sondern wir wollen dass über
investition in die wissenschaft
technologische innovation und
unternehmertum erreichen und damit die
mobilität der menschen weiter verbessern
und auch unseren beitrag zum klimaschutz
leisten
dh investitionen schienenverkehr in den
öffentlichen nahverkehr investitionen
natürlich auch in die digitalisierung
des verkehrs um den verkehrsfluss zu
verbessern und staus zu reduzieren aber
es bedeutet natürlich auch dass wir in
neue antriebstechnologien investieren
müssen und es bedeutet auch dass wir in
synthetische kraftstoffe in wird
investieren müssen möglichst natürlich
aus erneuerbarer energie und mein
kollege drt brok hat er eben völlig zu
recht in seiner rede dargestellt dafür
brauchen wir natürlich vor allem auch
den ausbau von elektromobilität vor
allem auch dass das große ziel in dieser
legislaturperiode den weiteren ausbau
der infrastruktur für elektromobile
fahrzeuge aber wir dürfen unsere
verkehrspolitischen initiativen hier im
deutschen bundestag nicht nur auf
elektromobilität reduzieren ein solches
denken würde auch zu kurz greifen
sondern wir brauchen technologieoffene
lösung
und meine damen und herren dafür müssen
wir mehrere pfade beschreiten das ist
für uns gar keine frage eines entweder
oder sondern eher eines sowohl-als-auch
denn mit mehreren faden werden wir am
ende an ziel kommen und das bedeutet
natürlich auch co2 neutrale kraftstoffe
denn die vorteile von synthetischen
kraftstoffen möglichst eben aus
erneuerbaren energie wie elektro fuels
oder fuels die liegen auf der hand sind
nutzbar in verbrennungsmotoren global
transportierbar gut lagerbar und vor
allem auch kann die bestehende
infrastruktur genutzt werden und
deswegen müssen synthetische kraftstoffe
und vor allem auch us- ein wichtiger
baustein sein wenn wir über eine
künftige mobilitätsstrategie hier reden
aber ihre kollegin der fdp und auch der
afd
viel wichtiger als steuerliche
diskussion wäre es das potenzial
synthetischer kraftstoffe zu heben und
die synthetische kraftstoffe weiter in
die förder und forschungsprogramme
deutschlands einzubauen
da wurde ja eben freundlicherweise von
den kollegen der grünen gesagt da
passiert im moment schon eine ganze
menge
das wollen wir weiter vorantreiben und
und das ist ein richtiger punkt das
stimme ihn zu lieben kollegen der fdp
wir müssen natürlich auch auf
europäischer ebene dafür werben dass
synthetische kraftstoffe aus
erneuerbarer energie angerechnet werden
denn nur dann werden sich investitionen
fuels rentieren und dann werden die evs
eine chance auf dem markt haben
umgekehrt würde das natürlich auch die
deutsche automobilindustrie stärken wir
sollten alle als deutsche politiker
daran ein interesse haben und könnten so
könnten wir kluge wirtschafts- und
umweltpolitik kombinieren beitrag von
umweltschutz stärkung unserer industrie
mit synthetischen kraftstoffen oder es
ist das möglich neben wie eben gesagt
der elektromobilität und deswegen herr
präsident lassen sie mich das zum
abschluss sagen für die mobilität der
zukunft müssen wir verschiedene
maßnahmen in die wege leiten dazu zählen
investitionen in alternative antriebe
aber dazu zählen auch investitionen in e
views und synthetische kraftstoffe
das geht es in dieser legislaturperiode
weiter voranzutreiben herzlichen dank
unser plus war dass für die
cdu/csu-fraktion und einen redner mir
noch zu diesem tagesordnungspunkt der
abgeordnete mathias stein wird das seien
für die spd fraktion erst mit dem
verkehrsausschuss ja sehr geehrter herr
präsident liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir stehen in der verkehrspolitik vor
einer epochalen herausforderung der
verkehr wird steigen und gleichzeitig
müssen wir es schaffen die klimaziele
von paris einzuhalten die co2 werte im
bereich verkehr sind immerhin bei über
20 prozent und das großartige an dieser
ganzen sache ist dass wir bereits heute
technologien greifbar haben die es
ermöglichen eine vision von einem
klimaneutralen mobilität zu machen ohne
dass es sozial einschränkt oder
wirtschaftlich ausgrenzt aber wenn ich
mir jetzt die anträge angucke hier von
der rechten seite der opposition dann
stelle ich mir die frage ob man da in
zukunft tatsächlich gut aufgestellt ist
die afg hat als rezept erst mal retten
wir den verbrennungsmotor und das ist
natürlich so natürlich werden wir den
verbrennungsmotor eine ganze weile
brauchen aber wenn man sich genau dann
mal anguckt was dann in dem antrag steht
dann ist da sehr viel heiße luft drin
heiße luft sie gehen davon aus dass es
autos gibt die nur mit fuels
funktionieren wie wollen sie das denn
machen eben haben sie gesagt na ja da
kann man dann alles reinschmeißen das
ist eine zusätzliche steuerliche
subventionen die wir an dieser stelle
nicht haben wollen wir haben eine nicht
konkurrenzfähigen preis von vier euro 50
bei ihnen hatten sie bei ihnen hatten
sie neulich von zwei euro fünfzig
gesprochen aber das ist immer noch eine
erhöhung wie wollen sie das denn sozial
subventionieren also mehr als heiße luft
ist da nicht und nun kommen wir zur fdp
nun komme zur fdp der gasantrieb das ist
günstig gas ist verfügbar das ist super
deshalb haben wir auch in der letzten
wahlperiode durchgesetzt dass die cng
kraftstoff förderung verlängert wird das
heißt wir tun da etwas und aber wir
müssen doch die priorität darauf setzen
dass wir
rechtzeitig die nicht endlichen
energieträgern fördern und insofern
müssen wir glaube ich auch dort andere
schwerpunkte setzen
zur frage der forschungsförderung ist ja
auch hier schon viel gesagt worden sie
wollen wieder eulen nach athen tragen
ich empfehle ihnen die kleine anfrage
der kollegen von den grünen
dort ist aufgeführt von anfang februar
dass es drucksache 19 75 21 können sie
sich aufschreiben
dort ist detailliert hinterlegt sogar
die einzelnen firmen werden genannt was
dort gefördert wird insofern tun wir das
also mehr als stückwerk bist bei fdp und
hfg nicht zu entdecken und wir als große
koalition wir haben die voraussetzungen
dass wir tatsächlich diese
klimaschutzziele erreichen wir haben
eine plattform zukunft der mobilität
da haben wir jetzt auch beschlossen
glaube ich dass der vorsitzende
verkehrsausschuss und die
stellvertreterin da auch mit dabei sein
dürfen und ich glaube da werden wir
einiges erreichen und wir haben einen
guten koalitionsvertrag da würde es im
übrigen auch helfen wenn der
verkehrsminister ab und zu mal rein
guckt weil wir wollen ohne scheuklappen
und ohne denkverbote wollen wir die
mobilitäts wende sozialverträglich
umsetzen herzlichen dank sagt mathias
stein für die spd und hier ja wurde
diskutiert von if you es bis die autos
wie sieht der antrieb der zukunft aus
und jetzt hören wir erstmal mit die
zukunft diese anträge aussieht die in
die ausschüsse überwiesen werden sollen
ist jedoch strittig naja die fraktion
der cdu/csu und spd wünschen
federführung beim finanzausschuss die
fraktion der fdp später führung beim
ausschuss für verkehr und digitale
infrastruktur ich lasse zuerst
abstimmung über den verwaltungsvorschlag
der fraktion der ard federführung beim
ausschuss für verkehr und digitale
infrastruktur her stimmt diesen
verwaltungsvorschlag zu er stimmt
dagegen wer enthält sich keine dann ist
diese verwaltungsvorschlag gegen die
stimmen der fdp fraktion mit den stimmen
der übrigen fraktionen des hauses
abgelehnt ich hatte nun abstimmen und
verwaltungsvorstand der fraktionen der
cdu/csu und spd federführung beim
finanzausschuss wer stimmt diesen
überweisungs vorschlag zu
gegenprobe enthaltungen keine dann ist
dieser verwaltungsvorschlag gegen die
stimmen der fraktion mit den stimmen der
übrigen fraktionen des hauses angenommen
ja das kommt den parlamentarischen
verfahren ab und zu vor dass es
unterschiedliche ansichten darüber gibt
wo eine vorlage weiter behandelt wird im
parlamentarischen verfahren und sie
haben es gehört die fdp-fraktion im
wollte ihren eigenen antrag im
verkehrsausschuss behandelt sehen dort
werden unter anderem beispielsweise
andere schwerpunkte gesetzt wenn eine
solche vorlage beraten wird
aber die mehrheit des hauses hat hier
beschlossen das ganze an den
finanzausschuss zu gehen es geht in
diesem antrag ja beispielsweise auch um
energie und kfz-steuer deswegen also in
den finanzausschuss auch der fdp antrag
ist in die ausschüsse überwiesen hier
federführend an den verkehrsausschuss da
ging es ja auch technologie auf eine
förderung von alternativen antrieben so
wir kommen zum letzten thema dieses
tages dieser sitzungswoche
es soll gehen um soziale gerechtigkeit
und um maßnahmen wie beispielsweise
armut reduziert oder auch verhindert
werden kann die linke hat dazu einen
antrag vorgelegt mit einem ganzen bündel
von maßnahmen unter anderem gesetzlichen
mindestlohn auf 12 euro gehören jetzt
aber dazu ag ticker klöckner von der spd
fraktion
die kollegen der fraktion die linke für
diesen antrag denn sie geben uns hier
einmal mehr gelegenheit über ein
wichtiges thema zu sprechen armut
überall da wo armut ist muss politik
handeln ich sage aber auch gleichwohl
enthält ihr antrag einige klischees
wenn man den antrag soli ist gewinnt man
den eindruck als würde bei uns in
deutschland maßen verelendung wachsen
überdurchschnittlich viele menschen
ausgebeutet oder unter ganz schlechten
arbeitsbedingungen arbeiten ich finde
dieses bild ist zu drastisch denn wenn
man deutschland vergleicht im eu weiten
vergleich mit den übrigen
mitgliedstaaten zeichnet sich ein
anderes bild
wir haben eine sehr sehr gute
beschäftigungsquote die höchste seit er
wieder für
wir haben positive entwicklungen ball
nettolöhnen von vollzeitbeschäftigten
und es wird der politik bescheinigt dass
wir viel unternommen haben gegen armut
und arbeitslosigkeit
sie sehen deutschland ist besser als sie
es zeichen
ich will aber auch sagen nicht alle
menschen in diesem land partizipieren an
dieser positiven entwicklung
beispielhaft willich schnellen
rentnerinnen und rentner mit niedrigen
lebenserwartung kommen menschen mit
behinderungen alleinerziehende
langzeitarbeitslose und natürlich auch
deren kinder ja wir müssen einiges tun
und machen wir uns ehrlich kolleginnen
von der linken es wird und es wurde auch
vieles getan und ich will da auch noch
einmal auf einige beispiele eingehen
ich spiele nennen die brücken teilzeit
mit der es möglich ist dass nach einer
teilzeit phase die menschen wieder auf
vollzeit um zwischen können und es endet
natürlich vieles an den einkommen zum
positiven und hilft auf altersarmut
entgegenzuwirken
ich will auch einen sozialen
arbeitsmarkt
wir ermöglichen damit vielen menschen
die lange in arbeitslosigkeit verharren
wieder in arbeit zu kommen wir wollen
nicht die menschen in arbeitslosigkeit
verwalten wir wollen dass ich in arbeit
kommen und ich will nennen das starke
familien gesetzt dass wir auf den weg
gebracht haben das stärkt die familien
und wird der kinderarmut entgegen
ja um die spd-fraktion wien auch dass
bürger dass bürger werden wir wollen die
grundrente ohne bedürftigkeitsprüfung
das sind für uns wichtige schritte wir
wollen einen modernen sozialstaat ja da
ist für die menschen wenn sie ihn
brauchen wir wollen nicht dass menschen
zwischen ämtern und behörden umher
laufen müssen und wir wollen mitarbeiter
in den behörden
die genügend zeit haben damit sie sich
um die menschen kümmern können ihr
antrag
einige vorschläge wir haben ein
umfassendes konzept um den sozialstaat
zu modernisieren
ich denke kolleginnen kollegen der linke
es liegt auf der hand wir haben das
bessere konzept ihren antrag muss wir
leider ablehnen der spd hat ihr
sozialstaats konzept hier ihr neues
formel für 14 tagen vorgestellt der
linken antrag der grundlage dieser
debatte ist er ist indes schon vom april
2009 10 gleich in beiden übrigens sowohl
bei der spd also bei der linken die
forderung nach einem mindestlohn von
zwölf euro die stunde
hör jetzt für die afd martin gesichert
leider bewirkt die antrag genau das
gegenteil sie schaffen damit
systematisch armut sie wollen nein es
ist kein humburg das ist tatsache
sie haben in ihrem antrag drinstehen sie
wollen 1050 euro netto für jeden
erwachsenen in deutschland
damit schaffen sie das problem dass sie
das sozialsystem in deutschland für arme
menschen aus anderen ländern noch viel
attraktiver machen dass die zuwanderung
in unsere sozialsysteme nachlassen
abzunehmen wird sie schaffen wir wollen
328 euro kindergeld pro kind haben wir
geben jetzt schon hunderte millionen an
kindergeld in andere länder ab und das
wird sich vervielfachen wenn wir das
kinderrecht so deutlich erhöhen
in ihrem antrag haben sie gar nicht mehr
versucht darzustellen wie das alles
finanziert werden soll
das einzige was sie noch rein
geschrieben haben ist der nächste
sozialpolitische oder arbeitsrechtliche
schwachsinn ist nämlich die forderung zu
sagen wir wollen jetzt minijobs
sozialversicherungspflichtig machen
das heißt sie versuchen in allen
möglichen bereichen den leuten die
anreize wegzunehmen zu arbeiten und dass
arbeit sich wirklich lohnt wenn man auch
niedrig qualifiziert oder gering
qualifiziert ist
das fällt bei ihnen alles weg sie
fördern es dass immer mehr menschen vom
sozialstaat leben müssen und dass
diejenigen die unser land inzwischen
massenhaft verlassen nämlich die
hochqualifizierten menschen die menschen
die wirklich die leistungsträger in
unserem land sind die versionen sie
immer stärker zu belasten indem sie
einfach nur an
symptomen herumdoktern das ist
grundfalsch was wir machen müssen ist
eine echte vernünftige armutsbekämpfung
und das heißt dass wir den menschen in
dem zeitraum ihres erwerbslebens mehr
von ihrem geld lassen müssen vor 30 40
jahren
vor 30 40 jahren da konnte ein einfacher
arbeiter und dann einfacher angestellter
der konnte mit seinem gehalt seine
familie versorgen und er hatte auch noch
die möglichkeit nebenbei noch eine
immobilie zu erwerben sich selbst ein
haus zu bauen
davon sind wir heutzutage meilenweit
entfernt und warum sind wir meilenweit
davon entfernt weil die staatsquote
immer mehr erhöht wird weil den menschen
immer mehr geld aus der tasche gezogen
wird und weil man dieses geld dann her
nimmt um es als staatliche wohltaten zu
verteilen
diesen sozialismus sehen wir ab wir
sehen dass der sozialismus in
deutschland immer in den ruin geführt
hat sozialismus ist eine ideologie die
versucht zu versprechen wohlstand für
alle
wir schaffen die armut abzulösen eure
probleme in wahrheit schaffen sie aber
armut letztlich für alle und wir haben
in deutschland schon zweimal erlebt dass
der sozialismus dieses land ruiniert hat
wir werden es ein drittes mal nicht
zulassen
deswegen lehnen wir diesen antrag ab und
bitte tun sie uns einen gefallen hören
sie auf solche potpourri anträge zu
stellen wo sie irgendeinen mitarbeiter
wahrscheinlich haben der würfelt welche
sozialpolitischen forderungen die jetzt
wieder in einem paket zusammen spüren
machen sie mal was vernünftiges was
durchgerechnet uns was durchkalkuliert
ist dann können wir uns ja auch intensiv
wirklich mit einzelnen sinnvollen
förderungen beschaffen
aber diesen sozialistischen schwachsinn
braucht unser land nicht als nächster
redner erhält das wort der kollege dr
matthias zimmer cdu csu fraktion
er ist mitglied im ausschuss für arbeit
und soziales
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine damen und herren
der antrag den wir heute debattieren ist
fast ein jahr alt mittlerweile hat die
spd einige dieser forderungen übernommen
das sei nur festgestellt manchmal adelt
die zustimmung der spd eine sache hier
nicht
deswegen will ich für die union
festhalten erster die forderungen nach
einer erhöhung des mindestlohns auf 12
euro ist falsch sie ist falsch deshalb
weil wir die festsetzung der höhe des
mindestlohns einer kommission überlassen
haben aus gutem grund wir wollten
verhindern
wir wollten verhindern dass der
mindestlohn zum spielball politischer
interessen wird das ist nach wie vor
richtig und ich kann nicht verstehen
warum ihr kollegen von den
sozialdemokraten von diesem richtigen
schritt wieder abstand nehmen wollte die
forderung nach einer sanktionsfreie
mindestsicherung ist falsch sie wäre
nichts anderes als ein bedingungsloses
grundeinkommen ein staatliches gehalt
ohne gegenleistung das entwertet die
arbeit als quelle der entwicklung der
persönlichkeit es entwertet den menschen
das entwerte den menschen und macht ihn
zum bloßen empfänger staatlicher
transferleistungen wir wollen dass der
mensch selbst ständig ist er soll seinen
stolz darin empfinden sein leben
selbstverantwortlich zu gestalten und
dem start zu sagen ich brauche dich
nicht das ist ein wesentliches element
von freiheit die geschätzen und
verteidigen
die forderung nach der abschaffung sagt
und voser befristungen und der
weitgehenden einschränkungen der
leiharbeit ist falsch wir wollen
missbräuche unterbinden aber
flexibilisierung möglichkeiten erhalten
am ende ist es doch die leistungskraft
der wirtschaft die den sozialstaat
finanziert aber richtig ist auch ohne
einen funktionierenden stolz sozialstaat
wäre die wirtschaft weniger
leistungsfähig deswegen ist die soziale
marktwirtschaft auch immer als ironische
formel bezeichnet wurden als
friedensordnung fehlt dieser frieden
fehlen auf alle möglichkeiten des
wachstums und des wohlstands eine
bemerkung zum begriff der armut armut
wird definiert als eine situation der
ungleichheit wer weniger als 40 prozent
des medianeinkommens zur verfügung hat
gilt als arm
folglich kann man die armut nur
beseitigen wenn man die ökonomischen
formen der ungleichheit beseitigt und
spätestens hier wird klar
neben der statistischen dimensionen hat
der begriff armut auch die dimension
eines kampfbegriff er richtet sich im
namen der gleichheit gegen alle
ungleichheit nur in einer vollständig
egalitären gesellschaft gäbe es
allerdings dann keine armut mehr aber
eben auch keine freiheit
wir haben alle unterschiedliche anlagen
und talente gott sei dank wie dunkel
wäre diese welt wenn die entfaltung
dieser anlagen und talente im namen der
gleichheit unterdrückt würde die arme
wie aber wäre unsere welt wenn sich
leistung nicht lohnte anstrengung ins
leere liefen ja ungleichheit motiviert
sie inspiriert sie ist eine treibende
kraft technologische und wirtschaftliche
entwicklung
deswegen wollen wir die ungleichheit
nicht beseitigen wohl aber im rahmen der
wirtschafts und sozialordnung einhegen
und nutzbar machen und wir wollen dafür
sorgen dass die ungleichheit immer auf
die gerechtigkeit bezogen wird so
garantieren wir dass die ordnung der
wirtschaft auch als legitim angesehen
wird
ein letzter punkt der antrag fordert
eine sanktionsfreie mindestsicherung von
1050 euro
dazu wird man die bedarfssätze erhöhen
müssen werden diese erhöht haben auch
die menschen anspruch darauf die bisher
darunter lagen und nun darüber lagen und
nun darunter liegen die folge ist wir
haben mehr menschen mit einem anspruch
auf staatliche leistungen und meine
damen und herren wenn ich die dynamik
populistischer umverteilungs diskurse
richtig einschätzen wird genau dies dann
zum argument gewendet in deutschland
steigt die armut weil die anzahl der
leistungsbezieher steigt und dann werden
wir wieder eine debatte führen oder
vielleicht auch nicht wenn wir heute den
antrag der linken ablehnen was meine
fraktion zumindestens tun wird
herzlichen dank
vielen dank herr kollege der zimmer als
nächster redner das wort der kollege
pascal kober fdp fraktion bakuba ist
sehr sprecher für sozialpolitik
es ist ja nicht so dass es keine
sozialen probleme in deutschland gebe
keine herausforderung die wir als
politik nicht besser lösen können als
bisher aber ihre schwarz malerei liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der
linksfraktion hilft keinem und ist
letztlich selbst ein skandal denn wir
haben in dieser woche die studie der
bertelsmann stiftung zur kenntnis nehmen
müssen dass es den kindern in
deutschland gut geht
acht von zehn kindern aber ein eigenes
zimmer neun von zehn kinder haben da
einen eigenen ruhigen platz für sich und
die meisten kinder sagen auch dass ihm
materiell gut geht aber jedes zweite
kind sagt dass es angst vor armut hat
und das muss ja irgendwo herkommen und
es kommt genau von dieser
skandalisierung die sie hier immer
wieder in diesem deutschen bundestag
einbringen
[Applaus]
es ist unverantwortlich die sorgen und
ängste der menschen zu
instrumentalisieren das muss ich ihnen
leider vorhalten
und wenn man sich ihre forderungen
anschaut dann sind es ja die üblichen
beispielsweise wie armani die
manipulation der mindestlohn kommission
sie wollen ein politisch festgesetzten
mindestlohn dass sie das fordern ist ja
eines aber liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der spd dass sie dieser politik
jetzt hinterher laufen
das kann ich ihnen und wirklich nicht
empfehlen sie wissen doch selber dass
wenn sie bei 12 euro sind die kollegen
rasch bei 13 euro sein werden diesen
wettlauf werden sie nicht vor gewinnen
die bären sie verlieren
und was sie als aktions freie
mindestsicherung fordern liebe kollegen
der linksfraktion ist letztlich nichts
anderes als ein abschreiben der menschen
wenn sie nicht einmal mehr den menschen
zutrauen dass sie sich auch selber durch
mitwirkung um arbeit bemühen können und
sollen dann bedeutet das dass es sich
letztlich aufs abstellgleis schieben das
zeigt wie klein sie von diesen menschen
denken und das ist nicht in ordnung
viel wichtiger wäre es wenn wir statt
immer neuen forderungen nach höheren
transferleistungen endlich
beispielsweise einmal die
zuverdienstgrenzen im hartz-iv-system so
ausgestalten würden das auch wirklich
arbeit sich nun für die menschen wenn
wir das täten das hat gerade eine
seriöse studie vorgerechnet dann würden
wir sofort mit einem schlag gerade zu
300.000 menschen neu in arbeit bringen
können das ist die richtige politik die
politik des liberalen bürgergeldes wie
wir es als fdp-forderung eine
alleinerziehende frau mit drei kindern
sie hätte nach unserem modell was wir
gestern vorgestellt haben nach dem
modell des liberalen bürgergeldes im
monat 370 euro
das ist wirkliche hilfe wenn wir den
menschen mehr netto vom brutto erlauben
wenn anstrengungen sich lohnt dann
arbeiten sich die menschen heraus aus
ihrer situation das wäre auch ein
bericht wirklicher jobmotor wie es eben
gerade geschrieben habe und deshalb
fordere ich die bundesregierung auf
handeln sie jetzt nehmen sie die
zuverdienstgrenzen in angriff das ist
eine leichte möglichkeit vielen menschen
mehr geld im portemonnaie zugelassen und
mehr gerechtigkeit in diesem land zu
herzustellen vielen dank pascal kober
war das für die fdp fraktion
er hat gesagt die üblichen forderungen
der linken sieht er in diesem antrag den
die fraktion vorgelegt hat der antrag
ist allerdings schon vom april letzten
jahres können wir mal was pascal leyser
von der linken es dazu sagt ich frage
mich schon was läuft eigentlich verkehrt
wenn man im reichen land wie deutschland
fast 14 millionen menschen von armut
betroffen sind hat die zahl der
millionäre und milliardäre von jahr zu
jahr immer weiter steigt was läuft
eigentlich verkehrt in deutschland das
es inzwischen mehr als fünf millionen
menschen gibt die sich nicht jeden tag
eine vollwertige mahlzeit leisten können
ich finde mit sozialer gerechtigkeit hat
das alles doch nichts zu tun aber
wirklich gar nichts mehr liebe kollegen
pak ist die armut in diesem land nimmt
zu und das obwohl die wirtschaft brummt
und die zahl der arbeitslosen sinkt
millionen menschen deren gnadenlos vom
wohlstand im land abgehängt das ist und
bleibt für uns als linke inakzeptabel
fakt ist auch die größte anteil der von
armut betroffenen menschen sind
erwerbstätig sind arm trotz arbeit
zu diesem erschreckenden ergebnis kommt
zum beispiel letzte armutsbericht des
paritätischen gesamtverbandes da ist die
bäckerei verkäuferin um die ecke da sind
die lkw fahrer da sind die
reinigungskräfte übrigen zur großen
schande dieses hauses leider auch die
die tagtäglich so zuverlässig unser
aller bundestagsbüros putzen da sind
noch viele mehr
aber es sind auch die renten und renten
hat im alter in armut leben und flaschen
sammeln müssen und natürlich die
erwarten
loosen die hartz 4 beziehen und dann
hören oder lesen diese menschen die
kanzlerin verkündet deutschland geht es
gut oder ähnliche sätze von bleiben dass
schönheit oder sie müssen sich diese
debatte an
insbesondere das was aus der rechten
ecke hier über armut erzählt haben sie
eigentlich die geringste in der
vorstellung was das bei denjenigen
auslöst die selbst in armut leben müssen
viele verlieren so das vertrauen in die
politik manche sogar die demokratie und
das doch etwas was uns alle uns alle
hier mit großer sorge erfüllen sollte
so vielfältig wie die gesichter so
unterschiedlich sind auch die gründe für
die wachsende armut deshalb genügt ist
auch nicht an einzelnen symptomen
herumzudoktern wie dass diese
bundesregierung beständig tut liebe
kollegen klöckner
wir brauchen endlich ein umfassendes
programm zur bekämpfung der armut in
deutschland wie es mit unserem antrag
vorgelegt habe dazu gehört zuallererst
dafür zu sorgen dass diejenigen die hart
arbeiten nach noch anständig leben
können
deshalb lassen sie uns endlich für einen
armutsfesten gesetzlichen mindestlohn
von 12 euro sorgen und für konsequenten
und für konsequente maßnahmen zur
erhöhung der tarife lasst uns dafür
sorgen dass die gesetzliche rente wieder
vor armut im alter schützt mit einem
rentenniveau von 53 prozent wie es vor
der unsäglichen riester reform hatten
aber mit einem ausgleich für
niedriglöhne bei der berechnung der
rente der auch geringverdiener all
seinen wurde erlaubt universitäten sie
ist ernst meinen da haben sie unsere
unterstützung auch in auseinandersetzung
mit der union liebe kollegen schließlich
wollen sie damit auf die hartz 4 sätze
künstlich kleinzurechnen und menschen
noch das notwendigste zum leben durch
sanktionen zu streichen lassen sie uns
stattdessen endlich eine armutsfeste
mindestsicherung schaffen für all
diejenigen die erwerbslos sind und die
genauso wie alle anderen ein recht auf
ein leben in würde
und wenn auch sie das vertrauen in die
politik wieder herstellen wollen dann
gibt es nur eins dann lassen sie uns
endlich den sozialstaat diesem land
wieder stärken und zwar so dass er
tatsächlich und umfassend gegen armut
schützt vielen dank pascal leyser war
das für die linksfraktion ja weniger
armut mehr soziale gerechtigkeit das hat
sich die linke hier in ihrem antrag
formuliert jetzt auch schon vom
vergangenen jahr ist aber natürlich
immer noch gültigkeit hat linken
forderungen übrigens die spielen auch
eine rolle
an diesem wochenende auf dem
europaparteitag der linken der beginnt
nämlich heute in bonn und noch ein
hinweis vielleicht dann in eigener sache
wir werden natürlich über diesen
europa-parteitag berichten auch
beispielsweise heute abend um 17 30 in
phoenix der tag ja das war schon das
schlusswort zu dieser tage zu diesem
tagesordnungspunkt und unserer
berichterstattung von dieser plenarwoche
des deutschen bundestages ich darf mich
hier aus der sprecherkabine von ihnen
verabschieden und sagen auf wiedersehen
bleiben sie bei phoenix
phoenix persönlich künstliche
intelligenz und datenanalyse werden die
medizin in zukunft mehr verändern als
jemals zuvor
michael de ridder ist internist werden
wir denn ärzte überhaupt der zukunft
brauchen wir werden sie ganz sicher
brauchen trotz all der verheißungen die
im raume stehen bei die bewältigung von
krankheiten empathischen kompetenten
arzt braucht der den